halbe Stunde früher als sonst. Mal gucken, ob schon genug Leute Vogue sind dafür.
Jetzt können wir gleich mal überprüfen, ob unser Background-Change-Script funktioniert.
Wallpaper, Wallpaper-Change-Script, ob das jetzt einen Sunrise-Hintergrund anzeigt.
Mein, es ist vor neun, müsste es eigentlich. Okay, da ist noch von gestern. Wallpaper.s.
Am Moment, da ist noch Nacht. Oh, mein Script ist gebrochen. Value to create for base.
Okay. Okay, der denkt noch, dass Nacht ist, unser Wallpaper-Changer.
Nun gut, scheint ein bisschen verbackt zu sein, was wir da gebastelt haben.
Das ist für ein paar Runden, ist das wirklich nice. Kann man immer mal so zwischendurch
spielen. Ist zwar komplett sinnlos im Endeffekt, aber zumindest bis man die Waffen anlockt hat,
kann man spielen, danach ist. Also ich glaube nicht, dass jetzt irgendwie das
neueste, das nächste Hype-Game irgendwie draus wird, aber ja.
Jetzt sind Stunden ja länger, als man bei den meisten anderen Games die Kampagne braucht.
Aber man kann das eh. Es ist eh so eine Diskussion, die man eigentlich sich nicht geben braucht.
So wie viel ist quasi die Minute Spielzeit wert. Also macht ja eigentlich keinen Sinn.
Wichtig ist, dass einem das Game am Schluss gefallen hat und je nachdem was für ein Game
ist, sind dann welche, die sind nach ein paar Stunden vorbei oder welche, da kannst du 100
oder 1000 Stunden spielen. Das kann ich mir vorstellen. Ich denke, kann man so pauschal
gar nicht sagen, was da angemessen ist. Weil ansonsten führt es dazu, wenn Spielzeit das
wichtigste ist, dass die Hersteller den Ubisoft-Trick machen und an jeder Ecke irgendeine Kiste,
irgendeinen Aussichtsturm, irgendwelche super sinnlosen Generic 0815 Aufgaben wahrscheinlich
auch noch irgendwie random generated reinpacken. Hauptsache, um künstlich die Spielzeit zu
strecken. Das braucht ja auch im Endeffekt keiner. Seit Freitag laufen bei mir keine
Windows Server bzw. Hyper-V mehr. Das ist sehr gut. Windows, Windows. Umso weniger Windows,
umso besser. Proxmox. Proxmox habe ich mir schon angeguckt. Hat sich für mich jetzt
nicht angeboten daheim, als reine Virtualisierungslösung.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass Broadcom auch nur ansatzweise genug Geld hat, um Vmware zu kaufen.
Ich meine, Vmware ist ein riesen Ding. Für wieviel wollen die denn bitteschön kaufen?
Ich habe sogar einen Key. Guck mal. X. Nee, aber ich habe einen Key und sogar runtergeladen.
Ubisoft Connect heißt es. Ich glaube, ich habe es nur vom anderen Account installiert.
Ich habe das sogar schon runtergeladen. Ich habe 30 Minuten Stream im Hintergrund laufen
lassen und habe es runtergeladen. Schon vor zwei Tagen oder so. Und habe es noch nicht
gespielt. Ich glaube, die Beta geht bis zum 23. oder 19. Irgendwie sowas. Ja, vielleicht
gucke ich nochmal rein. Ich habe nicht so Bock, mir ein neues Shooter Game anzugucken.
Aber ich habe halt mal einen Stream laufen lassen, wo ich einen Key habe. Muss man eigentlich
sich heute angucken, weil heute ist Sonntag. Da sind bestimmt auch die ganzen Noobs am
Start. Also dann hat man einen besseren Einstieg, weil man ist ja selber noch Noob.
Wie sieht es mit CS 2 jetzt eigentlich aus? Ich meine, das 2 zu nennen ist eh schon ein
bisschen fragwürdig. CS 1 war quasi 1.6. Was war dann Source und CS GO, wenn das jetzt 2 ist?
Ja, die Benahmung. Es gibt relativ wenig Sinn. Aber gut, ich meine, was kommt denn das raus?
Neue Engine. Ja, ich weiß ja nur, die Versionsnummer macht ja keinen Sinn. Aus Marketing-Sicht
macht die natürlich Sinn. Weil die Leute von heute wenigen was interessiert die 1.6.
Oder irgendwelche anderen Sachen, die davor waren. Das ist doch komplett unbedeutend für die.
CS GO ist das Ding, was heute 95% der Leute gleichsetzen mit CS. Also es ergibt schon
Sinn, dass es dann 2 heißt. Ist es jetzt eigentlich Open Beta oder immer noch Closed? Oder braucht man
random Gaben Glück, dass man das bekommt? Ja, die haben es auch aufgegeben. Aber im Ernst,
es ist gar nicht so verwirrend, wie man denkt. Weil viele, die Modern Warfare 2 gespielt haben,
man darf ja nicht vergessen, das war 2009, wo das rauskam. Die interessieren sich heute überhaupt
nicht mehr für Call of Duty. Für die ist Modern Warfare 2 Modern Warfare 2. Die haben da überhaupt
keine Berührungspunkte. Also die Einzigen, die das noch mitbekommen haben, sind Teile der Streamer-
Generation von heute, die damals quasi frisch angefangen hat mit und heute irgendwie krass im
Content Creator Game am Start ist. Die sind eingestiegen mit dem originalen MW2 und für
die ist es vielleicht ein bisschen verwirrend, aber für viele andere gar nicht mehr. Guck mal,
ich hatte 2009 nicht mal den YouTube-Channel und ich bin auch schon ewig auf YouTube.
Also ich glaube, ich glaube, also ja, es ist verwirrend, aber ich glaube für viele Leute
gar nicht mal. Aber ich finde trotzdem, kann ich vielleicht noch mal sagen, auch wenn das
Marketing technisch sicherlich ein guter Schachzug war, wenn man sich mal anguckt,
wie gut sich das verkauft hat. Zumindest das MW1 hat sich mega gut verkauft, auch schon das
originale. COD 4 hat sich mega gut verkauft, aber ich glaube 2019 war eines der best verkauft,
wenn nicht das best verkaufte. Hat SSL Probleme? Nö, ich mache ja nur die DNS-Sachen. Ich kann da
nichts für. Was soll ich machen? Ich habe ja nur die DNS-Dinger umgezogen.
Also ich weiß jetzt nicht, was ich da machen kann. Ja, also aus Marketing-Sicht mag das
sicherlich eine gute Idee gewesen sein, aber unterm Strich muss ich sagen, es ist immer noch,
ich habe schon oft gesagt, komplett die Bankrotterklärung, also die Kreative.
Das war sie da jetzt abziehen mit MW1, 2. Ich glaube, die sind immer noch traurig,
dass sie MW3 damals quasi, dass sie so einen Schlussstrich drunter gezogen haben,
dass sie damals nicht schon MW4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9 machen konnten. Die wollten ja Ghosts machen dann.
Ghosts war ja quasi der Auftakt einer neuen Reihe. Nur mit dem Unterschied, Ghosts wurde so schlecht
bewertet gemacht überall und wahrscheinlich hat es noch so wenig Geld gemacht, dass es nie ein
Ghosts 2, 3 gab. Ghosts war das, wer sich nicht mal daran erinnern kann, Ghosts war das,
wo der Hund sich durch die Tür gesprengt hat. Wo ich auch gedacht habe, was jetzt drehen sie
komplett durch. Was macht eigentlich die Microsoft? Was macht eigentlich die
Microsoft Activision-Übernahme? Games endlich Bewegung. Okay, was sagt die GameStar? Es war
schon 14 Tage oder 3 Wochen her. Okay, also anscheinend dürfen sie jetzt oder dürfen sie nicht?
Draus habe ich nicht viel gespielt. Ich überlege gerade, was das letzte Diablo 4 Beta-Fazit,
ja mein Jungs. Jetzt bitte leise mal. Skippen das einfach. Okay, doch. Was war das Letzte,
was ich wirklich gespielt habe? Alter, es gibt so viele. Guckt euch das an. Guckt euch das an.
Da fehlen da noch ein paar, oder? Das alles? Okay, also was war das Letzte, was ich gespielt habe?
Alles noch gespielt? Auch alles noch gespielt? Ich glaube tatsächlich. Also Advanced Warfare habe
ich auch noch ein paar Stunden gespielt. Jetzt nicht super krass. Ja, wahrscheinlich war das
Letzte, was ich gespielt habe so richtig. Ich glaube, das Letzte, was ich mir gekauft habe,
wobei das stimmt nicht. Modern Warfare habe ich mir auch gekauft, ein bisschen gespielt. World War
Tour habe ich auch gekauft. Also Black Ops 4 hatte ich glaube ich gar nicht. Weiß nicht. Zumindest
so richtig. Also aufgehört zu spielen habe ich tatsächlich auch so bei diesen zwei hier. Das
lag aber auch daran, dass zwei in Folge gesackt haben. Ghost hat mir nicht gefallen und Advanced
Warfare hat mir auch nicht groß zugesagt und danach war die Luft raus. Zwei Jahre in Folge
Luft raus. Die beste Zeit zum Spielen für mich war eindeutig die hier. Aber ich meine es nutzt
sich ja auch ab. Man ist ja auch klar, es ist irgendwo immer dasselbe. Ja und die Sachen,
die dir auf den Sack gehen, sind auch immer die gleichen Sachen, die einem auf den Sack gehen.
Also insofern irgendwann ist die Luft raus und ich glaube, das geht halt auch allen Spielern so
in einem gewissen Kreislauf dann halt so. Also bei mir war das halt hier so und jetzt geht es vielen
hier so. Jetzt geht es vielen hier so, dass für sie die Luft raus ist und wo sie halt viel gekreidet
haben. Danach ist langsam die Luft raus und man merkt halt, dass die Dinge, die einen nerven,
halt jedes mal die gleichen Dinge sind und sich nichts ändert großartig. Und bei der
nächsten Gamer-Generation geht es dann halt wieder von vorne los. Wie wäre es denn,
wenn die nicht in BF4 neu machen, sondern wenn die einfach ein gutes neues Battlefield rausbringen?
Was haltet ihr denn davon, wenn sie nicht einfach remastern, sondern ein gutes neues rausbringen,
was ja anscheinend aktuell ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit zu sein scheint, wenn man sich 2042 anguckt.
Was macht eigentlich Level Cap so?
Level Cap macht keine G-Bade-Videos mehr.
So startest du dein Smart Home in 2003. Das können wir uns nachher mal angucken,
mal gucken, was er sagt. Letztes Mal habe ich ihm ja nicht so zugestimmt bei dem Video.
Das stimmt schon irgendwo, wenn man sich anguckt, wie verschissen oder wie verkackt sie es haben,
weil es hat sich ja abgezeichnet. Video über den Assi-Tony. Hat da wirklich irgendjemand,
der asozialste Typ? Also ich sage euch, der Assi-Tony wäre heute eines der größten Influencer in
Deutschland. Der von damals. Heute ist der Typ ja aber älter als ich, glaube ich. Heute hätte
er mega Stonks machen können im Internet. Der war einfach 5 bis 10 Jahre zu früh.
Sehe ich genauso. Also allgemein bin ich der Meinung, es wäre besser gewesen. Sie hätten
Battlefield 3 noch für ein Jahr weiter supportet. Es gab ja genug Möglichkeiten. Battlefield 4 hätte
nicht diese großen Probleme beim Launch gehabt und man hätte Battlefield 4 noch verfeinern können,
dass es ein wirklich eigenständiges Game war. Es war ja für viele, zumindest hat sich damals so
angefühlt, nur ein Battlefield 3 abklatscht, wenn auch ein erweiterter. Es gäbe durchaus
mehr Feiner in Battlefield 4 als in Battlefield 3. Auch ein paar Sachen, die besser waren,
auch ein paar Sachen, die schlechter waren. Zum Beispiel, dass es keine Suppression mehr gab,
fand ich prinzipiell ganz gut. Ansonsten ist es zu lang her, ich kann mich gar nicht mehr großartig
erinnern, was jetzt da die genauen Unterschiede gewesen sind. Außer der Blaufilter und sowas.
Also es wäre besser gewesen und was halt wirklich besser gewesen wäre, es hat sich bei Battlefield
1 schon ein bisschen abgezeichnet. Aber Battlefield 5 und jetzt 2042 hat man gesehen, dass die
Vermutungen damals schon einen wahren Kern hatten und sich als wahr herausgestellt haben, nämlich,
dass DICE zunehmend die Leute verliert, die wissen, wie man ein gutes Battlefield macht,
das hat man ja damals schon vermutet. Also auch schon bei Battlefield 4 und vor allem beim Übergang
dann zu Battlefield 1. Es ist immer noch technisch sehr gut gemacht und alles, aber so ein bisschen
vermisse ich gerade, was das Mapdesign angeht, eben Battlefield Map. Und es hat sich ja dann bewahrheitet
und dann kam noch ihre Arroganz dazu, so nach dem Motto, wir haben eigentlich keine Ahnung,
aber wir können uns das nicht eingestehen und erzählen lieber allen anderen, sie sind planlos
und ahnungslos und sie sollen es ja nicht kaufen, wenn sie Scheiße finden. Mit dem ziemlich blödem
Ausgang für DICE, dass die Leute es auch gemacht haben. Ich meine, wie dumm kann man als Marketing
Mensch eigentlich sein, wo man ja wieder denken müsste, dass die wissen, was sie machen. Wie
dumm kann man als Marketing Mensch sein, ernsthaft Millionen potenzieller Käufer zu erzählen. Ihr
seid blöd und kauft es halt einfach nicht. Das war ja so unterm Strich die Aussage. Selbst wenn das
stimmt, was ja durchaus sein kann, will ich nicht sagen, dass die Leute unbedingt immer so zu den
schlauesten gehören. Selbst wenn das so ist, ist das eine sehr blöde Variante, es so den Leuten
direkt aufs Brot zu schmieren. Ich auch, ich habe es auch nicht gekauft. Doch, ich habe es gekauft,
vergesst sich am Mist erzählen, ich habe es dann irgendwann doch gekauft. Was mich wieder in meiner
grundsätzlichen Annahme bestärkt, dass gerade der Marketing bzw. Online Marketing, nennt man das
Business Sektor, kann man das so nennen, so dieser Marketing, im Social Media wird man das Bubble
nennen, so dieser Business Sektor für Online Marketing, dass das eigentlich nur zum größten
Teil, es gibt Ausnahmen, aber zum größten Teil ein riesen Haufen aus unfähigen Selbstdarstellern
ist und das ziemliches Scam Business ist. Also, die fähigen Marketingleute, die ich in so 13 Jahren
jetzt YouTube, Social Media und Zeug kennengelernt habe, kannst du an einer Hand abzählen, fünf
Leute. Ich rede damit, ich rede davon explizit so von Online Influencer Marketing, nicht Leute,
die jetzt vielleicht in irgendeiner Newsseite arbeiten und dort Werbeanzeigen auswählen oder
sowas in der Richtung, das heißt nicht unbedingt, sondern wirklich so Influencer Marketing-Agenturen
und sowas auch. Leute, das ist ein Meer aus Dummschwätzern, das ist wirklich eine Flut aus
Dummschwätzern, die eigentlich absolut keine Ahnung hat davon, was sie machen. Was übrigens
normal für diese Branche ist, also die haben alle keine Ahnung, was sie machen. Ich gebe auch zu,
ich verstehe auch, dass es schwierig ist, da in die Zukunft zu schauen, das ist ja das,
was man oftmals von Marketing-Leuten will, so nach dem Motto, sag uns mal, was gut laufen wird,
aber da wird so viel Dummzeug geschwätzt, das ist echt nicht mehr normal. Und die verkaufen die
auch alle ihre Oma, ohne mit der Wimper zu zucken, na alle nicht, aber viele, viele verkaufen ihre
Mutter, ihre Oma und ihr Erstgeborenes verkaufen für Appel und Ei. Also das sind ganz viele
Dummschwätzer, sehr, sehr viele Scammer am Start. Also mit Scammer meine ich jetzt nicht mal Leute,
die quasi, so wie kann man es sagen, so kriminell betrügen wollen die Leute. Doch schon, eigentlich
schon. Also mit Scammer, mit Scammer im Online-Marketing-Business meine ich eigentlich
eher Leute, die dir wissentlich, also mittlerweile erkennt man es ja, relativ schnell, die dir
wissentlich komplett realitätsferne Sachen versprechen und sich am Ende selbst nicht dran
halten. Fragt mal irgendeinen x-beliebigen Coach oder, ja wie nennt man das hier, Teammanager,
was auch immer, aus dem E-Sports-Bereich. Die können euch alle ein Lied von singen. Ich hab
das von so vielen gehört, dass es einfach nur Scam links und rechts ist, was Marketing-Scam
angeht. Und gerade auch intern in E-Sport-Organisationen, wie da gescampt wird,
da werden Spieler nicht bezahlt, die machen Verträge mit den Spielern. Pass mal auf,
das ist jetzt kein Nutz, das habe ich mehrfach mitgekriegt. Die machen Verträge, also E-Sport,
E-Sport-Organisation XY macht einen Vertrag mit einem Spieler, es ist egal für was, CSGO,
Valorant, es ist egal, das Spiel macht eigentlich keinen Unterschied. So, also E-Sport-Organisation
XY macht einen Vertrag mit dem Spielern, es ist kein Witz, wie gesagt, das habe ich mehrfach mitgekriegt.
Machen Verträge mit Spielern oder mit Spielern und dann spielt der Spieler Vollzeit für die oder
Teilzeit, meistens geht es ja darum, dass die Spieler irgendwie überleben können. Die Spieler
Gehälter, wenn wir jetzt nicht gerade um Top-Level-Counter-Strike oder sowas reden,
sind jetzt wirklich nicht hoch. Also da werden teilweise Spieler mit 20k im Jahr abgespeist
also die können dafür gerade mal Essen kaufen. Gut, man könnte sagen, da wo kein Geld zu holen ist,
steckt man auch kein Geld rein, aber es ist teilweise schon ein extremes Scam-Niveau,
allein schon teilweise die Gehälter. So, aber jetzt kommt der Hit, was ich auch schon mehrfach
erlebt habe, die machen Verträge mit Spielern, so nach dem Motto, wir bezahlen dir so und so viel
im Jahr oder so und so viel Monatsgehalt, dass du für uns Vollzeit spielst und wisst ihr was
dann irgendwann passiert, wenn die merken, oder die suchen sich das ja explizit so raus,
wenn die merken, dass die Spiele abhängig von ihnen sind, weil sie jetzt beispielsweise keinen
normalen Job haben, weil sie ja Vollzeit für die Spiele. Also es gibt ja durchaus Spieler,
die sagen dann ok, ich gebe hier meine Regaleinräumtätigkeit beim Lidl oder
sonst wo auf und werde jetzt Vollzeitspieler für euch, ihr bezahlt mir ein Gehalt und wenn
die merken, dass die Spiele abhängig von ihnen sind, dann bezahlen sie kein Gehalt mehr oder
bezahlen das Gehalt nur noch unter irgendwie geänderten Auflagen, die nicht im Vertrag
drinne stehen oder bezahlen irgendwann gar nichts mehr. Hab ich mehrfach mitgekriegt und dann sagen
sie, ja gut, verklage uns doch. Dazu kommt, dass das oftmals nicht mit Spielern aus Deutschland
gemacht wird, ich will nicht sagen, dass es mit deutschen Spielern auch passiert, aber ich hab
beispielsweise mit osteuropäischen Spielern mehrfach mitbekommen, dass sie dann einfach sagen,
ja gut, du bist jetzt abhängig von uns, wir bezahlen dich nicht mehr, verklage uns halt,
wenn es dir nicht passt. Und dann wissen die Spieler nicht, was sie machen sollen,
sie haben keinen Job, sie haben sich darauf verlassen, dass die Organisation sich an ihren
Vertrag hält, machen sie nicht und dann müssen sie quasi unter anderen Bedingungen, die nicht
im Vertrag geregelt sind, dort weitermachen in der Hoffnung, dass sie irgendwann ihr Geld bekommen,
die sagen dann zum Spieler, ja, wir bezahlen dir jetzt kein Geld, es steht zwar nicht in unserem
Vertrag, aber ja, du kannst doch sicherlich nächste Woche mal auf eigene Kosten zu dem
Event fahren, oder? Und wenn ihr gut abschneidet, dann kriegst du auch dein Geld. Solche Dinger
werden da gemacht. Leute, glaube ich, diese, also eSport, Marketing, sonst was, das ist ein
unglaublich, das wird nie, das wird selten publik so diskutiert, das müsste eigentlich viel öfter das
Public mal auch, ja, bekannt gemacht werden. Das ist so ein menschenverachtendes Scambusiness,
das ist nicht normal, weil ich da schon die letzten Jahre über alles mitgekriegt hab und die lachen
dich, die Marketing und die eSport Leute dort, die lachen dich an, auf einem Auge und ficken dich,
aber sowas von auf der anderen Seite, ohne mit der Wimper zu zucken, das ist eine der schlimmsten
Arten von Menschen, die euch vorstellen können. Macht nie was, macht nie was in dieser, in dieser
Richtung. Warum werden die scheiß Orgas nicht geleakt? Ja oftmals, weil die Spiele Angst haben,
beziehungsweise die Leute, die daran beteiligt sind, weil die Angst davor haben. Stell dir mal vor,
du bist abhängig, du bist abhängig davon, dass du, was du essen bekommst, oder das, teilweise haben
ja Spiele auch noch angehören oder sonst was. Also es kommt ja manchmal vor, es kommt, es kommt ja
manchmal vor, dass was geleakt wird, ja, dann ist der Aufschrei immer groß. Ich meine, ich weiß nicht,
ob ihr mitbekommen habt, das ist ein ganz anderes Beispiel, dass in irgendeiner hessischen Stadt
irgendwie 6000 polnische LKW-Fahrer jetzt gestreikt haben und stehen bleiben wollten,
bis sie kein Geld bekommen haben, ja. Sowas in der Richtung kommt ja im kleinen Rahmen oftmals auch
im E-Sport vor, bei irgendwelchen Orgas, die total verkacken. Und die Spieler haben schlicht
und ergreifend Angst davor. Außerdem, was auch noch, was auch noch dazukommt, also die
Spieler haben Angst davor, auch aus finanzieller Sicht. Und was auch noch dazukommt, viele Spieler
sind dann auch noch sehr jung. Die sind dann teilweise gerade 18, nicht mal 18, 19, 20 und
haben halt außer diesem bisschen Gehalt von der Organix. So, wenn jetzt die Auswahl hast,
du kriegst doch noch irgendwie dein Geld und hältst die Fresse oder du machst groß auf
Dings, fügst dir ein bisschen Marketingschaden zu und du kriegst nie dein Geld, dann sagen halt
viele, ich halte die Klappe. Ich habe einigen schon angeboten sogar, wir können darüber mal
öffentlich reden. Wollten die meisten nicht. Ansatzweise ist es vielleicht mal schon ein
bisschen angeklungen. Aber ich glaube so wirklich, ich habe doch nicht, also wie gesagt,
ich habe es manchen angeboten, wir können natürlich mal öffentlich darüber reden,
aber die meisten wollten nicht. Und das kann ich verstehen, aus denen ihrer Sicht. Also glaubt
es mir, man kann sich gar nicht vorstellen, was das für ein Sumpf ist, wenn du nicht gerade für
Top Tier CS Teams oder so spielst. Und ich würde mich nicht wundern, wenn es auch in Top Tier Teams
bei jetzt vielleicht nicht so prestigeträchtigen Games ähnlich abgeht. Ich kann da wenig zu sagen,
da müsste ich halt, da müsste ich schon mal zwei Leute einladen, von denen ich weiß,
dass die ja viel darüber sagen können. Ich weiß nicht, ob die da was zu sagen wollen.
Na ja gut, es ist wirklich Ultra-Scam. Wie findest du die CS2 Beta? Ich habe die CS2 Beta nicht
gespielt. Bei der ESL? Ja klar. Die ESL ist sicherlich noch eines der besseren Läden,
die haben aber selbst genug Historie von nicht bezahlten Preisgeldern und solche
Geschichten. Wobei, also das ist, zumindest habe ich die letzten Jahre nichts Negatives
mehr gehört in der Richtung. Aber ich muss auch ehrlich sagen, ich hatte wenig, wenig
Schnittmenge mit Teams, die irgendwie ESL-Probleme hatten. Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nichts zu.
Zumindest läuft da im Hintergrund allgemein viel, viel Zeug. Egal. Also ich kann nur sagen,
ich habe schon einige Leute angeboten, wir können da mal öffentlich darüber reden und in einem
Video, auch zu Zeiten, wo ich noch ein bisschen mehr Gaming gemacht habe. Aber die meisten wollten
nicht. Also lasst euch, Fazit ist, unabstrich, lasst euch von keinem Online-Influenz-Marketing-Typ
irgendwas erzählen. Ihr könnt, es sei denn, ihr kennt ihn schon jahrelang und wisst, dass ihr
euch darauf verlassen könnt. Die verkaufen euch ihre Oma heute und morgen bescheißen sie euch.
Das ist ganz normale Business-Praktik dort. Also glaubt einfach nichts, was die euch erzählen.
Glaubt das prinzipiell erst, wenn ihr das Schwarz auf Weiß stehen habt. Ich habe auch schon öfters
erlebt, dass in Verträgen komische Dinger drin standen und wenn du dann gesagt hast,
wie jetzt, ihr wollt Rechte daran, ihr wollt Rechte daran, Moment, ihr wollt Rechte für mein
Logo auf unbestimmte Zeit und was auch immer da teilweise für Dinger drin standen. Da haben
die dann darauf geantwortet, nach dem Motto, ach Max, macht ihr keine Gedanken darüber. Wir
verwenden das eh nur für die Kampagne, so sind unsere Verträge halt geschrieben. Und wenn einer
euch sowas antwortet, so nach dem Motto, macht euch keine Gedanken, so sind unsere Verträge halt
geschrieben, unterschreibt den Scheiß nicht. Ich habe mich einmal scammen lassen. Nehme ich sowas
unterschrieben, aber nie wieder. Also insofern oder wenn euch einer, wenn einer nicht auf eure
Bedenken eingeht und bzw. euch genau erklären kann, wie sie das jetzt meinen und euch diese
Erklärung überzeugt, unterschreibt das nicht. Auch wenn die Kohle teilweise verlockend klingt.
Ich habe auch schon, was ihr auch machen könnt ist, wenn ihr, wenn ihr Verträge bekommt,
ihr könnt auch Sachen durchstreichen, das ist vollkommen legitim. Ihr könnt auch Sachen
durchstreichen und sagen, ok, ich schreibe das nur so. Und oftmals, wenn es die anderen Seiten
ernst meinen, dann kommt man da auch zu einer Einigung. Ja. Hab mal mit einer bekannten
League-Organisation zusammen gehabt, da fehlt immer noch ein Viersteg. Das ist normal. Das ist
genau das, was ich meine. Ich kenne jemanden, der hat mehrere Valorant-Teams gemanagt und
die wollten die Teams zu Events schicken. Also es ist jetzt nichts international Tier 1, aber ich
würde sagen, Europäisch schon vorne mit dabei. Die waren die Teams zumindest. Und was ich da
mitbekommen habe, das ist echt nicht normal. Also von Events, wo sie hinfahren sollten und
die Fahrtkosten nicht erstattet wurden, obwohl gesagt wurde, die Fahrtkosten werden erstattet.
Also ich weiß, dass der Manager von diesen Teams, der hat teilweise noch tausende Euro,
die er nie wieder gesehen hat, weil er Essen kaufen musste für die Spieler. Ich habe ihn,
das muss man sich mal vorstellen, passt mal auf. Das kann ich an der Stelle auch nochmal erzählen.
Ich habe einmal, der macht für mich auch manchmal ein paar Sachen im Hintergrund. Also bringt man mit
mir jetzt nicht so in Verbindung, aber der hat auch schon ein paar Marketing-Sachen für mich im
Hintergrund geregelt in der Vergangenheit. Und ich habe ihm gesagt, hier, du kannst mir irgendwann
auch mal wieder eine Rechnung schreiben. Also du musst nicht alles umsonst machen. Also er guckt
schon lange meinen Channel und sagt, er hat keine Schmerzen mit meiner Ab- und Zumer, ein bisschen
nebenbei, was er macht für mich. Aber ich habe ihm schon öfters angeboten, hier weißt du was,
schick mir noch mal ab und zu eine Rechnung. Ich kann das dann bei der Steuer einreichen und du
kriegst übrigens ein bisschen was für. Und das haben wir einmal tatsächlich so gemacht. Die waren
bei einem Event, das ist nicht gelogen. Ich kann euch jetzt nicht erzählen, welche Organisation und
wem es genau ging. Aber ich schwöre, es ist nicht gelogen. Der ist mit seinem Team auf ein Event
gefahren. Für seine E-Sport-Orga auf ein Event gefahren. Nein, kein Event, sorry, kein Event,
in so einem Teamhouse-Trainingslager sind die gefahren, um zu üben für das nächste Event.
So. Und es hieß, es gibt dort Verpflegung, es gibt dort eine Küche, es gibt Aufwandspauschale,
alles möglich, sollte alles möglich bezahlt werden. Und als sie da waren, war die Küche
nicht benutzbar bzw. es hieß, glaube ich, sie dürfen die Küche nicht benutzen oder was auch
immer, so ganz weirde Zeug. Und Essen bestellen war nicht im Budget geplant und die Aufwandsentschädigung
kam auch nicht. Das heißt, die Typen saßen dann, manche von den Spielern kamen aus anderen
Ländern. Ich glaube, das Teamhouse war irgendwo in Frankreich. Die kamen aus anderen Ländern,
die waren quasi mehrere Länder von zu Hause weg. Und die Orga hat einfach gesagt, ja, macht ihr
mal, wir geben euch aber kein Geld, guckt mal, wie ihr klarkommt. Und ich habe damals, kein Spaß,
ich habe damals mit meinem oder mit dem mit dem Bekannten besprochen hier. Weißt du was? Schreibt
mir doch jetzt mal eine Rechnung über 300 Euro für das, was es letztes Jahr über so für mich
gemacht hast. Und da habe ich im Paypal 300 Euro überwiesen und die haben Essen gekauft für die
Spieler von den 300 Euro. Essen. Da muss ich das mal überlegen. Es geht hier nicht um irgendwie
Jahresgehälter. Es geht um Nahrungsaufnahme, die das Team nicht bezahlt hat für ihre Spieler.
Also das ist ein absoluter Sumpf, diese ganze E-Sport-Marketing-Laden. Ich habe quasi indirekt
das Essen für Spieler von der E-Sport-Orga bezahlt, weil es die Orga nicht hinbekommen hat,
weil es Dreckspasten sind. Das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Das ist wirklich nicht mehr normal,
was da läuft. Glaubt mir, ich habe die letzten, ich habe die letzten Jahre überzeugt schon mit
gekriegt, gerade im E-Sport-Marketing oder im Online-Influencer-Marketing-Bereich. Das sind
alles, bis auf ganz wenige Ausnahmen, das sind alles absolute Drecksäcke, die dich anlachen und
auf der einen Seite, die ihr Erstgeborenes verkaufen wollen, auf der anderen Seite ficken sie dich so
hart und bescheißen dich bei der ersten Gelegenheit, das ist nicht normal. Das heißt,
wenn ihr irgendwas mit den Leuten zu tun haben solltet, glaubt ihm gar nichts, was sie erzählen.
Es gibt glücklicherweise Ausnahmen, aber das merkt man auch erst, wenn man eine Weile mit
denen zusammengearbeitet hat, dass es eben keine Wichser sind, die dich bescheißen wollen. Gibt
es tatsächlich ein paar, aber das merkt man erst später. Die allermeisten und gerade im
E-Sport-Marketing-Segment können ihr vergessen. Lasst euch nichts erzählen. Die bescheißen euch
alle. Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel. Ja, durchaus möglich. Am Ende dürften sie es noch selbst
bezahlen. Das ist ganz wildes Territorium.
Also, was lohnt es sich, Windows 11 herunterzuladen? Warum nicht? Wenn du irgendwelche
Anwendungszwecke hast für Windows 11. Ja, das ist so, wie wenn du mich fragen würdest,
Max, lohnt es sich, eine neue Kellertreppe zu bauen? Was weiß ich, ob sich das für dich lohnt
oder nicht? Ich kann es schlecht einschätzen. Ich kann dir nur sagen, was für mich der
ausschlaggebende Grund war, Windows 11 zu benutzen. Nein, so einfach ist es tatsächlich nicht.
Windows 11 hat schon ein paar Dinge, die Windows 10 nicht hat. Also, was für mich der ausschlaggebende
Grund war, Windows 11 zu nutzen, das kann ich dir sagen, ob das jetzt für dich zutrifft,
weiß ich nicht, ist meine CPU. Und zwar, meine CPU besteht ja aus, boah, ich weiß,
8 Performance Cores und 16 Efficiency Cores, ist das richtig, Chet? Glaub schon. Und der
Windows 10 Prozess Task Scheduler, der kann mit den Efficiency Cores von dem 13900K nicht
richtig umgehen. Und Windows 11 kann das. Das ist für mich der Grund, warum ich Windows 11 benutze.
Ja, der Rest geht mir zum größten Teil eher auf den Sack. Was mir extremst, also wirklich mega
auf den Sack geht, ist das hier unten. Ihr seht, guckt euch das mal an, ich weiß nicht,
wer sich bei Microsoft wirklich gedacht hat, das ist eine gute Idee. Wann überlegt ihr euch mal,
guckt mal. Diese Taskleiste hier unten ist komplett leer und es gibt keine Möglichkeit,
sie zu füllen. Also mit sinnvollen Sachen. Sinnvoll wäre zum Beispiel, wenn ich bei einem
Programm zwei Fenster offen habe, dass es nebeneinander angezeigt wird. Das geht aber
nicht mehr. Man kann glaube ich mittlerweile, man kann glaube ich mittlerweile, wenn man,
ich glaube, man kann noch nicht mal Shortcuts drauf machen mittlerweile. Alter, das ist so
schlecht. Das ging unter Windows, ohne Scheiß Windows 95 konnte das. Windows 95. Wahrscheinlich
konnte der gut, Windows 3.11 hatte keine Taskleiste, aber sogar Windows 95 konnte das.
Es ist richtig, es ist richtig beschissen einfach nur, ich weiß nicht. So und unter Windows 10
konnte man zumindest noch einstellen, dass man, dass man den Text anzeigen lassen will,
was es ist. Ich glaube, das geht jetzt auch noch mehr, oder? Und man konnte das ungroupen,
was auch nicht mehr geht. Also es ist komplett einfach nur beschissen gemacht. Über Shortcuts
geht das mit Umwege. Warum braucht man für sowas Umwege, Mensch? Also es ist mies, es ist richtig
mies. Ja, nice. Die passende Lösung dafür wäre einfach, dass der Explorer nicht mehr so
oft abschmiert. Zwei Kontextmenüs. Ja, ja, ja, ja, das gibt's natürlich auch noch zwei Kontextmenüs.
Guck mal hier das und dann das alte. Das ist richtig mies, man. Okay, ich gette, warum sie es
gemacht haben. Und auf der anderen Seite auch nicht. Ich vermute mal, sie wollten schlicht
dieses Menü modernisieren, was nicht möglich ist, weil zu viele Applikation sich hier in das alte
Kontextmenü reinhängen können. Da haben sie die schlechteste Variante aller genommen und ein
zweites Kontextmenü implementiert. Man hätte dieses Kontextmenü einfach erweitern müssen
und besser machen müssen, dass es moderner wird, mehr unterstützt, aber rückwärts kompatibel zum
Alten bleibt. Warum sieht das noch so alt? Weil es alt ist. Du hast das neue Kontextmenü
wieder deaktiviert. Wie geht denn das? Bestimmt nur über irgendwelche lokalen AD-Benutzerrichtlinien
und solche komischen Dinge. Ja, was auch sehr pepega ist, es gibt jetzt hier den Volumenmixer.
Okay, den meine ich gar nicht, der ist tatsächlich ganz okay. Es gibt die Soundsettings. Die neuen
Soundsettings, die sind ja ganz okay mittlerweile. Ich meine, man kann immerhin jetzt so Sachen
einstellen wie das Format vom Input und das Volume. Allerdings, so wirklich Prioritäten
und Details kann man hier auch nicht einstellen. Das heißt, was man machen muss, wenn man manche
Dinge einstellen will, ist immer noch in das alte Control Panel, Sound und dann hier über
das Windows XP Menü, wenn man zum Beispiel mehrere supportete Formate unterstützen möchte. Was
tatsächlich manchmal sinnvoll ist, wenn man digitalen Soundoutput benutzt und beispielsweise
44,48 kHz Unterstützung. Das geht dann hier drüber nicht. Tja, und ein paar andere Sachen gehen auch
nicht. Es ist viel Schrott dabei. Sehe ich ähnlich? Ja, ich gebe dir vollkommen recht,
dass der alte Volumenmixer, der alte Volumenmixer war nicht besser, der alte Volumenmixer hat aber
einen großen Vorteil. Guckt mal, ich konnte die Soundsettings offen haben und den Volumenmixer.
Wenn ich den neuen Volumenmixer aufmache, überschreibt das automatisch, wo ich vorher
gewesen bin. Und in weiser Voraussicht, das ist ja auch so was Geiles, in weiser Voraussicht haben
die Settings nur ein Back-Button und kein Forward-Button. Also wenn ich jetzt wieder in
den Sound, in den Mixer rein will, muss ich immer hier unten klicken. Wenn ich sage, okay Mixer,
okay Sound-Settings, okay Mixer, okay Sound-Settings. Es ist unbegreiflich für mich,
was Microsoft sich denkt. Kann man nur eine Instanz der Settings offen haben? Ja, kann man.
Yep, cock. Also keine Ahnung, was mit Microsoft da wieder los. Und dieses komische Notification
Center, bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob das jemand verwendet. Ach ja und der neue Kalender ist
übrigens auch Schrott. Das Notification Center habe ich gleich gemutet, weil es einfach nur
nerviger Müll ist. Ist es auch? Also ich finde generell, dass sich der Desktop die letzten
Jahre zurückentwickelt hat. Nicht von der Optik und auch nicht von so Sachen wie,
dass mehr Anwendungen jetzt GPU-rendert sind und solche Geschichten. Nee, nee. Also es gab
schon mal ganz coole Entwicklungen, aber vom Funktionsumfang her und der Usability hat sich
der Desktop zurückentwickelt. Der Desktop hat sich zu einem Tablet, also entwickelt sich immer
mehr zu einem Tablet, das man mit Maus bedient. Was halt für ein Arsch ist. Weil ein Desktop-PC
ist genau für solche Sachen gut. Also, dass man vielfältige Input-Geräte hat, dass man
ordentliche Maus hat mit mehreren Tasten, Tastatur hat mit mehreren Funktionstasten und alles. Also
man kann einen Desktop einfach viel umfangreicher bedienen als ein Tablet und dementsprechend macht
es auch keinen Sinn, den Desktop immer weiter zu einem Tablet umzubauen. Und es ist aber ein
Trend der letzten Jahre, dass viele Desktop-Anwendungen sich immer mehr Richtung Tablet entwickeln.
Sinnloserweise. Wegen den Surfaces. Ja, schon möglich, schon möglich. Vielleicht kommt doch
das Jahr des Linux-Desktops. Ganz bestimmt. Also Linux ist ja tatsächlich in so gut wie
allen Bereichen schon da. Auf dem Server müssen wir nicht drüber reden. 80% oder 90% des Internets
würden ohne Linux nicht funktionieren. Beziehungsweise das ganze Internet wird
wahrscheinlich einfach nicht funktionieren, weil höchstwahrscheinlich, ich weiß es nicht,
aber höchstwahrscheinlich, die Root-DNS-Server wahrscheinlich auf Linux laufen. Rate ich jetzt
mal. Ich weiß es nicht, aber ich würde jetzt einfach mal von ausgehen. So, auf Android,
auf Smartphones ist Linux auch schon angekommen. Im Wohnzimmer ist es schon angekommen. Also die
sehr viele Fernsehgeräte. Entweder benutzen die Leute sowas wie einen Fire-TV-Stick oder
ein Shield-TV oder eben ein Smart-TV, die oftmals auf Linux-Basis laufen. In Kühlschränken ist
Linux da. Auf Toasters teilweise. Überall. Es gibt aber einen Bereich in Autos. Android Automotiv
heißt es, glaube ich. Nicht zu verwechseln mit Android Auto. Android Auto ist das, was euer
Android-Smartphone braucht, um sich zu Android Automotiv zu verbinden, wenn ich das richtig
im Kopf habe. Also es ist überall, es ist überall da. Nur Linux auf dem Desktop ist nicht da.
Hat iOS einen eigenen Kernel? Also ich würde vermuten, ich weiß es nicht genau, ich würde
vermuten, dass iOS auf dem macOS in den Reihen basiert und dementsprechend wahrscheinlich
immer noch ganz im Kern BSD ist. Ich weiß es aber ehrlich gesagt nicht, wie iOS intern
funktioniert. Ob das überhaupt jemand außer Apple weiß, ist auch fragwürdig. Also ich
vermute mal, dass es immer noch ein BSD unter der Haube ist. Ich bin mir jetzt nicht mal
sicher, ob es Open- oder Free-BSD ist. Übrigens, sie sind damit nicht die einzigen, die Playstation
basiert auch seit, glaube ich, der Playstation 2 auf BSD. Bei der PS5 weiß ich es nicht.
Bei Linux ist es nicht wahrscheinlich BSD.
Ja, okay, wahrscheinlich ist es BSD. Ja, aber auf dem Desktop ist das mit Linux nichts. Ja,
ich meine, dass es sich auch so ähnlich durchgesetzt hat wie auf anderen Plattformen. Ich benutze
das ja auch, aber wir sind eine Minderheit, Linux auf dem Desktop. Was wiederum dazu führt,
dass es viele Sachen für Linux-Desktops nicht gibt. Auf der anderen Seite, Linux-Desktop ist
auch, und das muss man denke ich ehrlich sagen an der Stelle, auch die schwächste, wie nennt man
das heutzutage so schön, die schwächste User-Story, die Linux so zu bieten hat. Also es gibt vieles,
was Linux auf dem Desktop bisschen zurückhält. Es ist zu kurz gegriffen zu sagen, es liegt nur
daran, dass eben Microsoft dominant auf dem Desktop ist und Linux sie nicht so durchgesetzt hat. Das
ist zu kurz gegriffen. Oder es ist auch zu kurz gegriffen zu sagen, Linux-Desktop gibt es nicht,
weil es kaum Anwendungen dafür gibt. Das Ding ist, Linux auf dem Desktop hat halt auch so ein paar
Designentscheidungen, die nicht gut sind. Ich mein, wir hatten lange Zeit jetzt X11, wo wirklich
gar keiner Bock hat, an den Innereien rumzumachen. Wir haben Wayland, was fast noch schlimmer ist als
X mittlerweile. Nicht von der Architektur her, sondern vom Rang, von der. Wie träge ich das jetzt am
besten aus? Vom Blame-Game quasi, wer da was machen muss. Also bei X hat es ja zumindest den Vorteil,
dass du noch von ausgehen konntest. Okay, damit das funktioniert, muss ich irgendwas von X supporten
oder unterstützen oder implementieren, dass es geht. Nur, dass bei X das Problem war. Okay,
du wusstest, es wird irgendwas in X11 sein, was ich machen muss, aber du wusstest nicht was,
weil keine Sau mehr X versteht. Bei Wayland ist es jetzt so, dass du sagst, ah, ich möchte das und
das machen und dann sagt Wayland, aber es ist nicht supported. Ja, warum nicht? Ja, das ist
nicht unsere Aufgabe. So, das ist ja das Problem, was du unter Linux hast. Das ist dann erstmal,
was mein bestes Beispiel dafür ist, ein GPU-Decoding für Browser. Ich weiß, das ist mein
Lieblingsbeispiel dafür. Ja, ist so. I3 ist, finde ich, auch eines der wenigen benutzbaren
Umgebungen, die es unter Linux tatsächlich gibt, wobei das halt auch nicht für den Mainstream ist.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen? Genau, bestes Beispiel ist GPU-Decoding-Support für Browser. Ich glaube,
das ging seit 2011 oder so. 2012 irgendwie, wo sie angefangen haben, dass es unter Windows geht.
So, GPU-Decoding, also sprich, wenn ich ein YouTube-Video aufmache, machen wir jetzt mal
hier YouTube, Max FPS, boah, mein Auge, mein Auge, oh, es ist hell. So, ich mache jetzt mal mein Video
auf. Ja, ich habe noch nicht mal einen Werbeblocker entziehen. Ich benutze Chrome Nix, außer für den Chat.
Alter, darf ich mein Video bitte mal abspielen? Ich will mein eigenes Video angucken. Leute,
wisst ihr eigentlich, dass YouTube ja fast nicht benutzbar ist. Ohne Adblocker ist ja schlimm. Wie
macht man das eigentlich? Also, ich kann jeden verstehen, dass ich meine Videos nur mit Adblocker
angucke und generell YouTube nur mit Adblocker angucke. So, also, guckt euch das mal an. Hier
läuft ein Video, 1440p, 60 FPS und jetzt gucken wir mal an den Taskmanager und schauen uns hier an.
Boah, wo sieht man das jetzt gescheit im Taskmanager? Hier, Chrome. Man sieht, guckt mal hier,
ein Prozent, ein Prozent CPU. Moment, wo sieht man jetzt die GPU-Auslastung? Das ging doch auch. Oder
muss man das extra einblenden? Also, guckt, man sieht hier, ich spiele ein Video ab im Chrome,
ein Prozent CPU-Auslastung und 14,5 Prozent GPU. Das liegt daran, das Video wird decoded von der
GPU und am Endeffekt wird wahrscheinlich Chrome mittlerweile auch Hardware Accelerated gerendert.
So, und jetzt machen wir mal das Ganze unter Linux. Das ist eine VM, da geht GPU-Decoding eh nicht.
Ist also optimal, um euch zu zeigen, wie das unter Linux lange Zeit aussah. 14 Prozent von der
4090, ja, warum nicht? So, jetzt sparen wir das hier unter Linux auch mal, gleich in Settings.
Und jetzt werdet ihr feststellen, oh, guck mal da. Firefox braucht irgendwie 150 Prozent CPU,
das muss bei alles irgendwie zusammenrechnen. Firefox braucht irgendwie eine komplette CPU
oder sowas zum Videorendern. Ja, die Details sind jetzt wurscht, den Takt der Grafiker und sowas.
So, und das liegt daran, weil GPU-Decoding oftmals unter Linux nicht funktioniert. Dass
es bei mir nicht funktioniert, ist klar, das ist Linux in der VM, da ist nichts mit GPU-Decoding,
aber das war lange Zeit unter Linux generell ein Problem. GPU-Decoding hat nicht funktioniert.
So, wie gesagt, seit in Windows und Mac, wahrscheinlich auch, weiß ich nicht,
in Windows geht das weit über zehn Jahre. Schon, ich würde sagen, seit 2010, 2011 geht das halbwegs.
So, und da ist das so aufgekommen. Und unter Linux geht das immer noch nicht so hundertprozentig.
Also was das Problem unter Linux gewesen ist, ist Folgendes. Irgendjemand hat gesagt, ich hätte
auch gerne Hardware Acceleration von Videos, also GPU-Video-Decoding unter Linux. Dann ging's los,
wer ist denn dafür zuständig? Muss der Browser-Hersteller das machen? Müssen
die Mesa-Driver-Programmierer das machen? Muss der Grafikkartenhersteller das irgendwie supporten?
Muss der Grafikkarten-Driver das irgendwie supporten? Müssen das irgendwelche Glue-Libraries
für OpenGL und Vulkan und hast du nicht gesehen, supporten? Muss das vielleicht der Linux-Kernel
selbst irgendwie supporten? Wo muss das passieren? Und jeder hat gesagt, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Muss das das Windows, muss das vielleicht, muss das vielleicht X oder Wayland supporten,
was auch immer. Und jeder hat gesagt, ah nee, das muss der Browser-Hersteller machen. Der
Browser-Hersteller hat gesagt, ah nee, das muss der Windows-System-Hersteller machen. Und die haben
gesagt, ah nee, Moment, Moment. Ja, aber die Grafikkartenhersteller, die machen so scheiß
Treiber, das können wir doch gar nicht richtig machen. Und das ist das eigentliche Problem von
Linux auf dem Desktop. Ich will nicht sagen, dass die alle unrecht haben, aber das ist unterm Strich
das Problem von Linux auf dem Desktop. Und das Problem manifestiert sich in ganz unterschiedlichen
Formen. Also wenn man in Probleme läuft, die irgendwas mit Desktop-Anwendungen zu tun haben,
oftmals läuft es genau auf sowas raus. Quadro-Karten habe ich noch nie ausprobiert,
keine Ahnung. Also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass die tatsächlich ganz gut funktionieren,
nämlich für Virtualisierung. Rate ich jetzt einfach mal, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe das noch nie
gemacht. So Business-Server-Zeug, das funktioniert bei Linux meistens ganz gut, das ist auch gut
supportet. Also man muss ja sagen, unter Linux funktioniert vieles auch schneller als unter
Windows. Das ist ja gar nicht so. Beispielsweise das Support für Intel-Hardware, generell auch für
Netzwerkkarten und solche Geschichten. Oder das Task-Scheduling für mein 13900K. Das war,
soweit ich weiß, schneller in Linux am Start als unter Windows. Und Intel-Netzwerkkarten-Supporten,
sowas out of the box, immer absolut top, super, gibt es überhaupt nicht zu beschweren.
Außer dass Linux ab und zu mal Intel-Dreiber-Entwickler zusammenstaucht auf der Mailingliste. Aber das ist
ja normal, da kriegt ja jeder mal ein bisschen Anschluss von ihm. So, und das ist das Problem.
Natürlich, daraus folgen dann, also das ist eines der Hauptprobleme, die ich sehe, was dem
Linux-Desktop-Support im Wege steht. Daraus folgt dann, dass halt auch viele Sachen nicht
suboptimal gemacht sind und dass es viele Anwendungen nicht gibt. Wobei ich glaube,
wenn sich das ursprüngliche Problem lösen würde, dass man die Sachen mit nicht... Also das Problem,
wofür ein Hersteller steht, ist doch, wenn er Linux-Supporten will, dann hat er eh schon,
sag mal mal, gewisse Ideale vielleicht. So nach dem Motto, ich möchte gerne Linux-Supporten machen,
auch wenn es erstmal nicht viel Geld abwirft. Aber ich erhoffe mir vielleicht weiteren Support
in Zukunft für die Linux-Plattform. Also wenn ein Hersteller Linux unterstützen will, dann muss er
sich ja überlegen, lohnt sich das. Und ich denke, viele Hersteller kommen aktuell zu dem Schluss,
das lohnt sich jetzt unmittelbar nicht. Zum Beispiel Valve ist ja auch ein schönes Beispiel für. Das
lohnt sich jetzt vielleicht erstmal unmittelbar nicht, aber sie erhoffen sich durch den Support
vielleicht in Zukunft mehr Unabhängigkeit, was ja auch eines der Punkte ist, warum die überhaupt
mit Steam, Linux und so angefangen haben. Sie erhoffen sich vielleicht in Zukunft mehr
Unabhängigkeit von Microsoft und vielleicht in Zukunft dann auch mehr Geld unmittelbar nicht.
Also vor der Frage stehen ja viele Hersteller, bringen wir unsere Sachen unter Linux raus oder
nicht? So und das große Problem, was sie jetzt haben, wenn sie Linux-Supporten wollen, ist,
dass sie wissen, okay, es wird sich bis auf Sonderfälle wahrscheinlich jetzt erstmal,
wir reden jetzt von Desktop-Software, es wird sich wahrscheinlich erstmal unmittelbar nicht
lohnen. Vielleicht kommen sie zu dem Schluss, vielleicht ist es eine gute Investition in die
Zukunft, das zu machen, aber wenn sie die Kosten gegenüberstellen, was Linux-Support sie kosten
würde und das um ein viel viel vielfaches höher ist durch diese ganzen Umstände, die ich vorher
beschrieben habe, wie bei einem anderen Betriebssystem, dann sagen sie, sie machen es nicht. So nach dem
Motto, wir würden ja gerne Linux-Supporten, aber wenn uns die Entwicklung oder der Support von
Linux im Verhältnis so viel mehr kostet als das, was es auch nur ansatzweise vielleicht mal in
Zukunft bringen kann, dann machen wir es nicht. Und das liegt, finde ich, fundamental eben an
diesen Geschichten, gerade was Linux-Destop angeht. Unter anderem, dass es halt so ein
Wildwuchs ist und das Plame-Game zwischen den Projekten so stark ist. Ah ne, wir müssen das
nicht machen, wir auch nicht, wir müssen den Teil machen, ach ne, dann doch nicht. Das ist
wahrscheinlich gar nicht so sehr das Problem, die meisten Leute administrieren den Kram doch daheim
selbst. Das ist, das finde ich, das ist mit das größte Problem und das sieht man auch an der
Software drauf. Es ist ja cool und man könnte sagen, das ist der Linux-Weg, dass es sehr viel
verschiedene Auswahl gibt und das finde ich auf der einen Seite gut. Du hast unter Linux wirklich
die Auswahl an Desktop-Umgebungen. Du kannst Gnome benutzen, du kannst i3 benutzen, du kannst
KDE benutzen, du kannst Enlightment oder irgendwie so Zeug, Xfce, LXDE, Cinnamon, Mate, es gibt ja
tausende, Batchi, wahnsinnig, es gibt ja tausende Desktop-Umgebungen. Einige davon ganz gut,
viele davon, ich persönlich finde ich grotten schlecht, gerade wenn ich mir so Sachen angucke,
wie das neue Gnome. Also man kann sich ja viel über Windows beschweren, somit nicht mehr
kopierbaren Icons in der Taskleiste oder diesem komischen Setting, man kann sich vieles unter
Windows beschweren. Unter Linux hast du das Vorteil, du kannst einen Terminal benutzen und
da eigentlich 90% deiner Sachen machen, aber seriously, was die Jungs sich bei Gnome gedacht
haben, zumindest out of the box, das ist ja unbenutzbar. Du kannst dich beim Fenster minimieren
unter Default Gnome und wenn du Themes ändern willst und Schriften und so komische Sachen,
glaube ich, brauchst du irgendein Third-Party-Tweaks-Tool dafür. Also was Gnome entwickelt ist mir
komplett Banane, was sie die letzten Jahre machen. Ich will nicht aussehen, dass es tatsächlich
Leute gibt, denen das gefällt, sicherlich, wo man wieder sagen könnte, Tweaks ist eingebaut,
ja super, wo man vielleicht sagen könnte, okay, ich wollte kurz nur Motto-Platt machen,
ich sehe hier gerade eine an der Wand. Direkt. Wo bin ich stehen geblieben? Ja, also das ist
tatsächlich das Vorteil und Fluch zugleich unter Linux. Peter, ja genau, bitte nicht leaken,
bitte nicht leaken. KDE mag ich auch nicht, das ist aber ein persönlicher Geschmack. Ich kann mir
vorstellen, dass viele Leute durchaus mit KDE gut klarkommen. Bei mir ist es so, ich benutze
aus Prinzip nur i3. Das liegt nicht daran, weil ich jetzt irgendwie die Hard i3-Fan bin,
also mittlerweile schon, aber es ist nicht so, dass ich nicht auf was anderes verwenden würde,
was gut ist, sondern dass mich alles andere nervt. Ich meine, wenn ich Desktop haben will,
grafische Oberfläche, die mich nervt, dann kann ich ja Windows benutzen. Aber ich benutze i3,
weil es nichts hat, was mich nerven kann. Weil es hat ja nichts. i3 hat keine Task-Leiste,
i3 hat keine irgendwie Fenster-Management, Task-Switching, Overlays, was auch immer.
i3 hat einfach gar nichts, i3 hat mehrere Desktops und das war's. Sway kann ich nicht verwenden,
weil Sway Wayland ist und Wayland, wo wir wieder beim Thema sind, Linux und Desktop,
Wayland in der VM nicht gescheit funktioniert. Das hier ist i3, i3, nicht E3, das hier ist i3,
das hier. Das war's. Das Einzige von i3 ist tatsächlich, was man hier sieht,
die Status-Leiste oben. Mehr gibt's nicht. Das ist i3. Das Einzige, was man hier sieht,
ist die Status-Leiste. Du kannst mit i3 noch ein bisschen mehr Sachen machen. Du kannst Anwendungen
starten im Fullscreen, im Fenster und du kannst, wenn du ganz hart drauf bist, theoretisch auch,
also wenn man das wirklich will, kann man auch Floating-Windows benutzen. Macht man aber
normalerweise unter i3 nicht. Ja, das muss man doch nicht mehr benutzen. Das war's,
das ist tatsächlich i3. i3, ihr werdet es sehen, ich habe einen Desktop mit einem Hintergrund,
da sind keine Eigens drauf. Also i3 kann noch nicht mal Desktop-Eigens und man würde jetzt sagen,
oh, so ein Scheiß, hat keine Features, warum soll ich das benutzen? Ich benutze es gerade deswegen,
weil es keine Features hat, die mir auf den Sack gehen. Ich meine, was brauche ich denn? Ich
brauche einen Browser, ich brauche einen Terminal und ich brauche irgendwie meine
Entwicklungsumgebung. So, fertig. Manchmal habe ich hier noch Visual Studio Code auf,
wenn man vielleicht Backend-Frontend-Sachen macht. Und eventuell habe ich hier ganz hinten noch
irgendwie eine Notiz-Anwendung auf. Fertig. Fertig. So, das ist so mein Standard-Setup.
Browser immer auf 1, Terminal immer auf 2, Text-Editor woran ich arbeite, immer auf 3,
eventuell zweiten Text-Editor, den ich zusätzlich dazu brauche, auf 4 und auf 7 oder irgendwo hinten
ein Notiz-Programm, wo ich schnell was reinschreiben kann. Fertig. Das reicht. So, und mehr brauche
ich nicht. Und das ist wunderbar und i3 geht mir nicht auf den Sack und kommt mir nicht in die
Quere. Das ist der Grund, warum ich i3 verwende. Ich verstehe, dass das nichts für den Mainstream
ist. Der Mainstream flippt aus. Ich meine, guck mal, allein schon wenn du Shortcuts brauchst,
um Anwendungen zu starten oder Sachen zu Copy-Pasten und so, da rastet ja der Standard-User schon aus.
Wenn ich dem Standard-User sage, drücke mal Windows-Taste D zum Anwendungen starten oder
Windows-Taste P zum Paste. Flippt aus. Der will hier unten auf seinen komischen Start-Button drücken.
So, und das hast du halt hier nicht. Aber für mich ist das das Beste, was es gibt. Es ist nichts,
was mir auf den Sack geht. Also für mich ist Linux auf dem Desktop schon da. Aber so in der
breiten Masse wird es das halt mit i3 garantiert nicht geben. Und ich finde halt, dass die anderen
Lösungen zumindest für mich nichts sind. Aber das größte Problem bleibt nach wie vor nicht die
Fragmentierung an sich, sondern so das grundlegende ihr seid dran schuld, nein, ihr seid dran schuld,
nein, ihr seid dran schuld. Wenn was nicht geht unter Linux. Wir haben zehn Jahre gebraucht bis
GPU. Ah ja, um das nochmal fertig auszuführen. Wir haben über zehn Jahre gebraucht bis GPU-Decoding
unter Linux gescheit funktioniert. Es funktioniert immer noch nicht gescheit. Es funktioniert nur im
passenden Zusammenspiel aus Browser-Version mit den richtigen Settings, den passenden Mesa-Treibern,
den passenden Grafikkarten-Treiber-Herstellern. Wahrscheinlich bedimensiert er den passenden
Windows-System. Und eventuell braucht man auch noch die neuere Kernel-Version, das weiß ich
aber nicht genau. Und dann funktioniert es auch nicht bei allem, sondern meistens nur bei H.264,
was so der 0815-Codec aktuell im Internet ist. Und wenn man so Sachen wie...
wie erst das VP9 oder H.265 abspielen will, was auch oftmals unter Windows kein Problem ist,
GPU-Decoded abzuspielen, geht das unter Linux nicht. Und wenn es geht, kann es sein,
dass bei nächsten Patches irgendwelche Gründen schon wieder nicht geht. Gab es letztens wieder
was, das H.265-Decoding jetzt nicht mehr funktioniert? Tja, das ist halt echt ein Problem.
Ja, ja, ja, ist so. Das ist richtig. Ja, natürlich ist da Nvidia auch dran schuld. Oder AMD oder
was auch immer. Mit dran schuld. Ja klar. Aber da sind wir wieder beim eigentlichen Thema,
was ich gesagt habe, dass Linux auf dem Desktop halt so ein reines Plame-Game ist. Das liegt an
dir, das liegt an dir, das liegt an dir. Das mag, streng genommen auch alles stimmen. Aber das ist
halt ein Problem unterm Strich. Alles, was beatscht, nicht vorhin zunächst ist überflüssig. Ja,
natürlich. Man braucht ja prinzipiell auch keine grafische Oberfläche. Also Linux Term... Warte mal.
Äh blöd. Warte mal. Warum kann ich das nicht umschalten? Warum kann ich nicht auf eine
Konsole umschalten? Ah, geht doch. Hä? Okay, keine Ahnung, was das gewesen ist. Ja, also der
krasse Linux-Hacker-Man, der braucht ja prinzipiell, der braucht ja prinzipiell nur das, ja. 80 Zeichen,
80 Zeichen breit, 120 Zeichen hoch, so nach dem Motto. Das muss reichen. Text-Editor ist auch
overrated, outdated, debated. Wir machen alles mit Z und AWK. Funktioniert E3 eigentlich gut mit
Docking Station und mehreren Bildschirmen? Also E3 hat einen relativ guten Multiple-Display-Support,
man glaubt das gar nicht. Wie das jetzt mit dem Umschalten zwischen verschiedenen Displays ist
und dem Erkennen mehrerer Displays, das glaube ich nicht, dass E3-Native das supportet. Das
wirst du wahrscheinlich über irgendwie X-Render oder so machen müssen. Also ich hatte das bei
meinem, bei meinem alten Notebook, beim alten Arbeitgeber hatte ich das so. Ich hatte drei
verschiedene X-Render-Configurations. Also X-Render, das ist das Tool, das man verwendet zum
ansteuern seiner Bildschirme. Es gibt auch noch AX-Render oder sowas für wer, wer irgendeinen
GUI braucht. Hier, das, das gibt's auch noch, ja. Aber das ist, das finde ich persönlich abartig.
Also man kann auch, ich zernese euch mal kurz. Ja, es gibt, es gibt auch das, aber seriously,
also ich hatte, ich hatte bei meinem alten Notebook hatte ich drei Scripts. Und zwar,
also aktuell, man, das ist halt, das ist, das ist, das ist eine VM. Also deswegen sieht man jetzt,
was? Hä? Hab ich das gerade deinstalliert? Aus irgendwelchen Gründen als Abhängigkeit. Okay,
also hier, hier sieht man normalerweise sein Display, sein Display-Output. Man sieht jetzt
aktuell nicht viel. Ich meine, ich habe nur einen Bildschirm dran. Und also hier an der VM,
also da erkennt man, erkennt man nicht so viel. Normalerweise würde man jetzt hier noch mehrere
sehen. Guck, man kann ja auch in der VM mehrere Bildschirme anschließen. So, und ich hatte,
ich hatte mehrere, ich hatte drei, ich hatte drei Scripts auf meinem alten Notebook. Das erste
Script war für Notebookbetrieb. Also wenn ich, wenn ich Notebook ohne Display dran verwenden
möchte, dann hast du, dann war das relativ simpel. Dann, ich glaube LVDS oder so hieß das Notebook
Bildschirm. Da muss man dann, ich kann es euch erst im Kopf jetzt nicht sagen, ja. Also man kann
dann hier so Sachen machen wie Left, Left of Monitor 1, Right of Monitor 2 und Disable von
irgendwie Monitor. Also muss man mal ein bisschen gucken, wie das funktioniert. Zumindest, ich hatte
halt drei Scripts dafür. Einmal für Notebookbetrieb an sich, also ohne extra Bildschirm. Dann normalen
Arbeitsplatzbetrieb, Notebook Bildschirm, zugeklappt, ausgeschaltet, alles auf dem großen
Bildschirm. Und ein Presentationbetrieb, Notebook Bildschirm eingeschaltet, extended auf zweiten
Bildschirm. Kann man mit I3 auch Beamer-Modus, du kannst mit I3 alles machen, was du willst,
weil I3 ist es vollkommen egal. Du brauchst nur die Passe in X-Render-Settings und wenn du deine,
wenn du deine Leiste hier oben, die Eigens und sowas woanders haben willst, kannst du das in
deiner I3-Config erweitern. I3 selber ist das ziemlich egal. I3 unterstützt Out of the Box
einfach alle Bildschirme, die du mit X-Render eingerichtet hast. Also wie gesagt, ich hatte
die drei Scripts, die habe ich dann gestartet für den unterschiedlichen, für den Betrieb und da
konnte ich alles machen. Ja, das verstehe ich. Das ist ein bisschen komplizierter und das ist
sicherlich auch nicht für den Mainstream-User. Ich glaube, unter Windows ist es Windows P. Da
kann man sowas machen. Ja, sowas wäre hier wahrscheinlich ganz nice, wobei ich mir sowas
hier selbstverständlich auch mit meinen eigenen Scripts hätte draufbinden können. Ja, also
deswegen, ich sage ja auch mein Setup ist definitiv nichts für den normalen User, der
irgendwie auf Linux umsteigen will. Garantiert nicht. Aber das war jetzt auch nicht der Punkt.
Der Punkt war ja, warum ich denke, dass es große Probleme gibt auf dem Linux Desktop und nicht
nur, dass es halt nicht alle Programme gibt. Das hat seinen Grund, warum es die nicht gibt.
Und der für mich auffälligste Grund ist halt dieses permanente Plame-Game zwischen allen
Projekten, wer jetzt was machen muss. Was ja auch aus dem Gesichtspunkt vom Einzelprojekt berechtigt
ist, aber unterm Strich problematisch. Kann man auch machen. Ja, habe ich ja im Endeffekt,
habe ich ja im Endeffekt nicht, aber ich habe hier mein Scripts-Menü und da könnte ich das
drüber ausführen lassen. Ja, also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel meinen Clipboard-Manager
ausschalten will, dann führe ich das aus. Ansonsten kann ich es vergucken, sieht man ja auch,
Clipboard ist gerade aus, kann ich Clipboard wieder einschalten. Das ist aber nichts von I3,
das ist jetzt hier Zusatzsoftware. Und ganz wichtig, ein Emoji-Picker, da sind wir uns ja
einig, dass das prinzipiell das Allerwichtigste ist. Das ist ein schönes Beispiel, was da im
Argen liegt mit Hardware Acceleration. Genau, guckt euch das mal an. Unter Windows funktioniert
der Scheiß halt, unter Linux hast du hier solche Probleme. Das ist genau das, was ich meinte. Es
funktioniert eigentlich mittlerweile, aber auch nicht immer. Also sprich, das ist hier die Sache
mit wie bekommt man Hardware Acceleration mit Linux im Browser. Und das ist glaube ich noch
nicht mal mit dem Browser, das ist glaube ich generell, wie man Hardware-Decoding bekommt.
Naja, das Problem ist daran, dass die Diskussionen bei Linux über zehn Jahre
dauern und bei Microsoft in einem halben Jahr abgehakt sind. Dass jetzt bei Microsoft auch
nicht immer der Weisheitsletzter Schluss rauskommt, sieht man zum Beispiel hier dran. Aber das sind
die Entscheidungen, die werden getroffen, die sind halt wenigstens da, da bewegt sich was.
Ich meine, überlegt euch mal, wie lange ist jetzt schon das hin, dass man gesagt hat, wir machen mit
Wayland ein besseres X und es ist nicht mal ansatzweise da aktuell. Es benutzen viele schon
Wayland, aber für meinen Einsatzzweck ist es halt nicht benutzbar zurzeit. Hier ist das beste
Beispiel für GPU-Decoding. Ich sage ja, muss eine passende Kombination sein aus Grafikkarten-Dreiber,
Mesa-Dreiber, Browser, alles mögliche. Dann unterstützen die Browser auch wieder unterschiedliche
GPU-APs und es ist für'n Arsch, glaubt's mir, es ist einfach für'n Arsch diese Geschichte.
Deswegen glaube ich auch nicht, dass es jedes Jahr des Linux-Desktops geben wird, weil ich glaube,
dass der größte Vorteil von Linux eben die Vielfältigkeit und eine, wie soll man das nennen,
eine streamelinte Desktop-Experience, wo vieles out of the box einfach funktioniert und es einen
klaren Weg gibt, schlicht und ergreifend nicht zusammenpassen. Linux wird auf dem Desktop für
alle gut sein, die sich ihr eigenes System zusammenbauen wollen und computeraffin und
technikaffin sind, aber auch die werden Probleme haben, weil es manche Sachen, die sie gerne
benutzen wollen, nicht gibt und der 0850-NOOB wird nie Linux auf dem Desktop benutzen. Ich glaube,
das passt einfach nicht zusammen, auch wenn es vielleicht Hardcore-Linux-Fans nicht hören wollen,
aber sie sind nicht 90% der Benutzer. Das passt einfach nicht zusammen. Also der größte Vorteil
von Linux passt nicht zusammen mit Linux auf dem Desktop und deswegen glaube ich auch nicht,
dass wir das sehen werden in nächster Zeit. Wenn überhaupt, werden wir das sehen in Form von
WSL auf dem Windows-Desktop, weil dort liefert das Microsoft benutzbar aus, auch wenn es für mich
zur Zeit nicht benutzbar ist, aber nicht alles, was ich machen will, aber wenn man darauf spekulieren
will, wo es am ehesten Linux auf dem Desktop gibt, dann in Form von WSL unter Windows.
Dafür gibt es ja Wein, da hast du noch ganz andere Probleme. Das wollen die meisten Leute
halt nicht. Die meisten Leute, wenn die Steam installiert haben, wollen sich ein Spiel kaufen,
auf Play drücken und das soll funktionieren. Was oftmals geht, was oftmals funktioniert,
aber auch oft genug nicht. Das ist richtig, das ist vollkommen korrekt. Ich hatte meiner Mutter
damals, das ist schon ewig her, 2008 oder so, als sie noch ein Desktop-PC hatte, hatte ich
der damals auch schon Ubuntu drauf gemacht und kam damit super klar. Das ist an sich kein Ding,
diese absoluten Standard-Anwendungen, wenn du wirklich nur der unterste Low-Level-Benutzer bist,
dann ist das tatsächlich kein Problem. Aber das, was wir am Rechner machen, vielleicht schon mehr.
Ich möchte meine Videos schneiden, ich will Sachen spielen, ich will streamen, ich will Sachen
recorden, ich will auch Spiele mit Anti-Cheat spielen. Ich bin jetzt nicht der Mega-Windows-Power-User
oder sowas, aber ich könnte nicht alles unter Linux machen, was ich zurzeit unter Windows mache.
Was für mich ja auch der Grund ist, warum für mich das beste Setup ist. Alles, was ich unter
Linux machen kann, mache ich unter Linux und für die Sachen, die unter Windows einfacher sind,
mache ich das unter Windows. Bis jetzt alles easy. Ja, dann spiel mal Rainbow Six unter Wine,
good luck, have fun. Ist WSL 2 schon Standard unter Windows 11? Ich glaube, WSL 2 ist mittlerweile
Standard, aber du kannst ja WSL nicht einfach starten, du musst ja WSL irgendwie erst über
Features aktivieren und, ach, keine Ahnung, habe ich schon eine Weile nicht mehr gemacht.
Habe ich schon eine Weile nicht mehr gemacht. So, wir gucken uns jetzt mal ein paar Videos an. Ich
habe jetzt eineinhalb Stunden geschwätzt. Was haben wir denn hier schönes zu bieten? Was können
wir uns mal angucken jetzt? Leute, es hat mich noch keiner dran erinnert, dass ich was trinken muss
und ich habe auch nichts getrunken. Jetzt haben wir schon, guckt mal, jetzt haben wir das schon.
Oh fuck, mein Browser ist gefriest. Ich darf nicht auf Emotes drücken, dann freest mein Browser,
weil Incognito-Modus und FFZ und so und das mag das nicht. Kackel. Oh, ihr Brocken, Leute,
Chat, Chat Brocken. Okay, jetzt gehts wieder. Max als Trinker, excellent, excellent. Würdest
du dir jedoch sagen, dass es sich im Enterprise-Umfeld durchsetzen könnte 90% meiner Arbeiter
aufnehmen im Browser und Terminal? Ja, wobei ich davon ausgehe, dass es sich bei dir auch nicht
durchsetzen wird, weil deine Firma auf Microsoft-Produkte setzt, wenn es um Zusammenarbeit und verschiedene
interne Workflows geht. Das heißt, selbst wenn du 90% unterwegs bist, ganz wirst du es wahrscheinlich
nicht loswerden, auch im Business-Umfeld. Viele interne Tools und Workflows sind halt sehr
Microsoft-zentriert in vielen Unternehmen. Was ist WSL? Quasi Linux, was in Windows läuft,
auf simple zu sagen. Im Prinzip eine in Windows integrierte Linux VM und das stimmt mittlerweile
unter WSL 2 auch. Es ist eine in Windows integrierte Linux VM, das hier ist übrigens nicht WSL,
vor allem im Workstation. Eine relativ gut in Windows integrierte, mitgelieferte Linux VM.
Ich habe aber immer noch so meine Schmerzen damit. Mir ist eine vollwertige Linux VM,
die ich selbst betreibe lieber. Gut Office 365 ist nicht das Ding, das geht mittlerweile auch
ganz gut im Browser. Also ich habe beispielsweise alle PowerPoint-Sachen für einen alten Arbeitgeber
immer im Browser gemacht. Aber interne Sachen, irgendwelche Zeiterfassungssysteme,
Meetingraum, Reservierung, Software, interne News-Sachen und so. Je nach Arbeitgeber sind
es halt sehr Microsoft-zentrierte Workflows. Was war das für eine Notiz-App,
das ist hier. Joplin von Laurent Kosic. Vielleicht ist das auch französisch. Keine Ahnung.
Das ist das hier. Warum ich das benutze, hat einen ganz simplen Grund. Weil es die einzige
wirklich gute Notiz-Software ist, die Windows, Mac, Linux, iOS und theoretisch auch Android
unterstützt. Wenn auch die Mobile Clients ein bisschen lecken im Funktionsumfang,
sind die trotzdem okay. Self-hosted Sync und die Möglichkeit, die Plattform Native
Notifications zu verwenden. Also man kann hier zum Beispiel sagen, ich will hier ein To-Do,
mal kurz zeigen. Neues To-Do hier. Kekl erledigen. Jetzt habe ich ein To-Do. Das können wir
jetzt theoretisch mal duplikaten, dass wir ein paar To-Dos haben. Wir haben jetzt ein paar To-Dos.
Da kann man sich auch ein bisschen Zeug reinschreiben, was man will. Man kann auch
Images reinkopieren. Was wir jetzt machen können, ist, wenn ich sage, das To-Do ist fällig heute,
Moment. Ah nee, ich habe mich verklickt hier. Wenn ich sage, das To-Do ist fällig heute um
12 Uhr. Es ist fällig um 10 Uhr 3. Ist ja gleich. Jetzt habe ich das eingetragen. Und wenn ich das
jetzt sünke, was ich hier nicht eingerichtet habe, man kann das Nextcloud sünken, sonst,
das ist nicht das einzige. Man kann es WebDAF, Nextcloud, Joplin sünken, kann man sünken. Wenn
ich das jetzt sünke, dann bekomme ich eine Smartphone-Notification, wenn mein To-Do ansteht.
Das kann Obsidian nicht, das kann Appflow nicht und es können die wenigsten Notizen,
Native-Notification. Das finde ich sehr praktisch, weil man will ja nicht für alles einen
Kalendereintrag machen. Will ich für diese vier To-Dos ernsthaft einen Kalendereintrag haben? Nee,
wahrscheinlich nicht. Übrigens, ich sehe gerade die Notification funktioniert nicht, aber das ist
woanders. Das liegt wahrscheinlich an beiden Linux-Einstellungen. Ah ja, ich habe kein
Notification-Demon mehr. Okay, das wird es natürlich sein. Das zeigt an, wenn es Neuigkeiten gibt.
Also, dass es jetzt zum Beispiel Notifications gibt und die würden dann auch auf mobile funktionieren
und unter Windows, Mac und Linux. Okay, excellent. Ich weiß nicht, warum die Notifications nicht
funktionieren wahrscheinlich. Nö, ich habe doch laufen. Vorführeffekt. Normalerweise hätte ich
jetzt vielleicht war ich ein bisschen zu... Geben wir ihm mal kurz noch Zeit. Ansonsten keine
Ahnung, warum es nicht geht. Jetzt eigentlich erwartet, dass 10.05 Uhr da eine Meldung kommt.
Wahrscheinlich gerade wieder eine Sache, was irgendwie broken ist. Gut, also lass uns mal ein paar
Videos angucken. Ich habe jetzt eineinhalb Stunden geschwätzt. Ich merke schon im Hals,
ich muss mal was trinken. Ohne Punkt und Komma. Hat die auch Wim-Bindings? Was hat Wim-Bindings?
Ja, habe ich. Ich habe eine Textdatei, Videoideen heißt das mittlerweile sogar. Früher hieß diese
Textdatei immer Weihnachtskalender. Das heißt Videoideen. Und dann habe ich noch einen extra
Notizordner für die einzelnen Videoideen, wenn ich dazu schon ein paar Ideen habe,
was ich sagen will. Da schreibe ich mir zum Beispiel auch Videotitel rein und Thumbnail-Ideen rein.
Ja, dann nehme ich was auf, dann bastle ich in Vegas irgendwas zusammen oder gib es dem
Teilo zum schneiden ab und zu mal. Sag meinem Thumbnail-Designer Bescheid, dass er ein Thumbnail
machen soll ungefähr mit dem und dem Text. Dann schickt er mir einen Vorschlag und dann
lade ich das Video hoch. Also mein Video-Workflow ist weit davon entfernt optimiert zu sein und
weit davon entfernt wirklich, wie soll man sagen, State of the Art 2023 zu sein. Also man könnte die
Videos, wenn man die, also würde ich meine Videos tatsächlich mal ein bisschen eins,
zwei Wochen im Voraus produzieren, wenn ich da nicht zu faul wäre, dann könnte man deutlich,
deutlich bessere Videos machen, indem ich nämlich das Ganze aufnehme und meinem Cutter schicke und
der das dann jedes Video cuttet. Bezahlst du den pro Video, den Thumbnail-Designer? Nee,
den bezahle ich im Pack für Thumbnails, so immer irgendwie im Zehnerpack oder so.
Den Video-Cutter, der kriegt pro Video tatsächlich was, ja, aber das hält sich in Grenzen. Das ist
jetzt nicht, dass ich irgendwie 200 Euro pro Video bezahle oder so. 200, 200 Euro pro Video,
das ist weniger, viel weniger. Und das müsste ich machen, also wenn ich mein YouTube-Game
tatsächlich mal richtig absteppen will und ich so ein bisschen auf Sparflamme laufen habe,
wie aktuell, weil ich irgendwie gerade gerade Zeit habe, neuer Job und Stream und auch nicht
so wirklich großartige Themen, auf die ich Bock habe an Games, gibt es auch gerade nichts. Da
könnte man gerade was Videos cutten angeht sehr viel machen. Und man muss halt auch gute,
also tatsächlich gute Leute zu finden, die Videos schneiden bzw. Thumbnails machen,
ist gar nicht so einfach. Okay, also was gucken wir uns jetzt an? Zeig mal her. Was haben wir denn
hier? YouTube. Ist schneller Laden wirklich gefährlich? Es wird ein bisschen wärmer?
Nee, Fiverr ist meistens nix. Gut, man findet auf Fiverr durchaus auch gescheit, so ist es nicht.
Aber bisher habe ich die guten Leute nie über Fiverr. Okay, also ist Schnellladen wirklich
gefährlich? Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das groß gefährlich ist. Es wird ein
bisschen wärmer, aber das war's. Komm, was haben wir denn sonst noch? Bestes Betriebssystem zum
programmieren. Aha. Warum ist es so leise? Warum hat das Ding eigentlich doch hier laut?
Lautstärke-Settings gibt es nicht. Okay, können wir uns das näher angucken. Was kann eine 400 Euro
Waage? Geldkosten as fuck wahrscheinlich. Was haben wir noch? I tried more AI-Tools,
Karriereplanung, Top 5 Smart Home zu starten. Okay, komm. Wir haben tatsächlich mal wieder
Linus-Tech-Tipps-Videos zur Auswahl. Stop buying Android-TV-Boxes. Warum? Ich habe selbst eine Android-TV-Box.
Okay, was kann eine... Wir gucken das jetzt einfach mal an. Das ist teilweise immer total an der
Realität vorbei. Die Videos sind alle wirklich gut geschnitten und so. Ich stimme halt oftmals
diesem Apple-Only-Mindset nicht ganz zu, was auf diesem Channel gezeigt wird. So nach dem Motto,
ja sogar unser Bad muss so designt sein wie die Icons auf unserem iPhone und solche Dinger.
Denke ich mal, man kann es auch übertreiben. Eine 400 Euro Waage. Okay, lasst mich mal überlegen,
was würde ich erwarten von einer 400 Euro Waage? Okay, ich würde erwarten erstmal die Basics,
die ich von jeder Waage erwarten würde, dass sie genau ist. Genau für Körpergewicht. Also,
ich brauche die nicht im Grammbereich. Es reicht mir, wenn das so sich in einem Bereich von so 100,
200 Gramm bewegt. Das ist okay. Ich wollte sie nicht aufs Gramm genau haben. Also, so auf 200
Gramm genau und so ist schon okay. Das erwarte ich aber auch von viel, viel günstigeren Wagen und
das sollte kein Problem sein, weil ich dachte eigentlich, dass Wagen, also zumindest das Wiegen
von Wagen, so diese Gewichtserkennung, ein gelöstes Problem ist. Das gab es schon. Kennt
noch jemand diese richtig oldschool Wagen mit einem Gewicht dran? Nee, die meine ich nicht.
Zum schieben. Heißt das vielleicht auch Schiebewaage oder so? Waage.
Ja, sowas. Also, wo man tatsächlich noch Gewichte geschoben hat und so. Also, man sieht,
Wagen an sich sind ja zumindest das Wiegen ein gelöstes Problem. Also, würde ich jetzt erwarten,
dass eine Waage für 400 Euro vielleicht noch irgendwie was Richtung Körperfett macht,
gehe ich mal von aus. Wobei das immer fragwürdig ist, wie gut das funktioniert,
wenn man nur mit Füßen drauf steht. Tja, und ich fürchte, ich fürchte, dass die wieder mit ganz
so viel Herstellerklaut und Appzwang und smarten Funktionen, die herstellergebunden sind, daher
kommen, was ich mir wahrscheinlich nicht kaufen würde. Okay, auf geht's.
Hey Leute, Wagen können wiegen. Smarte Wagen können wiegen, die Daten speichern und die
Körperzusammensetzung errechnen. Und dieses smarte Waage ist so intelligent.
Leute, ich muss meine Körperzusammensetzung nicht errechnen. Meine Körperzusammensetzung
kann man ganz einfach anhand eines Emotes betrachten. Ich brauch da keine Waage für.
Wie sieht's bei euch aus, Chet? Wisst ihr eure Körperzusammensetzung oder braucht ihr eine Waage
für? Man muss allerdings sagen, das letzte Jahr über ist es deutlich weniger P-Pro-Fett geworden.
Ich habe mich letztens auf die Waage gestellt. Ich hatte, glaube ich, neuesten Tiefstand mit 91,2.
Vor einem Jahr? Naja, nicht ganz. Ja, doch. Vor letztes Jahr, im Februar,
habe ich noch 108,5 gewogen. Wie steht es? Es hat sich nichts großartig bewegt. Es hat sich nichts
großartig mehr bewegt. Um die 92 schwankt es immer rum. Mal 91, mal fast 93. Ich müsste
wahrscheinlich jetzt neben meinem beim Bewegen am Tag tatsächlich noch mal ein bisschen weniger
bzw. noch ein bisschen gesünder essen oder aber tatsächlich mal noch ein bisschen mehr Sport machen
als einfach nur eineinhalb Stunden rumlaufen. Aber ich habe keinen Bock, ins Fitnessstudio zu
gehen. So, also gucken wir uns mal an. Dass sie euer Leben retten kann. Ob sich das Ganze lohnt,
ob es komplett unnötig ist und was es alles kann, will ich heute beantworten. Ja, für 400 Euro ist
es unnötig. Vielen Dank an Withings, die mir diese Waage schon vor Marktstadt zugeschickt haben und
mich bei diesem Video hier unterstützten. Es gab inhaltlich jedoch keinerlei Vorgaben, wie ihr
auch definitiv merken werdet. Ich habe die Waage jetzt seit drei Monaten täglich benutzt und in
diesem Video werde ich... Ich glaube ihm das, ja. Ich will es nicht schlechtreden. Ich kenne das
aber aus eigener Erfahrung. Naja, man zeigt ja schon am liebsten Produkte, die man selbst auch
ganz gut findet. Und nachdem die am Ende immer das Video noch mal sehen wollen, wenn man es
hoch lädt oder bevor man es freischaltet am Ende oder die wollen dann auch nicht, dass man die
Sachen total flamet. In gewissen... Gewissen Zurückhaltung hat man bei Sponsored-Videos einfach.
Zumindest kenne ich das aus eigener Erfahrung. Vielleicht ist es bei ihm nicht so.
Werde ich zwar Socken tragen, damit sie aber richtig funktioniert, muss man sie ohne Socken
benutzen. Das nur als kleiner Hinweis am Rande. Wir kriegen jetzt keine energischen Füße gezeigt.
Was ist da los? Kann und sollte achtsam designt sein. Auch eine Waage ist Teil meiner
Einrichtung und wenn ich sie Jahr für Jahr täglich anschaue, dann freut es mich einfach,
wenn sie schön ist. Deswegen habe ich mir 2018 meine erste Withings Waage gekauft. Nicht nur
weil mich die Funktion... Ganz wichtig Leute, die Waage muss designtechnisch ins Bad passen.
Das ist Punkt Nummer eins. ...überzeugt haben, sondern auch einfach weil sie schön aussieht.
Die neue Bodyscan ist schlicht flach und zeitlos. Die Oberseite besteht vollständig aus einer
Glasplatte. Der Unterbau ist aus mattem Kunststoff. Das ist etwas schade, denn meine alte Withings Waage
war noch unten aus Aluminium. An der Seite ist ein USB-C Anschluss zum Aufladen, was man bei
täglicher Benutzung einmal pro Jahr machen muss. In zehn Jahren, also zehnmal aufladen, irgendwie
finde ich das witzig. Es gibt nur... Einmal im Jahr aufladen, ja okay. Es hat ein weiteres Ding
wurde eins, zweimal im Jahr oder ja, also eins, zweimal, alle zwei Jahre wie auch immer. Die
Batterie wechseln muss, beziehungsweise laden muss, ja gut. Moment, hat er nicht gesagt,
hat er nicht gesagt, einmal im Jahr? Ich finde das witzig. In zehn Jahren, also zehnmal aufladen.
Ja in zehn Jahren, also einmal pro Jahr. Irgendwie finde ich das witzig. Es gibt nur ein Knopf und
den muss man auch nur einmal bei der Einrichtung drücken. Das ungewöhnliche an dieser Waage ist,
diese Stange, die man hochheben kann und die mit einem hochwertigen Seilzug verbunden ist.
Warum das nötig, unmöglich ist, erkläre ich euch gleich. Schön fand ich das Display. Es ist
ein farbiges OLED mit ausreichender Auflösung. Sicherlich das beste Display, was ich bei einer
Waage jemals gesehen habe und jeden Morgen sehe ich direkt wie das Wetter an diesem Tag wird.
Alter, unnützeste Funktion ever. Wenn dir nichts an smarten Funktionen einfällt, dann baue eine
Wetterfeuersage ein, weil er nur 850.000 smarte Geräte Wetterfeuersagen anzeigen können.
Wie groß bist du? Ich bin 174. Ich bin an der Grenze, wenn man mal nach diesem BMI-Chart geht,
ich bin an der Grenze von zu fett.
Das ist die Farbe und normalerweise ist eine Farbe subjektiv, aber eine glänzende,
schwarze Waage zu machen. Ein Gegenstand, der immer auf dem Boden liegt. Das ist,
als hätte man versucht etwas zu bauen, was möglichst schnell dreckig wird. Staub,
Wasser, Füße. Ja, schwarz und spiegelnd ist tatsächlich blöd. Meine ist weiß und spiegelnd.
Ich habe ja auch eine smarte Waage, wobei meine glaube ich 30 Euro kostet und ich 400. Ich habe
eine Mi Scale 2. So ein Teil habe ich. Bisschen teurer geworden die letzten Jahre. So ein Ding
habe ich. Da siehst du glücklicherweise nicht so viel drauf. Display auch vollkommen okay. Ich
habe ja schon Fotos davon gepostet aus dem Bad. Vollkommen okay. Und ich finde auch designtechnisch
ganz okay. Das Glas ist hier oben. Zumindest fühlt es sich sehr nach Glas an. Ein bisschen
Aloklas. Vollkommen in Ordnung. Ich muss euch sagen, mir gefällt das Design hier besser als
bei der 400 Euro Waage. Und ich wüsste jetzt auch nicht, warum das 400 Euro kosten muss. Ja,
die kann auch Körperfett und Geschiss benutze ich nicht. Ich halte das eh für fragwürdig,
was da immer rauskommt. Also ich benutze das rein für Gewicht. Und hast du die Waage geflasht? Nein,
die Waage muss man nicht flaschen, weil die Waage über Bluetooth funktioniert. Das heißt,
ich habe auf diesem Stockwerk einen ESP32 hängen, der Bluetooth-Geräte scannt, ob die generell
listenen am Bluetooth. Incoming Bluetooth Sachen. Und das dann an meine Heimautomatisierung weiter
leitet. Das gleiche Ding macht auch den Stand von Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensoren und von
Temperatursensoren und von diesen Thermometern, die ich im Haus verteilt habe. Ich habe doch hier,
ähm, wie heißen die Dinger nochmal? Ja, von diesen Dinger habe ich doch auch, habe ich,
glaube ich, fünf Stück im Haus verteilt. Und das ist was, die habe ich Custom-Firmware geflasht,
denn die Standard-Config schickt, glaube ich, alle 30 Sekunden oder sowas neue Daten. Was für
ein Thermometer viel, viel zu krass ist, Alter. Ich habe das jetzt hochgestellt, dass die alle,
glaub, alle zehn Minuten oder so das schicken. Und das erste, was ich mir gekauft habe, ist,
Moment, ich gucke jetzt mal, welche Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensoren, äh, diese
Pflanzenbodenfeuchtigkeitssensoren von von Xiaomi, äh, Flora heißen die, glaube ich, Flora. Ich
gucke mal kurz, wann ich die gekauft habe, weil der Akku geht immer noch. Das ist nur so eine
ganz kleine Knopfzelle, so eine CR-2-2, wie heißen die Dinger? CR-2-3-0-2 oder sowas, die da drin
sind. So, ich gucke mal kurz. Ich habe die gekauft am 5. April 2021. So, das hielt jetzt zwei Jahre.
Hier, zwei Jahre und die Batterie ist bei 20%. Also der nächste, ja, das sieht, das sieht ganz
gut aus. Ja, bald ist aus. Das sieht ganz gut aus. Allerdings muss man warten, bis es die bei
AliExpress im Angebot gibt, sonst lohnt sich das nicht. So, und also ich habe jetzt zwei Jahre und
die Batterie ist irgendwie so bei 15 oder 20% irgendwie in dem Dreh jetzt. Also wird wahrscheinlich
noch kurz halten und dann muss ich sie austauschen. Das ist natürlich wirklich gut,
da kannst du dich nicht beschweren. Das ist schon nice. Die kann man flaschen, ja,
die kann man flaschen. Hier, die Dinger. Haben wir sogar im Stream gemacht. Archiv.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht, welcher Stream das war. Aber wir haben das tatsächlich im Stream gemacht.
ATC. Hier haben wir es doch gemacht. Ja, hier haben wir das irgendwo geflasht, glaube ich.
Wir gucken uns Videos an und flaschen gar nichts.
Kann das sein, dass ich vergessen habe, bei dem Stream, kann das sein, dass ich vergessen habe,
irgendwie hier den Titel zu ändern, weil wir flaschen gar nichts. Das ist der Hour. Okay,
keine Ahnung. Hier. Da, da liegt. Okay, da wird Zeug geflasht. Flaschchamp. Das Motor flaschen.
P-Zeug flaschen. Ich glaube, hier machen wir das jetzt. Guck mal, da habe ich das sogar schon
eingeschaltet. Sinnvoller Titel. Ja, hier, hier. So kannst du die Dinger flaschen, damit. Genau.
Es gibt aber mittlerweile neue Versionen davon. Kannst du flaschen. Du brauchst einen Rechner mit
Bluetooth, der Bluetooth-fähig ist und dann kannst du über einen Browser sogar den Krempel
flaschen. Diese Thermostate, die ich gerade gezeigt habe, ja. Und es lohnt sich, also das
Intervall runterzustellen, lohnt sich auf jeden Fall, weil dann halten anstatt einem halben,
dreiviertel Jahr halten die Batterien über zwei Jahre. Also schon mal eine Hausnummer. Okay,
gucken wir uns erst mal an, was der mit der Waage weiter erzählt. Cremes und was sonst noch so alles
in einem wirklich schnell dreckig wird. Staub, Wasser, Füße, Cremes und was sonst noch so alles
in einem Bad ist, wird immer dazu führen, dass diese Waage selbst beim saubersten Menschen auf
der Erde schnell schmutzig aussieht. Ich verstehe diese Entscheidung nicht. Ich auch nicht. Und ich
hoffe wirklich, dass die angekündigte weiße Version zeitnah rauskommt. Smarte Waagen funktionieren
stark vereinfacht so, dass ein minimaler Jep-Astrom, einer, den man gar nicht mehr Jep-Klok merken
kann, durch den nackten Fuß in das Bein in den Körper reingeht und am anderen Fuß gemessen wird,
wie lange das gedauert hat. Dadurch ergeben sich dann Informationen zu Muskeln, Wasser,
Knochen und dem Fettanteil. Weil Strom aber immer den kürzesten Weg sucht, wird streng genut-
Ich habe immer noch meine Zweifel, wie gut das wirklich ist, was diese Dinger da messen.
...um nur der Unterkörper erfasst. Und da kommt dann die Sensorstange der Bodyscan ins Spiel. Durch
sie werden die vier Endpunkte unseres Körpers gemessen und die Ergebnisse sind nicht nur genauer,
sondern auch informationsreicher. Die Daten ermöglichen es jetzt die Arme, die Beine und
den Thor so einzeln zu errechnen und deswegen kann man in der App auch die Muskel-
Leute, ich glaube unser Thor so hat das meiste Fett.
...und Fettverteilung an der jeweiligen Stelle einsehen. Und ich finde das Ganze ist sehr
schön und verständlich gelöst mit einem 3D-Modell. Die Messwerte werden dann noch mit anderen
Withings-Nutzern verglichen- Wait a minute! Ich soll meine Körperfettdaten auch in die
von denen, dass sie die mit anderen Usern ver- Alter! Geh weg! Dafür soll ich 400 Euro bezahlen!
Da wird Strom durch den Körper gejagt. Ja und? Das ist ja kein elektrischer Stuhl in Wagenform.
Das ist nicht schlimm.
Was fast ein bisschen fies ist, weil Withings-Nutzer etwas sportaffinere Menschen sind als der
Ist das so?
...eine weitere Funktion, die durch die Sensorstange möglich ist, ist ein 6-Kanal-EKG. Smartwatches
unterstützen nur ein Kanal, der Akku-
Wait! Im Leben nicht! Im Leben... Nein, nein, nein, nein. Also die schreiben vielleicht,
dass das ein 6-Kanal-EKG ist und es wird vielleicht auch die größten Sachen erkennen, aber alles
andere im Leben nicht. Never. Vor allem am Hand des Fingers. Ein richtiges EKG, da kommen
Sachen ans Herz dran und sowas. Was soll das denn am Finger bitteschön machen?
Aktuelle Goldstandard in der Medizin sind 12 Kanäle, aber warum ist ein EKG wichtig?
Ich zitiere die Deutsche Herzstiftung. In Deutschland leiden schätzungsweise 1,5 bis 2
Millionen Patienten an Vorhofflimmern, viele davon ohne es zu wissen. Bei etwa 30 Prozent
der von Herzrhythmusstörungen betroffenen Menschen verursacht die Erkrankung keine auffälligen
oder belastenden Symptome. Nicht selten sind es erst die dramatischen Folgen, wie etwa
ein Schlaganfall, der auf Vorhofflimmern aufmerksam macht. Es ist deshalb sehr wichtig, die Rhythmusstörung
so früh wie möglich zu erkennen und zu behandeln.
Ähm, ich hatte auch mal sowas wie Herzrhythmusstörungen. Ist jetzt alles wieder gut, seitdem ich mich
mehr bewege. Das ist schon Jahre, ist schon wirklich ganz lang her. Da hatte ich mal doppelte
Herzschläge. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr sowas schon mal hatte, das fühlt sich ganz furchtbar
komisch an. Das fühlt sich wirklich sehr, sehr weirdchampig an. Hatte jemand von euch
schon mal sowas? Also, das war für mich auch so mit der Grund, zu sagen, Max, du musst
dich echt mal mehr bewegen. So eines der ausschlaggebenden Gründe. Ich meine, es kann nicht sein,
dass man mit 28 oder so, ähm, Extraschläge sind normal. Ne, also in der Form war das
hatte ich vorher nicht. Das fühlt sich ganz komisch an. Das war also der Punkt, wo ich
gesagt hab, ich muss mich mal mehr bewegen. Also, das fühlt sich, ihr könnt euch das
so vorstellen. Also doppelte Herzschläge. Das fühlt sich ungefähr so an, wie wenn
ihr euch erschreckt. Also jetzt ohne das Erschrecken, aber wenn ihr euch erschreckt, dann kriegt
ihr doch so einen kleinen Adrenalinstoß so, der vielleicht mal evolutionstechnisch dafür
da war, dass man jetzt schnell wegrennen kann. Also wenn ihr euch erschreckt vor irgendwas,
was kleines, wir reden vor was kleinem, jetzt nicht so nach dem Motto, ihr dreht euch um
und hinter euch steht da Dinosaurier oder irgendwas, was euch killen will, sondern Erschrecken
von irgendwas kleines. Es kommt einer zu euch ins Zimmer rein, wenn ihr gerade konzentriert
auf was guckt und nicht mitrechnet und sowas. Und dann erschreckt man sich und das äußert
sich ja noch nicht mal so krass wie ein heftiger Jumpscare, so mildes Erschrecken. Eine Sache,
die auftritt, wenn man sich erschreckt ist, also neben, dass man vielleicht ein bisschen
zusammenzuckt und dass man sich rumdreht und guckt hoch, was ist denn jetzt? Das meine
ich nicht. Was zusätzlich auftritt, was man vielleicht gar nicht so sehr merkt, weil man
eben so mit zusammenzucken und umdrehen beschäftigt ist, ist, man kriegt so einen kleinen Adrenalinstoß,
dieses hoch. Ich kann es nicht besser beschreiben, aber es hat wahrscheinlich jeder schon mal gespürt.
Ihr kriegt so einen kleinen Adrenalinstoß, wahrscheinlich evolutionstechnisch dafür da,
dass wenn man sich erschreckt, Adrenalinstoß und wegrennen kann möglichst schnell. Und ungefähr so
fühlt sich ein doppelter Herzschlag an. So wie als kriegst du so einen ganz kleinen Adrenalinstoß
und dein Herz gibt Gas. So, weil es passiert ja im Prinzip, wenn du so einen Adrenalinstoß kriegst,
dann schlägt dein Herz auch schneller. So ungefähr so fühlt sich das an,
allerdings nicht so lang, sondern nur ganz kurz. Das fühlt sich an wie so einen 1-2 Sekunden
Adrenalinstoß, ein kleiner. Und wenn du das vorher noch nie hattest, also doppelte Herzschläge,
dann denkst du irgendwas ist ganz furchtbar weird. Und ich bin damals dann auch zum Arzt und ich
dachte, das kann doch nicht sein, was ist das denn? Und er hat dann auch ein EKG gemacht, da wurden
dann halt so Dinge wirklich ans Herz geklebt und nicht geklebt, gesaugt, das war mit so Saugknöpfen
dran. So. Und dann haben die beim ersten Mal, da hat man gar nichts gemerkt. Das erste Mal
hat er nur irgendwie so zwei Minuten gemacht, da war nichts, weil das war unregelmäßig,
das zweite Mal ein bisschen länger gemacht. Und da war das. Und da hat er sich das angeguckt,
hat gemeint, hier Herr Max, Sie müssen sich keine Gedanken machen. Doppelte Herzschläge kommen ab
und zu vor. Und wie sieht es denn bei mir aus? Wie viel, was mache ich dann beruflich? Nee,
das wusste er, was ich beruflich mache. Wie sieht es dann beruflich aus und wie sieht es
dann so mit Bewegung aus bei Ihnen? Da habe ich gesagt, na gut, ich sitze beruflich mehr oder
weniger die ganze Zeit vorm Rechner, ich sitze privat mehr oder weniger die ganze Zeit vorm Rechner
und wenn ich YouTube und Streaming machen, sitze ich auch die ganze Zeit vorm Rechner. Also im
Prinzip sitze ich vorm Rechner und bewege mich ab und zu zum Einkaufen. Da hat er gesagt, Herr Max,
also Sie sind zwar noch jung, wie gesagt, ist er schon ein bisschen, sind noch nicht so alt,
hat er gesagt wahrscheinlich, glaube ich. Ist ja schon ein paar Jahre her. Ist glaube ich fünf
Jahre oder so her, vier, fünf Jahre. Sie sind noch nicht so alt, aber gerade jetzt ist wichtig,
wenn man so viel sitzt, gucken Sie mal, dass Sie sich ein bisschen mehr bewegen. Habe ich
natürlich danach nicht gemacht, weil ich zu faul war, aber irgendwann, ich weiß gar nicht,
was wirklich der große Anschluss war, warum ich angefangen habe, mich mehr zu bewegen. Das war
eine Kombination aus einmal diesen Herzgeschichten, generell, dass man sehr schlapp und müde war,
dass ich oft Kopfschmerzen hatte. Irgendwann habe ich gesagt, weißt was, ich fahre jetzt hier
einfach mal zu einem Berg in der Nähe, Berg, für die Schweiz heißt das kein Berg, Hügel in der Nähe
und laufe da ein bisschen rum, so irgendwo, wo es mir landschaftsmäßig gefällt. Das habe ich ein
paar Mal gemacht und habe festgestellt, ey, das ist eigentlich recht entspannend, da eineinhalb,
zwei Stunden rumzulaufen. Seitdem habe ich das immer, also ich habe da nicht mit eineinhalb
Stunden angefangen, ich habe da wieder 45 Minuten gelaufen. Seitdem mache ich das jetzt zunehmend
und es gibt eigentlich außer sonntags, heute ist vielleicht ein Tag, wo ich nicht laufen gehe,
aber ansonsten gehe ich mittlerweile jeden Tag raus, eineinhalb bis zwei Stunden, zehn Kilometer plus
mit rumgelaufen. Vor ein paar Tagen bin ich sogar 18 Kilometer gelaufen, weil zu einer etwas
weiter entfernten Eisdiele und zurück, dass man auch ordentlich, ordentlich fressen, fressen kann.
Das war eine ordentliche Runde, da war ich bestimmt auch drei Stunden oder so, irgendwie würde ich
sagen, im Dreh unterwegs, aber das war schönes Wetter vor ein paar Tagen und es hatte sonst
nichts zu tun. Da kann man das mal machen, eineinhalb Stunden hin, eineinhalb Stunden zurück und
da ist man natürlich ziemlich im Arsch danach. Aber das hilft und seitdem ich das mache, habe
ich keine Kopfschmerzen mehr, keine irgendwie Verspannungen großartig mehr, keine Schmerzen
mehr, was so Nerven im Bobbes angeht. Wir haben teilweise ohne Mist der Hintern weh getan,
wahrscheinlich vom vielen Sitzen, also nicht Gatschi-Bass oder so und ich habe nichts mehr,
auch keine, also so gut wie nie, vielleicht einmal im Monat noch oder so, doppelte Herzschläge,
nichts mehr und dazukommen, seitdem ich angefangen habe jetzt, seit Corona laufe ich tatsächlich noch
ein bisschen mehr und ich habe angefangen, ein bisschen minimal gesünder zu essen und jetzt
habe ich 17 Kilo ungefähr abgenommen, ein bisschen über einem Jahr. Also das ist schon möglich,
wenn man sich bewegt. Also ich weiß, ich selbst hätte es nicht geglaubt und ich selbst hätte es
definitiv auch nicht gemacht vor ein paar Jahren, wenn ich es mir selbst erzählt hätte, weil es
ist immer noch ein Unterschied zwischen, man weiß, dass es eigentlich sinnvoll ist und man
macht es, also das Erste ist natürlich, man muss es erstmal erkennen, was sinnvoll wäre zu machen,
das Zweite ist natürlich, man muss es dann auch wirklich machen und vieles von dem, was sinnvoll
wäre, wird man wahrscheinlich auch nie machen, aber in dem Fall muss ich sagen, unterm Strich,
ist es das Beste, was man machen kann, sich ein bisschen zu bewegen, ihr müsst es nicht übertreiben,
ihr müsst nicht wie ich zwei Stunden am Tag durch die Pampa laufen, manche Leute laufen gerne,
manche gehen auch gerne ins Fitnessstudio, manche andere machen hier den krassen Joggingstells,
was auch immer, aber eine Stunde Bewegung am Tag ist eine sehr sinnvoll investierte Zeit,
die vielleicht euch auf den ersten Blick kein Geld bringt oder keine Belohnung in Form von
irgendwas, dass man was geschafft hat in der Zeit, so zumindest materiell, aber unterm Strich
wahrscheinlich die best investierteste Stunde am Tag ist, was ihr machen könnt.
Deswegen, ich weiß, ich hätte es selbst nicht, hätte ich mir das vor zehn Jahren erzählt,
hätte ich gesagt, Max, verpiss dich, geh mal nicht auf den Sack, ich weiß, dass es gesund ist,
sich zu bewegen, aber geh mal nicht auf den Sack, hau ab, laber mich nicht voll mit dem Scheiß.
Aber eine Stunde Bewegung am Tag und teilweise auch schon weniger, jede Bewegung ist besser
als keine, es ist für die gesamte Gesundheit, ihr habt keine Muskelprobleme mehr, keine Herz-,
keine Kreislaufgeschehen, keine Kopfschmerzen mehr, Ausdauertechnik, ihr seid wache, ohne Scheiß,
ich war selten früher den ganzen Tag wach und jetzt geht das, ich stehe morgens auf,
sagen wir irgendwie, 7.30 Uhr und ich bin eigentlich mehr oder weniger den ganzen Tag
wach, also auch wirklich wach und fit wach, gut, natürlich ab 20.00 Uhr, wenn du weißt,
wir sind auch mal müde, mittags, manchmal, wenn ich viel gefressen habe, vielleicht auch ein
bisschen, aber ich bin den ganzen Tag wach und gerade, wenn ich von der Arbeit komme oder wenn
Homeoffice fertig ist, ich freue mich tatsächlich drauf, wenn schönes Wetter ist, jetzt rauszugehen
und zwei Stunden oder eineinhalb Stunden, je nachdem, ob man ein bisschen irgendwo hinfährt,
draußen rumlaufen zu können. So, jetzt gucken wir uns erstmal die Waage fertig an, also was ist
denn jetzt so schlimm hier? Also nicht erst dann, wenn es bereits zu spät ist, Zitatende,
ich habe euch übrigens alle Quellen aus diesem Video unten verlinkt. Aber ob einem die Waage
da jetzt groß für hilft, eventuell wiegt einen die Waage auch in falscher Sicherheit, man hat
wirklich Herzprobleme, stellt sich auf die Waage und die Waage sagt alles okay. Tag ein EKG zu machen
ist natürlich etwas exzessiv und morgens hundemüde 30. Du kannst doch gar kein EKG richtig machen,
ohne dass du Sonden am Herz angebracht hast. Wie soll es denn funktionieren? Das achte doch nicht
nur auf den Pulsschlag, das achte doch irgendwie auch auf Herzgeräusche und was auch immer alles,
keine Ahnung, was da alles passiert. Aber wie willst du mit einem einfachen Griff in der Hand
ein ordentliches EKG machen? Das glaube ich nicht, dass es scheinbar funktioniert. Ja, und wenn du
wirklich Herzprobleme hast, ist sicherlich das auch unter Belastung zu testen gar nicht verkehrt.
Übrigens, by the way, ich glaube ab 35 gibt es, ich weiß bei euch sind auch schon ein paar älter,
ab 35 könnte sogar sein, dass es teilweise Sachen schon ab 30 gibt, aber ab 35 bekommt ihr glaube
ich einmal im Jahr oder einmal alle zwei Jahre ein Gesundheitscheck mit Belastungstest und Gedöns
umsonst von eurer Krankenkasse und ihr könnt auch, aber das geht glaube ich nur als Mann,
das geht glaube ich nur als Mann. Ich glaube man darf als Mann alle zwei Jahre ab 35 kostenlos
eine Darmspiegelung machen. Also wer Bock hat und alles umsonst abgreifen will, let's go. Zur
Darmkrebs, Prostata Krebs, Vorsorge könnt ihr das machen, glaube ich alle eins oder zwei Jahre ist
das kostenlos. Ich muss ehrlich sagen, das ist auch so ein Punkt, ich weiß, dass es sinnvoll ist,
weil umso früher man Sachen merkt, umso besser, logisch. Ich habe aber keinen Bock auf eine
Darmspiegelung. Ich war auch noch nicht bei meiner kostenlosen Darmspiegelung und ich habe auch keinen
Bock auf eine kostenlose. Das sind so Sachen, die nimmt man nicht mal geschenkt.
Kostenlos und nicht umsonst, das ist richtig, umsonst ist es nicht. Das bringt natürlich
wirklich was und sei es nur, dass man danach sagen kann, jawoll alles gut, ich habe nichts,
was ja auch ein ganz gutes Gefühl ist. Das ist gar nicht so schlimm, habe ich schon hinter mir.
Hast du mit Betäubung oder ohne Betäubung gemacht? Ich habe keinen Bock es mitzubekommen,
wie sie mir das Ding in Bobbes schieben. Ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht. Irgendwie stelle
ich mir das nicht so toll vor. Das ist ja kein Finger, das ist ja ein Schlauch und da kommt
ein paar Meter rein. Mit Betäubung, Moment, nicht Betäubung, Betäubung gibt es ja immer,
glaube ich. Mit Narkose oder ohne, mit Schlafen oder nur Betäubung. Mit Narkose würde ich es mir
machen lassen. Ich will es nicht mitbekommen, wie die mir den Schlauch und Bobbes schieben.
Ich will da gar nicht drüber nachdenken. Wie sind wir jetzt eigentlich von der 400-Euro-Waage auf
Darm-Spiegelung gekommen? Gucken wir weiter. Ein weiterer neuer Messwert ist die Pulswellengeschwindigkeit.
Kann die Waage, blöde Frage, kann die Waage auch wiegen? Wie nicht in BTU pro Stunde,
ich bin enttäuscht.
Ich habe wirklich meine Zweifel, dass das aussagekräftig ist. Das mit dem Körperfett und dem
Ding in der Hand, das lasse ich mir noch am ehesten gefallen. Aber das und das EKG und
diese, also ich weiß nicht, wie aussagekräftig das ist. Nicht, dass das in falscher Sicherheit
wiegt, so nach dem Motto, die Waage sagt, ich habe nichts, es ist alles gut, dabei misst die
gar nicht alles. Außerdem, braucht man das in der Waage? Möchte man dafür 400 Euro bezahlen?
Ich bin skeptisch, ich nicht. Warum genau ist das geblurrt? Ich meine,
er hat doch eine Hose an. Sind nackige Füße auf YouTube auch schon nicht erlaubt? Oder ist da
JAPCLOCK und man sieht es nicht, die Füße. Ja, wenn du einen Arzt hast, den das interessiert,
wenn ihr gesetzlich versichert seid und zum Arzt geht, dann könnt ihr darauf wetten,
dass es dem komplett am Arsch vorbeigeht, um am Thema zu bleiben, was ihr ihm da so zeigt. Der
will euch in fünf Minuten wieder rausbuxieren aus seiner Praxis. Wenn ihr selbst bezahlt bzw.
privat versichert seid, dann sieht das anders aus, dann kann er das alles abrechnen, dann macht er
das auch. Es gibt Studien, die belegen, dass tägliches Wiegen dafür sorgt, dass man das
eigene Wunschgewicht erreicht. Kann ich mir vorstellen, ja, mit dem Gewicht kann ich mir
vorstellen, das hat mich sehr motiviert beim Abnehmen zu sehen, so im Tages-Wochen-Abstand,
wie es runtergeht, tatsächlich. Hat mich auch dazu motiviert, so nach dem Motto, ich fress
heute Abend jetzt nicht noch den Rest vom Mittagessen und sowas. Tatsächlich, das kann
ich mir auch vorstellen. Da passiert, wenn du nämlich jeden Tag siehst, dass deine Gefäße
älter sind als du, dann motiviert das unheimlich dazu, dagegen etwas zu machen. Ich habe mein
Bestes getan, die Daten der Waage gegen zu checken. Erstens, das Gewicht passt perfekt zu den anderen
Wagen, auf die ich Zugriff hatte. Zweitens, der Puls war auch auf den Schlag genau richtig. Drittens,
hat die Bodyscan klinisch validieren lassen. Das heißt, sie ist offiziell als medizinisches
Produkt eingestuft und viertens, ich habe gesehen, dass dieser... Als medizinisches Produkt heißt
nicht, dass man es zur medizinischen Verwendung freigegeben hat. Vermute ich mal, dass es da noch
eine Unterscheidung gibt. Alter, hat er ein Loch im Hals? Nee, das ist einfach nur der Schatten.
Das sah auf den ersten Blick so aus, als hätte er ein Loch im Hals.
Der CEO, der zwei Millionen im Jahr dafür ausgibt, seinen Alterungsprozess umzukehren,
auch jeden Morgen als erstes auf einer Withings-Wage steht, das verdeutlicht ja irgendwie,
dass es nichts genaueres gibt. Aber Spaß beiseite. Alterungsprozess umkehren, ja ist klar,
Kollege, natürlich. Kann ich euch nicht genau sagen, aber selbst wenn es nicht ganz akkurat
Ich würde auch gern meinen Alterungsprozess umkehren, Leute. Also ich definiere, wobei,
heutzutage ist es noch kein Problem. Heute kann doch wirklich jeder sein, was er will.
Ich indemnifiziere mich jetzt einfach als 28-Jährigen. Easy.
Wäre das meiner Meinung nach halb so wild, weil bei diesen Werten geht es ja vor allem darum,
wie sie sich im Laufe der Zeit verändern. Jeden Morgen messe ich mich direkt nach dem Aufstehen
auf leeren Magen, ohne Klamotten, direkt auf dieser Waage und wenn ich dann halt nach einigen
Die Frage ist, vorm oder nachempinkeln?
... plötzlich 17% Körperfett habe, ja dann weiß ich natürlich, dass ich was falsch gemacht habe.
Und diese Waage ist in der Lage, 8 Nutzer zu erkennen und das am Gewicht und sie kann bis
maximal 200 Kilogramm messen und ist auf 50 Gramm genau. Meine Erfahrung bei smarten Produkten ist,
dass die App eine entscheidende Rolle darin hat.
Meine Erfahrung bei smarten Produkten ist, dass die Hersteller gerne wollen, dass man in ihrem
Ökosystem bleibt und ich wette mit euch, dieses Ding hat keine Möglichkeit, offiziell zumindest,
die Daten zu exportieren bzw. in irgendeinem allgemein verständlichem Format rauszubekommen.
Gucken wir gleich mal, gucken wir, wenn das Video fertig ist. Ich könnte wetten, dass es so ist.
Wie gewissenhaft ich etwas nutze. Wenn die App schlecht aussieht und umständlich aufgebaut ist,
dann kann das Produkt eigentlich noch so gut sein, es macht einfach kein Spaß es zu benutzen.
Withings hat aber eine der besten Apps, die ich kenne. Sie ist schön, sie ist verständlich,
sie zeigt die Daten nicht nur einfach an, sie setzt sie auch in Relation und erklärt,
welchen Einfluss sie auf meine Gesundheit haben. Wirklich vorbildlich, wie hier alle Geräte und
mehrere Nutzer integriert werden können. Mit großem Abstand meine liebste App für Gesundheitsdaten
und einer der größten Gründe, warum ich nahezu jedes Withings Produkt privat gekauft habe. Die
Datenspeicherung erfolgt außerdem mit europäischen Richtlinien auf Servern in Frankreich. Das ist ein
nicht ganz... Ja und wenn mal Daten geleakt werden, wird gesagt, ups, wir werden den Vorfall
untersuchen und es passiert uns nicht wieder. Das ist ja bei den meisten Datenleaks bisher so
passiert. Oh nein, wir sind ganz furchtbar traurig, wir haben Daten geleakt, aber jetzt haben wir unsere
Security hochgefahren, jetzt passiert das nie wieder. Bei so sensiblen Informationen, für mich waren die
Daten... So sensibel können die schon mal nicht sein, wenn das mit allen anderen Withings Benutzer
verglichen wird. Am Anfang erzählt, natürlich, wenn man Glück hat, hoffentlich anonymisiert
gespeichert, aber trotzdem, irgendwie wird der Kram ja rausgegeben, sonst könnte man sich nicht
vergleichen mit anderen Usern. Es sei denn, es wird explizit nach Einwilligung gefragt, ja dann okay.
Letzten sechs Monate sehr interessant, weil ich seitdem vegetarisch lebe und wieder regelmäßig
Sport mache. Was ist denn das? Das ist sehr interessant, weil ich...
Das ist Püree? Das sind Erbsen, oder? Sind das Erbsen? So Erbsen-Püree?
Ich glaube, das schmeckt gar nicht schlecht. Ja, was ist das Leute? Sind das Erbsen? Sind das Erbsen
irgendwie püriert oder was ist das? Ich glaube, das schmeckt... Ich meine, das sieht jetzt vielleicht
nicht so wie die Augenweide aus zu essen, aber ich glaube, das schmeckt gar nicht mal so übel.
Seitdem vegetarisch lebe und wieder regelmäßig Sport mache. Ich konnte genau beobachten,
wie ich meine Ernährung anpassen muss und der letzte Monat mit zwei Kilo Gewichtszunahme und
ein Prozent Körperfettverlust sind für mich Bestätigung, dass ich diese Daten praktisch
nutzen konnte. Trotzdem bin ich nicht nur voller Lob, was die App angeht. Ich würde mir wünschen,
dass sie noch mehr Ratschläge für die Gesundheit gibt. Muss ich mehr Cardium machen oder wann es
meine ideale Uhrzeit... Alter, woher soll das meine Waage wissen? Welche Muskelgruppe hat ein
Defizit? Aber jetzt kommen wir zum zweiten großen Kritikpunkt an der Withings Body Scan und das ist
definitiv ihr Preis. Sie kostet 400 Euro. Das ist ein Preis, den sich ganz viele Menschen nicht
leisten können oder wollen. Also ich würde ihn mir nicht leisten wollen. Ich sehe die
Zusatzfunktion aktuell nicht irgendwie als... überzeugen mich nicht, dass die Waage ordentlich
wiegt. Wir hatten übrigens glaube ich nie einen Test, ob die Waage auch wirklich ordentlich wiegt,
oder? Muss auch gar niemand davon überzeugen, sich das Ding zu kaufen. Für die allermeisten
Menschen ist es ganz ohne Zweifel ein kompletter Overkill. Aber es gibt zwei Szenarien, wo ich mir
schon vorstellen kann, dass diese Waage Sinn macht. Erstens, ihr nehmt Bodybuilding ziemlich ernst. So
mit Meal Prep, dem Achten auf die Nährwerte, regelmäßigem Training und dann ist es schon
praktisch zu sehen, wo und wie man Muskeln und Fett zunimmt, oder? Ja, wie gesagt, das kann ich
noch nachvollziehen. Zweitens, ihr seid jemand, wo erbbedingt Herzinfarkte einfach ein häufigeres
Ding sind, oder? Man ist im fortgeschrittenen Alter und man macht halt nicht jährlich diesen Checkup
und hier macht man ihn dann halt täglich und damit kann man definitiv Dinge früh erkennen,
die zu einem frühzeitigen Ableben führen würden. Wer auf die segmentielle Muskelzusammensetzung
und das EKG verzichten kann, der kann für die Hälfte des Geldes, aber auch die Withings Body
Comp kaufen, die auch die Pulswellengeschwindigkeit erkennt. Ich hoffe, dieses Video hier war für euch
hilfreich und informativ und dann sehen wir uns beim nächsten Mal wieder. Ja, okay, jetzt weiß ich
schon mal, dass ich wahrscheinlich keine 400 Euro ausgebe. Wie heißt dieses Ding jetzt genau?
Withings. Wir suchen mal kurz danach. Withings Waage Home Assistant. Okay, man kriegt halt
wirklich was raus. Natürlich nur über die Cloud. Ja, was sonst? Logisch. Und was können die da
jetzt abrufen? Moment, Leute, ist das der gleiche Hersteller mit dem Sensor, was man ins Klo hängt,
mit dem Urinsensor? Was ist das der gleiche Hersteller? Da gab es doch letztens so einen
Hersteller, der einen smarten WC-Stein rausgebracht hat. Sind das die gleichen,
wo man sich doch die Zusammensetzung von seinem Gepinkel angucken kann? Ich glaube,
das sind die gleichen. Okay, ja, also so die Grundvoraussetzung scheint ja schon mal da zu
sein, dass man zumindest über eine AP, hoffe ich mal zumindest, aus seinem Cloud-Account die Sachen
wieder auslesen kann. Das ist ja schon mal besser, als ich gedacht habe. Noch besser
wäre es natürlich, man könnte das lokal irgendwie abgreifen, so die Basic-Werte von der Waage.
Ja. Health, AP, Health, AP, das braucht man nicht. Nokia Health. Allow for Local Network,
das ist von 2011, ja, das bestimmt nicht. Ja, sind die das mit diesem WC-Stein? Ja, das ist es doch.
Das ist es doch. U-Scan. Das ist das Ding, was man ins Klo hängt, draufpinkelt und dann lockt das
irgendwie die Urinzusammensetzung. Also Leute, wenn ihr noch nicht wusstet, ihr könnt jetzt
quasi euer eigenes Klo smart machen, was es nicht alles gibt. Ja, was es nicht alles gibt,
so sieht es aus. Hey Leute, schon wieder? Nein, das reicht jetzt. Zwei, was haben wir hier? I
tried, tolles Startbildschirm, I tried more AI-Tools, it gets crazier. Na, komm.
Was haben wir denn hier? Lohnt sich das, die Arbeit als Personalreferent bei der Stadt? Oje,
Leute. Was auch immer ein Personalreferent macht. Das hatten wir uns schon angeguckt,
das haben wir noch nicht geguckt, den Rest hatten wir, glaube ich, alles geschaut.
Okay, zeig mal, was verdient ein und lohnt sich ein Personalreferent? Ich weiß noch nicht mal,
was ein Personalreferent überhaupt ist.
Ich verdiene auch mehr als ich brauchen würde, aber ich wäre auch nicht mit weniger zufrieden.
Weil, also der Grund ist nicht, weil ich sage, ich will einfach immer mehr haben und das geht
nicht anders, weil der Punkt bei mir ist, ich sehe, was drumherum bezahlt wird und ich sehe es
nicht ein, quasi die gleiche Leistung zu erbringen und weniger dafür zu bekommen. Warum sollte ich
das machen? Ich muss mal kurz die Lautstärke einstellen. Ich verdiene auch deutlich mehr als
ich brauche, also ich wäre auch mit weniger zufrieden. Die Mitarbeiterin wünscht sich ein
bisschen mehr Gehalt, das wird schon sehr genau geprüft. Ich denke nie, oh nein, es ist schon
wieder Montag, sondern im Gegenteil, ich freue mich dann wieder auf die Arbeit und es macht echt
viel Spaß. Wieder abgelehnt. Moin, ich bin Timo, 39 Jahre alt und Personalreferent. Was macht
er denn? Ich stehe jeden Morgen um 4 Uhr auf, weil ich zur Arbeit gehe und dann bin ich um 6.30 auf
der Arbeit. Das hier ist eine Immunkur, die nehme ich, damit ich nicht so schnell krank werde und
schön gesund und fit bleibe. Aktuell habe ich eine Einlegerwohnung bei meinen Eltern und in ein paar
Wochen werde ich umziehen in eine neue Wohnung, ganz hier in der Nähe, zwei Minuten Fußweg vom
Elternhaus entfernt und da freue ich mich schon drauf. Ich gehe jeden Tag zu Fuß zur Arbeit,
wenn der Regen das zulässt, sage ich mal, und das sind dann ungefähr anderthalb Stunden. Ich
habe tatsächlich kein Auto, ich hatte auch noch nie ein Auto. Wenn ich dann mal eins brauche,
miete ich mir eins. Ich habe das beste Auto, Leute, wo wir gerade beim Thema sind. Ich habe es
letztens wieder gemerkt, ich habe einfach das beste Auto, für meinen Zweck wohlgemerkt,
ja, für meinen Zweck. Ich sage jetzt nicht, dass es das beste Auto allgemein, für meinen Zweck das
beste Auto. Ich habe es letztens erst wieder beim Einkaufen gemerkt, so ein kleines Auto ist einfach
poggers. Ich laufe auch viel zu Fuß wegen mehr Bewegung und Kreislauf und alles. Hast du einen?
Ja, ich habe einen Fiat 500e und ich habe erst letztens wieder gemerkt, dass es einfach ein
richtig poggers Auto ist. Du fährst so ziemlich, zumindest so bis zu 50, 60, 70 Stundenkilometer,
ja, fährst du erst mal allem weg. Im Stadtverkehr ist das wunderbar und ich habe es letztens erst
wieder beim Einkaufen gemerkt, wie nice das ist. So ein kleines, so klein ist das gar nicht, ja,
aber beim Einkaufen ist es immer noch wunderbar, dass man auch, wenn der Parkplatz voll ist und
eine Lücke ist, man da easy reinkommt in die Lücke, ohne irgendwie dreimal hin und zurückfahren zu
müssen. Es ist schon sehr, sehr nice. Also so klein ist der Fiat 500e, ja, auch gar nicht.
Der sieht vielleicht klein aus, aber der ist auch schon relativ breit, ja, ich weiß nicht,
wie breit das ist, 4 Meter oder so, aber 4 Meter lang, ich weiß gar nicht. 3, genau, ja.
Ja, genau, irgendwie um die 4 Meter lang habe ich mir gemerkt, genau. Also der ist schon ein
bisschen breiter als mein Alter. Das stimmt, glaube ich, gar nicht, was hier steht. Stimmt
nicht, das stimmt nicht. Der E, das ist der normale, der E ist breiter. Genau, da kommen
noch Spiegel dabei und solche Geschichten, ja, genau, genau. Also der ist gar nicht so klein,
wie er auf den ersten Blick aussieht, ja. Nicht 4 Meter, 4 Meter lang, ich weiß nicht,
wie ich auf 4 Meter breit komme, aber ja, genau, irgendwie so was, mit Außenspiegel fast. Also der
ist so breit, dass ich in die alte Garage, die der Opa mal gebaut hat, gar nicht reinkomme.
Aber trotzdem, beim Einkaufen ist es nice und ich merke es immer wieder, dass es ein sehr angenehmes,
für mich ist der schon klein, natürlich, wenn er das mit irgendwelchen fetten Autos vergleicht,
aber er ist nicht klein, so wie man sich das früher so ein paar Kleinwagen vorgestellt hat.
Also der normale 500 ist beispielsweise deutlich schmaler als der 500e. Aber ich merke es immer
wieder, dass es eine gute Entscheidung war, das Auto zu kaufen. 800 Kalorien zu verbrauchen.
800 Kalorien. Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss,
ich muss mal kurz gucken, was hat er denn gelernt? Also BWL Studium, MonkaS. Wir brauchen ein Monka
BWL. Wir haben kein Monka BWL. E-Mode, nicht mal irgendwie ansatzweise was. Sechs Jahre BWL
Studium. Ein E-Sport Startup. Da bin ich mal gespannt, was da geht. Okay, nice. Ja, Toss,
Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss. Moin. Hallo. Wenn ich bei den Stadtwerken anfange,
ist meistens schon das meiste vorgeplant. Aber es können immer Sachen dazwischen kommen.
Krankheitsfälle oder so ein Vorstellungsgespräch sich verschiebt. Als Personalreferent ist die
Hauptaufgabe, Geschäftsbereiche zu betreuen, mit sich mit den Führungskräften abzustimmen. Also
Personalplanung, Personalentwicklung, Personalcontrolling, Personalbeschaffung,
solche Dinge. Jetzt haben wir ein Mitarbeitergespräch und da geht es jetzt los. Wie wäre es eigentlich,
jetzt mal so eine ganz ketzerische Frage. Wie wäre es denn, wenn das Mitarbeitergespräch von Leuten
geführt wird, die wissen, was der jeweilige Mitarbeiter macht und nicht so ein abstrakter
Personal tut oder zumindest mal zusammen mit einem, der weiß, was der Mitarbeiter so macht. Was kann
dann der Personaldut einschätzen, wie gut, wie schlecht, wie erfolgreich und so was? Wie soll
das funktionieren? Mein gut, der Chef kann dann irgendwie was notieren, was der Typ sich
vorher durchgelesen hat, aber das ist doch... Na, okay, gucken wir mal.
Wir sprechen jetzt mit einer Mitarbeiterin, die sich gut geschlagen hat. Die Mitarbeiterin wünscht
sich ein bisschen mehr Gehalt, auch aufgrund ihrer guten Leistungen, die sie gezeigt hat.
Wünschen klingt immer so nach dem Motto, ja, wenn es nicht klappt, ist ja auch nicht schlimm,
die hat es wahrscheinlich schlicht und ergreifend verdient. Schön, dass du da bist. Wird in einem
Platz. Genau, wir sprechen heute über den Wunsch, den du hattest, den der Höhergruppierung. Genau,
und da würde ich dir gerne Feedback zu geben. Wir unterliegen ja dem Tarifrecht bei den
Stadtwerken, deswegen ist es nicht immer einfach, eine Höhergruppierung zu kriegen.
Ja, deswegen findet ihr auch keine gescheiten Leute gerade in der IT. Genau geprüft. Ich hatte
tatsächlich einmal einen Mitarbeiter... Leute, ich habe jetzt letztens... Weird Flex,
ich gebe... Wobei, nee, ich würde Flexe jetzt nicht. Ich, der sich vorgestellt hat, direkt drei
Entgeltstufe nach oben zu springen, und das fand ich persönlich dann schon ein bisschen irritierend.
Ich habe mich mehr mit deinen Jungs... Je nachdem, was hat er für einen gehabt? Ich hatte tatsächlich
einmal einen Mitarbeiter in einem Gespräch, der sich vorgestellt hat, direkt drei Entgeltstufe
nach oben. Wahrscheinlich hat er mal geguckt, wahrscheinlich arbeitet der Typ in der IT,
hat mal geguckt, was drumherum so bezahlt werden und festgestellt, damit ich ähnlich was verdiene
wie dort, müsste ich hier drei Entgeltstufe überspringen. Um zu springen, und das fand ich
persönlich dann schon ein bisschen irritierend. Ich habe mich mehr mit deiner Führungskraft
abgestimmt. Okay, okay, das ist schon mal gut. Okay, die Kombination macht natürlich Sinn,
wobei man halt sagen muss, es wäre aus meiner Sicht jetzt die Aufgabe der Führungskraft,
also wenn die der Meinung ist, dass das guter Mitarbeiter ist und dass die mehr verdienen,
sich jetzt für diese Mitarbeiterin einzusetzen, zum Beispiel, dass er in dem Gespräch dabei ist,
falls er nicht so gedacht ist, dass die Führungskraft sagt, ja, ich unterstütze das und nicht,
dass der Mitarbeiter zum Chef gehen muss, sagen bitte, bitte, und dann nochmal zum
Personalgehen sagen muss und bitte, bitte, sondern dass der Mitarbeiter überzeugt in seiner Arbeit,
was er macht, vielleicht noch mal seinem Chef sagt, alle, es wird mal wieder Zeit,
der Chef sagt, jawoll, ich unterstütze das und dass der Chef das dann auch vorantritt,
dafür ist er doch da, dafür ist eine Führungskraft doch da unter anderem, so was zu machen.
Und sind mit deinen Ergebnissen sehr zufrieden tatsächlich?
Das freut mich.
Dann, vielen Dank und wir freuen uns natürlich, dass wir deinem Wunsch nachkommen konnten und auf die weitere gute Zusammenarbeit.
Und wie viel gibt es jetzt? Und wie viel gibt es jetzt unterm Strich?
Ist klar, bis dann, tschüss.
Das sind viele Personalgespräche, die machen am meisten Spaß, wenn man natürlich auch Wünsche
erfüllen kann und natürlich auch sieht, dass es sinnvoll ist, diesen Wunsch zu erfüllen,
einfach weil die Leistung auch sehr gut ist und die Verantwortung höher ist als vorher.
Nach links, das andere links.
Okay, ich bin vielleicht ein bisschen zu fies.
Ich habe mit den Leuten aus meiner alten Personalabteilung keine allzu guten Erfahrungen gemacht.
Ich bin da, wobei ich sagen muss, bisher von den Neuen habe ich tatsächlich einen sehr guten Eindruck.
Die haben sogar eine Hotline, die man anrufen kann bei Fragen, was Organisation und Personalsachen,
Urlaubsplanung und so was angeht.
Vielleicht bin ich jetzt ein bisschen zu hart.
Wir kriegen ja auch nicht wirklich was von mit.
Das muss jetzt nicht heißen, dass es irgendwie schlecht ist oder so.
Ich sehe da wahrscheinlich das Negative vielleicht ein bisschen zu präsent bei solchen Dingern,
aber ich glaube trotzdem, dass es bei vielen Unternehmen zu boomermäßig läuft,
gerade was so Gehaltsverhandlungen angeht.
Weil mal ehrlich gesagt unterm Strich, geht es doch bei Personal haben halt keinen guten Ruf.
Ja, das stimmt.
Es geht doch da um viel mehr als bitte, bitte, ich hätte gern mehr Geld und ja,
wir sind nett und geben dir was.
Das wirkt immer so, aber das ist es doch eigentlich nicht.
Selbst wenn jemand lange Jahre dabei ist und einfach nur seinen Job gut macht,
kann der Arbeitgeber ja diese Arbeitskraft zu Geld machen.
Und jetzt gerade in Zeiten von Inflation und sonst was kann der Arbeitgeber diese
Arbeitskraft auch zu zumindest in Zahlen mehr Geld machen.
Weil er selbstverständlich die Services, die der Arbeitgeber anbietet
oder die Produkte, die der Arbeitgeber verkauft oder was auch immer unterm Strich
dann auch teurer werden oder für mehr verkauft werden.
Das heißt, aus diesem Gesichtspunkt muss dann schon mal der Mitarbeiter für so eine
Anpassung, was Inflation angeht, eigentlich es reicht, wenn er seinen Job auch in schwierigen
Zeiten gut macht, um ihm eine Anpassung zu geben.
Da muss er nicht noch tausend Sachen mehr machen.
Der kann ja die Arbeitskraft nach wie vor zu Geld machen und bekommt selbst unterm Strich
mehr raus, also in Zahl.
Also allein schon aus dem Gesichtspunkt.
Er kann die Arbeit weiterhin zu Geld machen und wenn jemand langjährig dabei ist.
Der kennt die Firma besser, der hat mehr Skills sich angeeignet,
der kann vielleicht effektiver arbeiten, hat seine Kenntnisse erweitert.
Der kriegt die Sachen viel besser hin wie jemand, der kurz dabei ist und solche Geschichten.
Und wenn es nicht so eine automatische Erhöhung gibt, leckt Vodafone mal gucken.
Vodafone leckt nicht, es leckt bei dir.
Nichts, nichts, gedroppt.
Droppen keine Frames.
Und wenn es keine automatische Erhöhung mit der Zeit gibt, dann ist das vollkommen berechtigt
zu sagen, hey, insgesamt hat sich das verbessert und ich muss keine Führungssachen übernehmen,
keine Projektplanung übernehmen, kein irgendwie sonst was machen dafür.
Man ist einfach effektiver und ich finde, da kann man durchaus auch schon mal sagen,
okay, das ist es wert, dass man dem dann auch mehr bezahlen.
Dazu kommt noch und das sind zwei ganz wichtige Faktoren, wo ich denke,
dass was viele Unternehmen unterschätzen, erstens mehr Gehalt motiviert die Leute.
Es ist gar nicht so sehr, wie sich das zumindest Boomer-Chefs habe ich den Eindruck vorstellen.
So nach dem Motto, die Leute können froh sein, dass sie Geld kriegen und so lange sie Geld
bekommen, haben sie gefälligst 100% motiviert zu sein und mehr Geld gibt es nicht, es sei denn,
die machen noch viel krasses Zeug mehr, wo ich noch viel mehr davon habe,
sondern es ist einfach auch eine Motivation zu sagen, hey guck mal, wir sehen jetzt,
du machst die Sachen gut und das und das wurde erreicht mit deiner Beteiligung zum Beispiel,
dass man sagt, okay, gibt jetzt mehr Kohle, weil die Hauptmotivation, warum Leute arbeiten gehen,
ist natürlich sicherlich auch Anerkennung so ein bisschen vom Umfeld, aber ist ihr Gehalt und
ohne dass die in Vorleistung gehen müssen, so nach dem Motto, ich habe jetzt das und das und das und
das, wenn man sagt, okay, das ist gut gelaufen, du warst daran maßgeblich beteiligt, wie auch immer,
kann man durchaus sagen, ja, gibt es ein bisschen mehr Geld, es muss gar nicht so viel sein,
das motiviert die Leute einfach und von motivierten Leuten hat ein Arbeitgeber mehr als von permanent
genervten Leuten und ein paar gesparten Euros, ist zumindest meine Ansicht und der zweite Punkt
ist und er ist gerade in der IT enorm wichtig und mein alter Arbeitgeber merkt das gerade,
es rennen einem die Leute nicht weg, wenn man sie ordentlich bezahlt, wenn man sie nicht ordentlich
bezahlt und sie merken, dass man drumherum zwei Haustüren weiter, 50%, ist übertrieben, 50% mehr
kriegt, dann werden die sich sagen, ja gut, warum gehe ich nicht einfach zwei Haustüren weiter,
50% ist übertrieben, um eine Hausnummer zu sagen, ich kriege zwei Haustüren weiter,
30% mehr, habe vielleicht sogar noch interessantere Aufgaben als hier und vielleicht noch ein paar
andere Vorteile, die mich interessieren, da gehe ich einfach woanders hin, also ordentliches Gehalt
zu bezahlen, gerade in der IT oder in gefragten Bereichen, ist natürlich auch eine Maßnahme,
die man treffen kann, damit einem die Leute nicht wegrennen. Ja genau, das ist ja immer die
Standardsache, Gehaltserhöhung ist, weil Corona, es ist schwierig, schwierige wirtschaftliche Lage,
blablabla, also wie gesagt, ich denke von motivierten Mitarbeitern hat ein Unternehmen meistens mehr als
auf jeden Sinn zu gucken und wenn sie nicht wollen, dass einem gerade qualifizierte Leute in der IT oder
auch in anderen, wo es ein bisschen schwierig ist, Leute zu finden, wegrennen, müssen die die auch
mehr bezahlen, wo es natürlich kein Problem ist, ist im Personalbereich wahrscheinlich oder im
Managementbereich, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass aktuell mehr Leute für Managementpositionen
Schlangen stehen als für IT Positionen. Würdet ihr diese Einschätzung teilen, Leute? Ich weiß
es nicht, ob das stimmt, also eine Sache sind wir uns einig, gute Manager gibt es ganz wenig,
also von vielen, die sich bewerben, die das auch machen in vielen Unternehmen, können es nicht.
Es gibt wenige gute Manager, es gibt auch wenige gute Führungskräfte, es gibt ein paar gute,
bisher hatte ich tatsächlich auch den einen oder anderen, wo ich sagen würde und muss auch sagen,
oder sage ich jetzt nicht, so nach dem, vielleicht guckt jemand von der Arbeit den Stream zu,
bisher habe ich auch von meinem aktuellen Chef und auch von der Personalabteilung und das schon
bevor ich angefangen habe, dort wo ich jetzt arbeite, den Eindruck, dass sie wissen, was sie
machen. Gerade von der Personalabteilung ist wirklich krasser Unterschied, beim alten Arbeitnehmer
war die Personalabteilung wirklich krass unfähig, die haben es ja nicht mal rechtzeitig hinbekommen,
mir alles auszustellen, bis ich fertig war und das Zeugnis habe ich auch nur gekriegt, wahrscheinlich
weil ich am letzten Tag hochgegangen bin und gesagt habe, Alter jetzt gib mal her. So und beim neuen
hat das schon im Vorfeld besser geklappt als beim alten. Nun ja, aber ich würde tatsächlich
vermuten, dass für Managementpositionen es deutlich einfacher ist Leute zu finden, also für Projektmanager
oder so was, Projektleiter oder Teamleiter, einfacher Leute zu finden ist als für anspruchsvolle
IT-Positionen. Besonders bei der jungen Generation wiegt glaube ich die Freizeit vor Karriere,
ja haben sie ja auch recht, niemand der gesagt bekommt, Herr XY, Sie sterben in zwei Stunden,
was auch immer, warum auch immer das sein könnte, wird sich denken, oh shit, Alter, jetzt noch mal
kurz Remote auf der Arbeit einloggen oder wird sich denken, so Mist, hätte ich mal die letzten
Jahre über mehr gearbeitet, ja, wirklich wahrscheinlich nicht. Im unteren Management,
ich rede nur vom unteren Management, ab Abteilungsleiter und ab, sieht das tatsächlich
schon wieder anders aus mit geeigneten Kandidaten und Leuten, die das machen wollen, das wollen
auch wenige machen, das auch zurecht. Das ist ja auch so ein Thema, wo ich das Gehate und Geflame
immer nicht ganz nachvollziehen kann. Es wird auch öffentlich, sei es jetzt Twitter ist natürlich
dabei oder auch in Nachrichten, es wird immer so negativ darüber berichtet, dass irgendwelche
Manager super krasse Gehälter bekommen. Sicherlich kann man sagen, wenn man das vergleicht, ja,
was bekommt irgendwie der CEO versus der Typ, der in der Produktionshalle arbeitet, klar,
das sind krasse Gehaltsunterschiede. Okay, es ist aber, finde ich, eine ganz andere Diskussion und
auch gar nicht die richtige Diskussion an der Stelle, wenn es um Manager-Gehälter geht. Die
eigentliche Diskussion sollte nicht sein, wir flamen Top-Manager, von denen es ja wirklich
nicht so viele gibt, es ist ja auch nicht so, dass so ein Unternehmen irgendwie 500 Positionen für
Top-Manager hätte. Man sollte nicht die Manager flamen, dafür, dass sie einfach ihr Gehalt sich
überweisen lassen. Wenn man irgendjemand flamen müsste, dann den Vorstand beziehungsweise die
Leute, die den Vertrag mit dem Typ gemacht haben. Weil es ist ja nicht so, dass der Manager sagt,
ach ja, ich hätte jetzt gern das und dann bekommt er das. Der hat ja einen ganz normalen Arbeitsvertrag
beziehungsweise einen Vertrag mit Konditionen und Bonuszahlen und sonst was, die an Bedingungen
geknüpft sind. Also wenn du dich über Manager-Gehälter aufregst, dann solltest du dich nicht über den
Manager aufregen, der einfach nur das haben will, was er vertraglich vereinbart hat, sondern über
die, die den Vertrag mit ihm gemacht haben. Es wird total oft auf Manager herumgehackt und natürlich,
ich verstehe, ich verstehe das Geflame schon, wenn man dann sagt, okay, es mussten jetzt so und so
viele Leute entlassen werden und manche mussten in Zeitarbeit geschickt werden und sonst was,
aber der Manager, der nimmt seinen Bonus. Die Kritik kann ich schon verstehen und natürlich
könnte der Manager auch sagen, ich verzichte da drauf für den besseren Betriebsfrieden irgendwie,
könnte er machen, muss er aber nicht, solange es in seinem Vertrag steht und ich finde es auch nicht,
wie soll ich sagen, nicht verwerflich, das zu machen oder auf das zu bestehen, was in dem Vertrag
geregelt ist. Also wenn ich jetzt die Möglichkeit habe, mal angenommen, ich habe einen Bonus in
meinem Vertrag vereinbart, so nach dem Motto, wenn ich das und das erreiche, bekomme ich einen
Monatsgehalt mehr. So sagen wir jetzt mal einfach mal als Beispiel und ich habe das erreicht,
aber dem Unternehmen geht es schlecht oder manche oder sonst wie. Ja, natürlich könnte ich dann
sagen, ich verzichte da freiwillig auf mein Monatsgehalt, aber würdet ihr das machen?
Würdet ihr so, ich weiß nicht, kommt ein bisschen auf die Umstände an, aber wahrscheinlich nicht.
Wahrscheinlich würde ich das nicht machen. Wahrscheinlich würde ich auch sagen,
Gäpp die Kohle her, steht im Vertrag drin. Also insofern. Ja, also man sollte sich bei diesen
ganzen Diskussionen so nach dem Motto verdienen, Manager zu viel immer fragen, wer hat denn den
Vertrag mit dem Typ gemacht? Wer hat den Vertrag mit dem Typ gemacht und aus welchem Grund wurde
der Vertrag mit dem Typ gemacht? Vielleicht haben sie einfach keinen geeigneten gefunden,
der es für weniger macht. Kann ja auch sein. Und ich kann mir auch gut ungefähr vorstellen,
wie so eine Verhandlung läuft. Da kommt dann der Typ rein und sagt, wenn ich den Job bekomme,
dann verspreche ich ihnen innerhalb von zwei Jahre Steigerung im Bereich XY um 80 Prozent. Dann haben
die Typen natürlich im Vorstand kompletten und im Aufsichtssatz und sonst wo komplette Dollarzeichen
in den Augen und denken, krass, das heißt ja, wir kriegen auch 80 Prozent mehr, den holen wir uns.
Oder wie auch immer. So in der Richtung könnte es vielleicht laufen. Vielleicht haben sie auch
schlicht und ergreifend keinen anderen gefunden, der es für die Kohle machen will. Also ich weiß
nicht. Ja, man kann sich über Managergehälter aufregen, aber man sollte sich oftmals auch nicht so
sehr über die Manager aufregen, die einfach nur darauf pochen, dass das, was im Vertrag steht,
eingehalten wird. Man sollte sich viel eher fragen, wer hat diese Verträge überhaupt gemacht? Wer
hat diese Verträge überhaupt abgesegnet? Und wenn ich sehe, dass teilweise im öffentlichen
Rundfunk irgendwelche Leute Verträge haben, die ihnen 180.000 Euro Pension im Jahr oder so was
zu sichern oder einen Gehalt von 400.000 Euro und so. Da kann man sich dann schon so wirklich
fragen, wer macht diese Verträge eigentlich? Ich bin jetzt weniger sauer auf den Typ, dass
er das haben will, was er in seinem Vertrag stehen hat, aber wer macht diese Verträge denn? Du
findest doch garantiert Leute, die das auch für weniger gut machen, oder? Wie auch immer. Wir
sind jetzt ein bisschen abgeschwiffen. Ja, wir sind ein bisschen abgeschwiffen vom eigentlichen
Thema. Weiter. Wir sind verstehen geblieben hier. Jetzt gehen wir einmal raus rüber zum
Kraftwerk und besprechen mit dem Geschäftsbereichsleiter für Projekte und Anlagenbau,
was so an neuen Projekten ansteht und welcher Personalbedarf sich daraus ergeben kann.
Moin. Also das hier, was wir hier sehen, ist der sogenannte Kessel 13. Das ist eine Gasturbine und
für solche Projekte suche ich zum Beispiel Personal. Ich bin in den ersten drei Monaten
rausgefahren mit Monture. Ich würde gerne mal eine Stellenanzeige sehen, die er geschrieben hat.
Ob das eine Stellenanzeige ist, wo ich denken würde, ey, dafür würde ich den Personaler
Geld bezahlen. So eine Reversebewertung durchführen. Das ist übrigens auch ein Punkt,
das muss ich jetzt einfach noch mal sagen. Das passiert immer noch viel zu wenig. Reversebewertung.
Ich finde, das ist genauso wichtig wie umgedreht. Also wenn es darum geht, so nach dem Motto zu
sagen, hey, welche Ziele setze ich mir für die Firma und wie gut habe ich das und das gemacht.
Ich finde es auch umgedreht wichtig, dass es eine Reversebewertung gibt. Wie gut findet man denn,
so den Weg, den die Firma eingeschlagen hat, wie gut finde ich denn, dass mein Chef,
wie gut führt er das Team, wie klar sind die Aufgaben gestellt und sowas in der Richtung.
Das finde ich auch wichtig und wird aus meiner Sicht viel zu wenig, viel zu selten gemacht. Und
ich finde, eine der Kenngrößen, woran man so einen Personaler durchaus messen könnte,
falls das zu seinen Aufgabenbereichen gehört, ist, wie erfolgreich sind denn die Stellenanzeigen,
die er erstellt. Bewirbt sich da jemand drauf? Wenn ja, taugen die was? Wie hoch ist die Quote
dessen an Bewerbern? Was findet man? Ist ja durchaus was, wo man den Personaler mal daran
messen könnte. Okay, du bist hier bei uns fürs Recruiting zuständig. Wie gut klappt das denn eigentlich?
Es gibt wirklich von ihm geschriebene Stellenanzeigen.
Wait a minute, da muss ich jetzt kurz reingucken. Ich habe halt von dem Job überhaupt keine Ahnung,
aber okay.
Ah, jetzt geht's, okay. Was, was auch immer, jetzt geht's. Okay, also hier, Stadtwerke,
Flensburg, GmbH, Jobs. Suchen die irgendwas IT-mäßiges, wo ich was zu sagen kann?
Okay, was haben die denn so? Der Link geht. Ja, ich bekomme zu dem Blogpost von ihm und dann
hier Public Text über uns, das habe ich doch auch gerade. Suchen die irgendwas IT-mäßiges,
wo ich was zu sagen kann? Nö, na gut.
Dann wird's schwierig, dass ich, na kann ich nichts zu sagen. Okay, wo sind wir stehengeblieben jetzt?
Ah, okay, wir gucken, das wird jetzt fertig. Ich habe mir angeguckt, wie die Rohre verlegt werden.
Ich habe mir die Projekte, die die großen meinen. Was habt ihr immer mit zu vielen Tabs? Das ist
doch optimal. Guck mal, man sieht sogar den Text noch. Wir gucken auch die Gas-Turbinen und das sind
halt Dinge einfach, ich muss es gesehen haben. Was machen die Menschen? Wie feingliedrig ist das?
Ist es eher grob oder feinmotorisch? Ist es eher Kopfarbeit oder physische Arbeit? Einfach,
um zu begreifen als Personaler, was suche ich da eigentlich? Und das ist wirklich essenziell in
meinen Augen. Finde ich gut, dass er das macht. Gibt genug Personaler, die absolut keinen Plan
von dem eigentlichen Job haben, wofür sie Leute suchen. Also das finde ich, so ist er. Hut ab,
dass er sich das auch alles anguckt. Based, sagt man doch da heute zu, oder? Da brauchen wir
eher dringend eine Verstärkung im Bereich EMSR und E-Technik. Genau, also E-Technik für die
GUD-Anlage und für den Wärmespeicher, dann E-Anbauingenieur. Das Ziel ist, für die
jeweilige Position, die wir in diesem Gespräch dann besprochen haben, den richtigen Kandidaten
zu finden. Deswegen habe ich die Qualifikation zum Beispiel auch abgefragt und dann eben zu gucken,
wo wir denjenigen bekommen und wann wir ihn auch bekommen. Neues Personal für gerade Anlagenbau
und Projekte zu finden, das ist schon eine Herausforderung. Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Weil qualifizierte Menschen sind, die heiß begehrt sind am Arbeitsmarkt. Der Wettbewerb unter
Unternehmen, was die Fachkräfte angeht, ist sehr hart. Also wir haben viele Fachkräfte, die fehlen.
Ich persönlich würde mir auch ein kleiner Tipp, wenn man den Leuten ordentlich was bezahlt,
da kommen die auch zu einem. Schönes Zuwanderungsgesetz. Hab ich gehört. Ich wünsche,
damit wir einfach mehr qualifizierte Menschen aus dem Ausland hierher bekommen. Der
Verdrängungswettbewerb, auch was gerade Fachkräfte angeht. Menschen aus dem Ausland
bekommen ist ja nicht das Problem. Qualifizierte Leute aus dem Ausland bekommen,
das ist tatsächlich nicht das Problem, weil viele haben auch überhaupt keinen Bock nach
Deutschland zu kommen. Das ist wirklich immens. Wollen wir rübergehen? Qualifiziere. Ist für
Nutella auf der? Gab es da nicht letztens vom Lindner so einen schönen Clip? Wobei ich nicht
weiß. Vielleicht ist vielleicht auch Fake. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, weil ich habe das irgendwo
auf Twitter gesehen. Kann durchaus sein, dass es Fake ist. Gab es da nicht letztens vom Lindner
sogar irgendeinen Clip, wo er in Nigeria oder so in irgendeiner afrikanischen Uni war und
geschwärmt hat vom Industriestandort Deutschland und danach gefragt hat im Hörsaal, wer von euch
könnte sich vorstellen, so eine Greencard-Geschichte in Deutschland zu machen und alle
so hat sich im gesamten Hörsaal irgendwie irgendwie ein Typ, ein Typ gemeldet oder so.
Glauben wir, als Personaler bekommt man schon sehr viele krasse Probleme mit,
auch von Menschen, die jetzt nicht unbedingt direkt was mit der Arbeit zu tun haben,
die Probleme. Das kann Alkoholkonsum sein, Missbrauch, also Alkoholmissbrauch.
Habe ich auch mal bei einem mitgekriegt auf der Arbeit. Da gehe ich jetzt allerdings nicht
so sehr ins Detail. Ich will ja nicht, dass man sich frei und irgendwas davon ableiten kann.
Das habe ich auch mitgekriegt bei einem. Der hat sich ein bisschen zu auf die Kante gegeben.
Der arbeitet auch nicht mehr da. Also ich rede nicht von meinem aktuellen Arbeitgeber,
sondern von einem davor. Der hat sich ein bisschen zu auf die Kante gegeben und der ist mittlerweile
auch nicht mehr da. Und an einem Tag, ich glaube, was auch so der ausschlaggebende Punkt war,
warum man ihm dann, sag mal mal, es nahegelegt hat, sich mal Hilfe zu suchen, was du ja als
Arbeitgeber so gar nicht darfst. Du darfst ja nicht sagen, ich habe mitgekriegt, du haust dir zu oft
einen rein, geh mal in Behandlung oder so. Offiziell ist es sehr schwierig, was du da
als Arbeitgeber sagen darfst, du machst nicht. Ich sage auch, okay. Man hat ihm dann nahegelegt,
er könnte doch mal er könnte doch mal sich in Therapie begeben und man bezahlt ihm irgendwie
auch drei Monate oder so. Dann davon noch war eigentlich recht entgegenkommt. Zumindest der
ausschlaggebende Punkt bei ihm ist gewesen, dass an einem Morgen im Büro der gesamte Schreibtisch
voll mit so Einwegbierdosen stand. Der hat auch öfters, der ist auch, hat auch wohl öfters in,
habe ich erst im Nachhinein mitbekommen, der hat wohl öfters auch in der Firma gepennt,
dann irgendwie bei uns hinten in dem einen Raum. Zumindest am einem Morgen muss man so gewesen sein,
der gesamte Schreibtisch stand voll mit Bierdosen und der Chef kam dann halt morgens rein und hat
das gesehen. Der wusste das vorher auch schon, aber das ist halt solche Ausnahmen und da haben
sie ihm zumindest mal nahegelegt. Also wir bezahlen ja auch noch, also wir bezahlen ja auch drei Monate
irgendwie Urlaub oder wie auch immer, Kur oder keine Ahnung unter was das läuft, aber mach doch
mal eine Therapie. Und der war dann auch drei Monate weg und ich weiß nicht, wie gut das bei
ihm funktioniert hat, ob das irgendwie angeschlagen hat oder nicht. Der war dann irgendwann wieder da,
aber er hat wohl irgendwie nicht gefruchtet und nach einem halben Jahr war er dann ganz komplett weg.
Ich meine, wenn es schon so weit ist, dass man den Arbeitsschreibtisch voller Einweg,
so Bierdosen hat, dann ist es halt schon irgendwie offensichtlich, dass man es nicht mehr im Griff
hat. Das war wirklich schon entgegenkommend und ich glaube, das war auch nur entgegenkommend,
weil damals noch sein alter Chef da war, den sie dann selbst gekickt haben, kurze Zeit später,
der tatsächlich sich noch für persönliche Belange und Probleme der Leute interessiert hat.
Also das war so eines der härtesten Fälle, die ich da bei uns auf der Arbeit mitgekriegt
habe. Also der hat es wirklich gar nicht mehr im Griff gehabt. Okay, gucken wir mal weiter.
Impressionen sein oder andere Erkrankungen, die man jetzt nicht sofort sieht, dann biete ich
erstmal ein Gespräch an und sage, was ist das Problem und dann wird erstmal darauf hingewiesen,
dass wir eben auch einen sozialen Dienst haben und dass es aber auch außerhalb unseres Unternehmens
ja Hilfsangebote gibt. Jetzt spreche ich mit einer Kollegin. Finde ich ganz gut, dass ihnen das nicht,
also wenn das auch in der Praxis so gemacht wird, wie er das jetzt sagt und nicht nur aus Werbekunden,
finde ich das tatsächlich ganz gut, wenn sie da versuchen, auch bei persönlichen Problemen,
wenn die Mitarbeiter das wollen, sie zu unterstützen, finde ich nice, wenn man da
zumindest mal erwähnt, dass es Möglichkeiten gibt. Du kannst ja keinem vorschreiben, du musst
es jetzt machen, aber man kann es ja durchaus erwähnen, wenn es da was gibt. Wir sind aus
der Personalabteilung über Elternzeit und wie wir die Elternzeit danach besetzen möchten. Hallo.
Wir haben einen Antrag auf Elternzeit bekommen und sie möchte gerne also anderthalb Jahre in
Elternzeit. Sie? Wie jetzt? Ich dachte, das heißt jetzt gebärende Person. Einfach jetzt hier. Es
zoomt wieder. Ja, das mache ich schon. Das ist früh. Okay, genau, dann würde ich dich bitten,
vielleicht einmal rauszusuchen, welche Qualifikation sie hat. Dann prüfe ich das einmal und dann können
wir uns wieder abstimmen. Perfekt, dann mach ich das. Kann ich einfach in seinem Note, auf seinem
Desktop einfach mal kurz den Namen eingeben, dann siehst du den Bereich oder? Na gut, vielleicht
verheigt er noch mehr dran. Super, ich danke dir. Bis dann, tschüss. Und das ist auch so eine
grundsätzliche Aufgabe, die ich habe, mich darum zu kümmern, dass Nachbesetzungen erfolgen. Das
kann aus unterschiedlichen Gründen sein, zum Beispiel Elternzeit, langfristige Erkrankungen
oder auch Mitarbeiter, die mal kündigen. Ich verdiene rund. Gibt es da überhaupt eine
Entscheidungsmöglichkeit? Nein, ich glaube nicht, dass man das absagen kann. Ich glaube,
worum es Ihnen geht, ist jetzt zu gucken, was die macht. Ja, ich glaube, es geht eben nicht darum,
dass man das ablehnen kann. Ablehnen können sie das nicht. Es geht darum, wie die das besetzen in
der Zeit, wenn die nicht da ist bzw. auch über darüber hinaus. Wer weiß ja nicht, ob die wiederkommt
bzw. ob sie im gleichen Bereich arbeiten wird, wenn sie wiederkommt. Das habe ich auch sie gesagt.
Also es geht glaube ich darum, dass man das fürs Unternehmen möglichst reibungsfrei gestaltet,
diese Elternzeit nicht, um zu sagen, es gibt keine Elternzeit, weil geht ja nicht. Kannst ja nicht
sagen, gibt es nicht. 5500 Euro brutto und ungefähr 3200 Euro netto. Ah, ist okay. Wie viel? Er ist
immer die Frage, wie viele Monatsgehälter? Also 5500 mal 12 ist in Ordnung. Das ist jetzt nicht
die Welt, wobei man halt sagen muss, der muss wahrscheinlich auch in diesem Ding dann nicht so
viel Steuern bezahlen, weiß ich nicht. 500 Euro brutto. Und am Ende hat er 3000. Ja, okay.
Okay, jetzt an der Stelle Weirdflex. Weirdflex muss jetzt einfach mal sein, weil es ganz gut passt.
Ich habe letztens bei mir in das Gehaltsabrechnungsportal reingeguckt und heute
mir ist gar nicht klar gewesen, wie viel Kohle das im Monat bedeutet. Also ich habe
ja schon ein Video drüber gemacht, es ist ja nichts Geheimes. Ich habe ja schon im Video erzählt,
wie viel es jetzt letztendlich ist. Und sogar im Stream haben mir Leute schon erzählt, Max,
das ist ja enorm viel Geld, aber ich habe es jetzt erst zum ersten Mal so richtig schwarz
auf weiß gesehen. Also wenn man das hochrechnet, sind das sind das mit Bonus brutto ungefähr
7900 Euro brutto im Monat mit Bonus mit Bonus. Es ist nicht klar, dass es alles Bonus gibt.
Und netto habe ich ungefähr 3700 Euro im Monat bei 3500 Euro glaub ich. Ich glaube 3700 war es
irgendwie bei vier Tage Woche netto. Das ist schon, da kannst du dich schon nicht beschweren.
Das ist schon enorm viel. Ich wusste es zwar theoretisch, aber es ist schon echt ordentlich.
Es wird jetzt erst, als ich in das Portal geguckt habe und die Zahl gesehen habe,
klar geworden. Also muss ich mal überlegen. Das ist bei vier Tage Woche, also bei 80 Prozent,
bei 80 Prozent, quasi nochmal irgendwie 20 Prozent von dem hier. Also es ist schon krass.
Wo wir wieder beim eigentlichen Thema sind, ich wollte jetzt gar nicht weird flexen im Stream.
Es kann sich durchaus lohnen, gerade wenn man im IT Bereich ist, dass vielleicht auch mal für euch,
die unschlüssig sind, ich glaube 42, nicht 45, ich glaube 42. Zumindest, was soll ich jetzt sagen?
Ja zumindest so eine Sache, die man da vielleicht für euch sich auch ableiten kann,
was man jetzt daran schön gesehen hat ist, es kann sich durchaus lohnen, in der IT oder auch
nicht in der IT, wenn man irgendwie so ein gefragtes Posi hat, den Job zu wechseln. Ich war weit davon
entfernt schlecht zu verdienen im alten Laden, muss man ja auch sagen. Es war aber trotzdem
eine Ecke weniger. Jetzt nicht ultra viel, aber es war eine Ecke weniger. Ich würde sagen so
25k in dem Dreh weniger, aber es ist schon ordentlich. Also überlegt euch mal, wenn ihr
eh schon mit dem Gedanken spielt, dass euch die aktuelle Firma auf den Sack geht, dafür hast
ihr jetzt Windows, stimmt. Stimmt, das müsste man eigentlich als schwerstes Geld als schwerstes
Geld betrachten. Zumindest, es kann sich für euch durchaus lohnen. Also wenn ihr eh schon keinen Bock
mehr auf die aktuelle Firma habt und es schadet nichts, wenn ihr euch mal ein bisschen umguckt.
Gerade im IT Bereich, hast du studiert? Ne, habe ich nicht. Ich habe mal eine Ausbildung gemacht vor
Uhrzeiten, Fachinformatiker, Systemintegration, ganz lange her, 15 Jahre her, 16 Jahre her,
bis ich da angefangen habe mit. Es kommt auf den Standort an, es kommt natürlich selbstverständlich,
Leute, das kann man jetzt nicht so allgemein sehen. Es kommt auf den Standort an, es kommt
auf die Branche an, es kommt auf die Lebenshaltungskosten in der Region an. Es ist
Frankfurt Finanzbranche ist eines der am höchst bezahltesten Branchengebiete, die es gibt in
Deutschland. Wenn man jetzt in die Schweiz guckt, ist das, was ich verdiene wahrscheinlich das,
was nichts gegen Sekretärinnen, was dort, also ich kenne eine, die Sekretärin ist in der Schweiz,
die hat ungefähr das gleiche verdient. Also das ist kein Ding. Das in der Schweiz ist das was
anderes. Liest du ab und zu mal Papers? Ja, bei Security-Sachen ab und zu mal. Würdest du mit
Studium mehr Geld bekommen? Nö. Es ist die Frage, wie du das meinst. Im Durchschnitt ja,
im Durchschnitt verdienen Leute, die studiert haben, mehr. Im Einzelfall muss das nicht der
Fall sein. Und wenn du jetzt persönlich konkret auf mich guckst, ob ich jetzt studiert habe,
oder nicht, ist für die Position vollkommen egal. Also ich würde das Gleiche bekommen,
wenn ich studiert habe, wie wenn ich nicht. Das ist denen vollkommen egal, ob ich studiert
habe. Ich habe die Skills für die Position. Ich mache die Arbeit für die Position. Ich mache die
Arbeit, hoffe ich, auch ganz gut für die Position, dass es darauf ankommt, ob ich da studiert habe
oder nicht. Also ich kriege nicht automatisch mehr, nur wenn ich studiert hätte. In Frankfurt hast
du auch ziemlich hohe Mietwohnkosten. Das kommt dazu, ja. Ja, je nach Gebiet sind 60k auch schon
richtig viel im Vergleich zu manch anderem. Das darf man immer nicht vergessen. Wir sind ja,
wie gesagt, auch vorher, wie gesagt, war ja nicht schlecht beim alten Arbeitgeber, was ich verdient
habe. Ist mir bewusst, dass es mehr ist, als viele andere Berufe verdienen und sicherlich auch mehr
ist oder beziehungsweise viele andere weniger verdienen, als sie verdient hätten. Also gerade
wenn ich Richtung Altenpflege, Krankenpflege, soziale Berufe und so was gucke, die Leute machen
sehr wichtige Sachen, auch sehr anstrengende Sachen, sowohl körperlich als auch psychisch
belastungsmäßig, auch mit wirklich hoher Verantwortung. Wenn du da Mist machst, können
Leute sterben, was bei mir nicht der Fall ist. Unterm Strich, es ist halt leider so,
dass dort, wo Kohle zu holen ist, auch mehr bezahlt wird. Das ist halt so, weil jetzt mal
seriously ist. Ich weiß, es klingt unmoralisch, deswegen sage ich auch explizit dazu, dass es
nicht meine persönliche Meinung ist, sondern ich nur denke, dass eben die Businesswelt so tickt.
Also, wenn du jetzt die Möglichkeit hast, einen Ausfall in einem IT-System zu vermeiden,
indem du qualifiziertes Fachpersonal einstellst und du hast ausgerechnet, also gehen wir mal von
irgendeinem Unternehmen, gehen wir von irgendeiner Bankversicherung, irgendwie sonst was, irgendeinem
Unternehmen aus. Dann gehen wir mal von aus, man arbeitet bei irgendeinem IT-Unternehmen und die
stellen Fachleute ein und mit dieser Expertise der Fachleute möchte man zum Beispiel vorbeugen,
dass wichtige IT-Systeme ausfallen. Man hat sich ausgerechnet, eine Stunde Ausfall von einem IT-System
kostet uns 5 Millionen Euro. Ich, made up, es ist einfach so random Zahlen im Kopf. Gehen wir mal
von dem Beispiel aus. 5 Millionen kostet eine Stunde Ausfall und irgendwelche schlauen Leute haben sich
dann überlegt, okay, wir können den Ausfall drastisch reduzieren, wenn wir ein paar Leute
mehr mit Know-how einstellen und wenn wir den Leuten für Rufbereitschaft noch extra Kohle in
Popo schieben, weil dann sind die Reaktionszeiten eben nicht irgendwie eine Stunde, sondern die
Reaktionszeiten sind vielleicht eine Viertelstunde und dann haben wir quasi 4 Millionen gespart. Das
heißt, wir rechnen das mal gegen so risikomäßig, okay, lasst uns mal zwei neue Leute einstellen für
120.000 Euro im Jahr, weil selbst wenn wir die nicht brauchen, für den einen Fall in 10 Jahren,
wo wir die brauchen, hat sich schon gelohnt. So in der Richtung, irgendwie muss ja so eine
Risikobewertung passieren. Das sind die einen, die stellen dann IT-Leute ein für 120.000 Euro im
Jahr, weil sie im Zweifelsfall unglaublich viel Geld sparen versus im Gesundheitswesen. Lasst
uns mal auch einen für 120.000 einstellen, der dafür sorgt, dass weniger Leute sterben. Was meint
ihr, wo die Leute mehr bereit sind, business-mäßig Geld auszugeben? Für 120.000 Euro für die IT-Leute,
die dafür sorgen, dass du keine 5 Millionen verlierst oder 120.000 Euro für ein paar Leute
im Gesundheitswesen, die dafür sorgen, dass weniger Leute sterben. Wo business-enterprise-mäßig,
wo wird lieber Geld in die Hand genommen? Ich weiß, es klingt wahnsinnig unmoralisch,
aber es ist auch nicht meine persönliche Überzeugung, dass man das so machen sollte,
aber was meint ihr, wo wird mehr Geld in die Hand genommen oder wo wird einfacher Geld in die
Hand genommen? Ich denke, bei den 5 Millionen Kosten verursachen, ist man viel schneller bereit im
business-enterprise-Umfeld, als wenn es um Menschenleben geht. Was du ja im Endeffekt auch daran siehst,
ist, wie schlecht teilweise im Gesundheitssystem Leute bezahlt werden. Wenn du dir anguckst,
wie die Arbeitsbedingungen dort sind, sowohl körperliche Belastung, man darf auch nicht die
psychische Belastung unterschätzen, die du hast, wenn du in einem Beruf arbeitest, wo du täglich
mitbekommst, wie Leute sterben an irgendwelchen Krankheiten. Arbeitspenden, Belastung, Schichtbetrieb
und dann werden die irgendwie mit 45k oder sonst was im Jahr abgespeist. Das ist halt schon der Witz
irgendwo, aber da ist man halt einfach auch anscheinend gesellschaftlich irgendwie nicht
bereit, weil letztendlich bezahlen wir das ja über Umwege, da mehr für zuzuteilen. Und im privaten
Sektor, wenn du bei irgendeiner Bank oder Versicherung oder sonst wo arbeitest, die sagen,
hey, wir können damit 5 Millionen sparen, wenn wir 2 IT-Leute für 120.000 Euro im Jahr einstellen,
dann machen die das. Da ist die Kohle halt da. Also im Prinzip sind den 5 Millionen, unterm Strich
muss ich sagen, okay, sind uns da Menschenleben nicht so viel wert. Ich sage wie gesagt, nicht,
meine persönliche Meinung ist, aber man sieht es. Tja und das ist fragwürdig schon, ob das so sein
muss, aber es ist halt aktuell so. Und man versucht ja auch die Leute im Gesundheitssystem abzuspeisen
mit, könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, wie die dann applaudiert
haben. Es ist ja nicht nur Gesundheitssystem, es ist ja viele, viele Sachen im sozialen Umfeld,
sei es Lehrer und sonst was. Ärzte verdienen ja auch einiges, ja, Moment mal, da muss man mal
wirklich was zu sagen. Es wird ja gerne auf Ärztegehälter rumgeschümpft und sicherlich
gibt es die ein oder anderen Schönheitschirurgen, die super krass Megakohle machen im Vergleich zu
anderen. Aber wenn man sich mal die Gehälter anguckt von einem Arzt, ja klar, die verdienen
viel, die verdienen mehr als ich, die verdienen ab einer gewissen Position mehr. Aber wenn man mal
so ein Chefarztgehalt oder so vergleicht, hey, da gibt es in so einem Krankenhaus nicht so wahnsinnig
viele von Positionen. Außerdem willst du da wirklich Qualifizierte haben und du musst auch
erst mal dahin kommen. Du musst mehrere Jahre Medizin studieren, was du nicht mal auf halbe
Arschpacke machst, ja. Du musst dir lange Jahre die Arbeitsbedingungen geben, den Schichtbetrieb
geben, die Anstrengungen geben und was du bei Ärzten tatsächlich nicht vergessen darfst,
was ich tatsächlich, wenn du mal Richtung Piloten und sonst was guckst, ja, und bei Ärzten aber noch
viel direkter, wenn die Scheiße bauen, kratzen Leute ab. Wenn ich Scheiße baue, haben wir einen
Ausfall, der vielleicht 5 Millionen die Stunde kostet, aber es kratzt niemand ab von. Wenn die
Scheiße bauen, sterben auch Leute, also da sollte man sich durchaus überlegen, möchte man nicht
auch ordentlich bezahlen für qualifiziertes Personal. Dass es in anderen Bereichen nicht so
ist, ist leider setbar true. Das ist auch so ein Punkt. Ich weiß das beispielsweise von meiner
Mutter. Meine Mutter war Krankenschwester früher, ist schon ganz lang nicht mehr. Die ist irgendwann
auch aus dem Krankenhaus weg, weil sie gesagt hat, das hält sie nicht mehr aus. Sowohl die
Belastung an sich von der Arbeit her, auch dass es ja ein seelisch anstrengender Job ist, da drin zu
arbeiten, darf man nicht vergessen, aber auch die ganzen Auflagen und Sticheleien und Stöcke,
die einem in den Weg geschmissen werden, dass sie gesagt hat, sie will das nicht mehr machen. Das
ist schon 30 Jahre her, mittlerweile ist das wahrscheinlich noch deutlich schlimmer. Ich kann
es verstehen, dass keiner in den Alterspflegebereich gehen möchte. Vielen Leuten dort geht es
tatsächlich, wie der Chat gesagt hat, gar nicht so sehr um mehr Geld, sondern um bessere
Arbeitsbedingungen. Aber das eine ergibt ja das andere. Bezahlst du mehr Geld, machen es mehr
Leute, du hast die Arbeit besser verteilt und die Arbeitsbedingungen werden besser. Wo auch immer du
in diesem Kreislauf ansetzt, unterm Strich läuft es immer auf mehr Geld raus. Weil mehr Geld heißt
ja auch, wenn du zwei Leute hinstellst, die den Job machen, dass dann die Arbeitsbedingungen werden,
kostet das ja auch mehr Geld. Es läuft im Prinzip immer auf mehr Geld raus.
Ja, auch geil. Gut, wir wollen jetzt nicht so sehr über unangenehme Themen in der
Richtung reden. Habe ich auch keinen Bock drauf. Ja, aber war das Video jetzt schon fertig? Ne.
Es macht jetzt schon kaum noch einer. Also ich möchte nicht später ins Altersheim müssen,
zumindest kein öffentliches Altersheim mit Mindestlohn und vorüber ein bisschen über
Mindestlohn. Da habe ich wirklich keinen Bock drauf. Und dass es nicht funktioniert, sieht man ja auch
schon daran. Es hat ja eine Zeit lang geklappt, dass das versucht wurde, gerade für Altenpfleger
und fürs Gesundheitssystem irgendwie Leute aus Polen und sonst wie anzuwerben. Aber ich glaube,
das funktioniert auch nicht mehr. Ich glaube, da haben immer weniger Bock drauf, das zu machen.
Das kommen auch immer weniger. Den Scheiß gebe ich mir nicht.
Ja, ich hoffe auch, dass es dann richtig geile Roboter gibt, bevor ich ins Altersheim muss.
Ja. Also weiter geht's.
Fährt 3200 Euro Netto. Mir persönlich ist Geld relativ unwichtig, wenn ich ehrlich sein soll.
Ich verdiene hauptsächlich mehr als ich brauche, aber ich bin auch weniger zufrieden. Alter,
wie viel von dem sein Brutto übrig bleibt, ist ja krasse. Einfach weil ich keine hohen
Ausgaben habe und ich habe auch keine hohen materiellen Ansprüche an das Leben. Also ich
schaue gar nicht, wie man Geld vermehren kann. Gar nicht. Ich habe noch nie in Aktien etwas
angelegt, auch nicht in Krypto. Das habe ich mittlerweile. Währung oder ähnliches,
außer halt in Festgeld Sachen, was jetzt aber wirklich keine Zinsen großartig abwirft.
Was machen, Sekunde, wo wir gerade dabei sind. Was machen eigentlich meine Stonks?
Dieses Jahr waren die ja nicht so geil. So, was machen meine Stonks? Lass mal kurz gucken.
Oh, oh, nee. Naja, nee, nee, nicht wirklich. Wenn ich raus scale hier auf dem Ding ist nicht so
geil. Also es ist immer noch Minus. Wie viel ist es denn jetzt? Gibt es das vielleicht auch in
Prozent? Nö. Also dieses Jahr waren die Stonks echt nicht so geil. Ja, ich habe nur ETFs.
Ich habe keine einzelnen Stonks. Einfach weil mir das nicht wichtig ist, dass es jetzt noch
viel mehr wird. Und ich bin jetzt auch jemand, der das Risiko eher schäut. Ja, Soldat. Ja,
korrekt. Allerdings nicht den MSCI World, sondern den. Aber es ist mehr oder weniger das gleiche.
Wie heißt denn das Ding? Wie man das hier in der App?
Vanguard FTSE All World UCITS ETF USD Accumulating. Alles klar. Stonks.
Bis morgen. Schön verärmt. Toss Musik. Toss. Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss. Kommt auch
ein bisschen zur Ruhe. Man fühlt sich da einfach so ein bisschen geborgen. Toss. Alter, hör auf mit
Toss Musik. Das ist ja schrecklich. Ich will erst mal eine Runde gebetet. Prager. Leute, Prager
Time. Um mich so ein bisschen von dem zu entkoppeln, was so die normale in Anführungsstrichenwelt ist
und sich so ein bisschen mal zurückzunehmen und sich zu hinterfragen, was ist eigentlich das
wirklich Wichtige im Leben? Das ist einmal mein Glaube und meine Familie. Also meine,
nicht meine eigene Familie mit eigenen Kindern, sondern meine Familie, meine Geschwister,
meine Eltern. Persönlich könnte ich mir jetzt aktuell keine Familie vorstellen,
weil mir einfach meine persönliche Freude
ist. Exzellent. Was sagst du zu einer Fortbildung zum IT Projektleiter mit Blick
auf die Zukunft? Also für mich auf gar keinen Fall. Für dich weiß ich nicht,
wenn es dir Spaß macht. Wobei ich mich immer frage, was man bei einem Projektleiter groß
fortbildern kann, was man da lernt in so einer Fortbildung. Aber gibt es, hat sicherlich seinen
Sinn. Ich hätte ja auf Projektleitung gar keinen Bock. Ja, gibt es tatsächlich schon Clips dafür.
So komm, eine Sache gucken wir uns so an. Was haben wir denn sonst hier zu bieten noch?
I tried more AI tools, it gets crazier. Top 5 fastest programming languages. Oh, 21 Minuten,
ne, ne, ne. So startest du dein Smart Home in 2023. Okay, auf geht's. Leute, ich muss mal ganz kurz.
Ich bin gleich wieder da. Ich muss mal ganz kurz pinkeln.
Ich bin gleich wieder da. Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Leute, ich habe extra nochmal nachgeguckt, dass ich euch kein Mist erzählt habe.
Ich habe eben gesagt, es wären 3700 Euro brutto. Das stimmt überhaupt nicht. Es sind knapp 3400,
nicht brutto, netto. Es sind nicht 3700 Euro netto. Es sind also für vier Tage Woche. Es sind
3400 Euro netto nur. Aber da ist noch nicht der ganze Bonus drin. Also wahrscheinlich habe ich
euch gar kein Mist erzählt. Und ich habe gesehen, die App von der Arbeit hat ein Osterupdate bekommen.
Es gibt jetzt nämlich noch einen dritten Reiter. Also es gibt auf dem Firmen iPhone, was ich habe,
gibt es so eine App, wo man gucken kann, Abrechnungszeiten, Gehalt und sowas in der
Rechnung. Habe ich extra gerade nochmal nachgeguckt, dass ich euch kein Mist erzähle. Es gab ein
Osterupdate. Es gab ein Osterupdate. Nein, das steht jetzt drunter. Ihr Nettogehalt ist das und das.
Das sind 850 Schoko-Osterhasen. Da war jemand besonders lustig. Aber das müssen auch schon
die guten Lindt-Schoko-Osterhasen sein, oder? Ah, das ist was. Wie viel kostet so einer?
What? Ah, nee, Goldhasen. Okay, vier Euro. Das kommt tatsächlich ungefähr hin.
Ich finde es auch nicht schlecht. Ich finde die Idee gar nicht blöd. Ich finde es sehr witzig,
dass sie sogar ein Osterupdate für die Personalabteilungs-App machen.
Nee, das Updaten passiert automatisch. Das Device ist komplett managt.
Deswegen benutze ich das Handy von der Firma auch für nichts, außer für Sachen von der Firma.
Ja, mindestens so. Nee, das kenne ich nicht. Vielleicht hat YouTube mal wieder ein Bug im
Interface. Ich kenne nur das, dass es abspielt, wenn man drüber hovert. Aber durchaus möglich.
YouTube hat öfters mal Bugs im Frontend. Die sind einfach way too agile, um keine Bugs zu
haben. Ich glaube, die sind einfach nur viel zu groß und planlos, was sie machen. Ich glaube,
ganz ehrlich, nach außen hin sieht es viel geiler aus, für Google zu arbeiten,
als wenn man wirklich für Google arbeitet. Ein bisschen Hinweise gibt es ja auch darauf,
dass die Leute nicht länger als eineinhalb Jahre im Durchschnitt bei Google bleiben.
Die haben einfach keinen Bock drauf mehr. Der hat seine eigene Consulting-Bude.
Wundert mich nicht. Vielleicht wollte er dich ja anwerfen. Okay, dann gucken wir jetzt noch
mal ein Witt. Und zwar schauen wir uns mal an, was er dazu meint. Video hat nicht viele Views,
keine Comments. Mal gucken, ob das was zu bedeuten hat. Der Schlaumeier erklärt,
so startest du dein Smart Home in 2023. Bevor wir uns das Video angucken, ich sage euch jetzt mal
in 5 Minuten oder ganz in 2 Minuten, wie ich ein Smart Home starten würde 2023. Das allererste,
bevor man überhaupt startet mit Smart Home, ist, sich Gedanken dazu machen, was man eigentlich
machen will. Will man eher einfach ein bisschen was zum rumbasteln haben, hat man ein konkretes Ziel,
was man machen will. Möchte man zum Beispiel Notifications von seinem Garagentor bekommen und
sonstige Geschichten. Und das ist das allererste, was man sich tatsächlich angucken sollte,
mal Smart Home Sachen vergleichen. Also Open Source Smart Home Sachen vergleichen. Man
sollte gar nicht damit anfangen, mit Herstellerproprietären Apps als Hauptinteraktionszentrale
mit seinem Smart Home. Es muss irgendwie so eine Meta Home Smart Home Geschichte sein. So
was wie Home Assistant zum Beispiel oder so was wie oder Open Hub oder Home, nee nee nee nicht
Home, IO Broker und so was in der Richtung. Wenn man die Möglichkeit hat, das ist das nächste,
genau, Meta ist ja nur das Protokoll, also nicht die Zentrale, worüber du das bedienst. Wenn du
die Möglichkeit hast, dein Haus zu verkabeln, ist natürlich Porg. Und dann kann man sich
verschiedene Technologien aus. Aber gucken wir mal. Welche Plattform? Also schauen wir uns das mal an.
Ich bin Marcel und heute sage ich dir, wie du in 2023 dein Smart Home am besten starten kannst. Los geht's.
Smart Home ist ein Thema, was uns bereits seit über 20 Jahren begleitet. Am berühmtesten ist
wohl das Video von Microsoft, welches 1999 rausgekommen ist, wie sich das Unternehmen
ein Smart Home vorstellte und viele Dinge davon sind auch wirklich eingetroffen.
Eine wichtige Entscheidung, die du treffen solltest, ist natürlich die Wahl der Plattform.
Kennt ihr das Video? Plattform. Wollen wir das mal gucken? 1990, Microsoft. Nicht solitär,
wenn man das noch richtig schreiben könnte. Smart Home. Home of the Future. Microsoft,
das können wir uns irgendwann mal angucken. Okay, auf geht's. Welche Plattform? Und ich
würde nicht sagen, am Anfang mit System, man sollte sich überlegen, über welchen
Funkstandard man seine Geräte vernetzt, das auch, sondern welchen der, welche der
Plattformen man verwenden will. Und zu steuern. Selbstverständlich gibt es da die drei großen
Amazon, Apple und Google. Aber es gibt auch Systeme, die dir mehr Freiheiten bieten,
dafür aber etwas fummeliger sind, wie zum Beispiel Home Assistant. Home Assistant. Wie heißt dieser
Typ, der immer dieses Home Assistant-Meme einspielt? Home Assistant. Home Assistant.
Home. Vielleicht wisst ihr, was ich meine. Wie heißt der? Paul? Paul? Warte mal. Das ist egal,
jetzt. Keine Ahnung. Um nur einige zu nennen. Diese sind doch eher an Nützeln. Ich meine den
Klatschkopf, Dude. Genau, genau. Ich weiß, wie heißt der denn? Warte mal. Smart Home Paul,
irgendwas Paul? Lena? Ja. Okay. Home Assistant. Ich weiß nicht, wo das drin ist. This week's
video. Keine Ahnung, wie man das jetzt findet. Ja genau, bloß mit Sound jetzt noch. Bloß mit
Sound noch.
Okay, keine Ahnung. Keine Ahnung. Zumindest, der springt manchmal rum und schreit irgendwas
von Home Assistant. Irgendwie ist mir das gerade so in den Kopf gekommen. Alter, was trinken?
Ja, hast recht. Jetzt darfst du nicht in jedem Video drehen. Ja, ich find's jetzt auf die Schnelle
nicht. Ich hab was getrunken. Pog. Auftrag erfüllt, Chat.
Wenn du ein Android-Handy hast und zu Apple wechselst, weil das ist halt nicht so einfach.
Wenn du aber ein Android-Handy hast, wär's natürlich intelligent, wenn du auch Google
Assistant benutzt und da dann die ganzen Smart-Handy. Nee, hör mal auf. Ich meine,
ich hab' ein iPhone, ich verwende weder Siri, na doch, ich muss Siri verwenden wegen CarPlay,
aber ich verwende normalerweise kein Siri und ich verwende auch kein Apple Home oder
weiß gar nicht, wie der HomeKit heißt das, glaub ich. Ich geh mal bloß weg, Alter. Never.
Hier ist natürlich auch eine blöde Idee. Also als Hub, ja als zusätzlicher Voice Assistant
kann man das machen, wenn man da drauf steht. In irgendein System nicht so tief ist, wie es
bei iOS oder Android der Fall ist. Dafür ist Alexa in der Regel um einiges günstiger. Aber
welches System solltest du jetzt nutzen? Meiner Erfahrung nach bietet HomeKit und Alexa den
einfachsten Einstieg. Sie nehmen dich an die Hand und zeigen dir was Mögliches. Außerdem bieten sie
dir auch manchmal Automationsvorschläge an, die du dann gleich einfach übernehmen kannst,
ohne groß fummeln zu müssen. Die Qual der Wahl liegt ganz bei dir. Ich fummel aber gerne an
der Technik rum. Deswegen mag ich Home Assistant. Es müssen natürlich auch Geräte her. Die ersten
Geräte, die ich dir vorschlagen würde anzuschaffen, sind smarte Leuchtmittel. Diese sind relativ
günstig. Nein, siehste, siehste, das ist genau das. Ohne Scheiß, ich würd's anders machen.
Natürlich ist es deine persönliche Meinung, alles gut. Würde ich nicht machen, weil,
und das habe ich schon oft gesagt, ich würde nicht mit Beleuchtung anfangen, weil die meisten
Leute am Anfang, was Smart Home und Beleuchtung angeht, überhaupt kein richtiges Händchen dafür
haben. Die kaufen sich dann Philips Hue in der Top-Ausstattung und dann hast du an jedem
Furzding RGB. Das brauchst du nicht. Das brauchst du nicht. Was man braucht ist, also erstmal braucht
man eh an den wenigsten Stellen überhaupt smarte Lampen. An den meisten Stellen tut es eine
stinknormale Lampe für Licht im Zimmer. Dort, wo das sinnvoll ist. Leute im Wohnzimmer zum
Beispiel, weil es gerade einer im Chat schreibt, die irgendwie so Atmosphäre beim Fernsehen gucken
haben wollen, welche, die eine Nachtbeleuchtung im Flur haben wollen, alles kein Ding. Oder in
der Küche oder im Wohnzimmer. Es gibt ja verschiedene Anwendungszenarien, aber es ist ganz selten sinnvoll,
tatsächlich eine RGB-Lampe hinzupappen, weil RGB bedeutet, ja, du kannst auch den Raum pink machen
oder grün machen oder sonst was. Das will man an den wenigsten Stellen machen. Es gibt da mehrere
Abstufungen von smarten Lampen. Ich sage Lampen, ich weiß, die coolen Leute sagen Leuchtmittel und
RGB ist scheiß teuer, gerade wenn es Philips Hue und Zeug ist. Da gibt es sogar witzige Sachen.
So, das Erste, was die meisten Leute noch haben wollen, ist, dass man die Lampen remote an- und
ausschalten kann. Zum Remote an- und ausschalten, wenn das euer einziger Anwendungszweck ist, zum
Remote ein- und ausschalten der Lampen, würde ich gar keine smarte Lampe einbauen. Weil das Dumme
ist, an smarten Lampen, sie müssen permanent mit Strom versorgt sein, dass sie smart sein können.
Und wenn ihr noch so eine alte, so eine Oldschool-Fassung in der Decke habt und ein Lichtschalter an der Wand
und dann drückt jemand auf den Lichtschalter drauf, dann ist der Strom von der Lampe aus und die Lampe
ist auch nicht mehr smart. Das heißt, das Erste, was man machen muss, um seine Beleuchtung smart zu
machen, also auch die Deckenbeleuchtung ist, man sollte sich überlegen, ob man nicht so was wie
einen Shelley oder einen Sonoff oder sonst was, so die kleinen Unterputz-Sonoff-Dinger, in den
Lichtschalter einbaut, sodass der Lichtschalter gar nicht mehr wirklich die Lampe abschaltet,
sondern nur noch den Relay triggert, der dann das Schalten vornimmt. So, das ist schonmal das Erste.
Wenn man das haben möchte, ist man in 80% der Fälle mit seiner Deckenbeleuchtung eigentlich schon
glücklich. Der nächste Fall ist, es soll dimmbar sein, also Remote-Ein-Ausschalt. Nächste Fall,
es soll dimmbar sein. Dimmer gibt es auch für normale Lampen, aber angenommen möchte man
extra Lampen kaufen, dimmbar. Ist das so? Warum? Also gerade mit den Shelley-Dingern, die haben
ja zig Ausführungen, wüsste ich jetzt nicht, wo das nicht gehen soll und die neuen sind auch
noch ein Stückchen kleiner. Ja gut, mag sein. Man muss es ja auch nicht selbst machen. Ich
würde da selbst, auch wenn man keine Ahnung hat, auch nicht dran gehen. Das nächste ist dimmbar.
Das geht, du kannst die Schalter austauschen. Ja, das würde theoretisch auch funktionieren.
Das nächste ist, dass die das Licht eben einstellen wollen, wie hell es ist,
also dass die Lampe dimmbar ist. Das ist auch eigentlich so die Einstiegssache,
was smarte Lampen angeht. Die sind auch relativ günstig. Also eine normale Lampe, die dimmbar ist,
die kostet nur einen Bruchteil einer RGB-Lampe. Die nächste Steigerung, die auch noch oftmals
sinnvoll ist, also wenn man jetzt Sachen hat, die man remote an- und ausschalten kann und dimmen
kann, hat man meistens schon 90 Prozent der Wünsche an smarte Lampen abgedeckt. Die nächste
Steigerung davon ist, remote an- und ausschaltbar, dimmbar und Farbtemperatur bzw. Lichttemperatur
anpassbar. Die sind auch noch eine ganze Ecke billiger als vollständige RGB-Lampen und damit
hat man 95 Prozent seiner Wünsche angepasst, weil damit kann man auch, wenn man beispielsweise
im Wohnzimmer abends eher rötliches Licht haben will und eher weißes, pläuliches Licht morgens
haben will, das schon machen. Das ist keine RGB-Lampe, das ist alles noch günstiger,
das ist dimmbar und das ist eine Lampe, die hat eine weiße LED und meistens eine rote LED dabei,
also das ist nun die Hälfte von RGB und die sind auch günstiger und damit hat man 95 Prozent seiner
smarten Lampen Anforderungen eigentlich schon abgedeckt. Remote an- und ausschaltbar, dimmbar
und Lichttemperatur anpassbar. Die nächste Steigerung und die letzte Steigerung ist tatsächlich eine
volle RGB-Lampe. Okay, das geht, aber das braucht man wirklich nur dort, wo man auch was, wo man den
Raum mal grün machen will, komplett blau machen will, pink machen will, was auch immer und das
will man eigentlich an den seltenen Stellen. Das kannst du vielleicht ab, das kannst du an ein paar
Fingern abzählen, dass vielleicht 1, 2, 3 Stellen im Haus wo du das wirklich haben willst und es
gibt noch theoretisch eine vierte Steigerung. Es gibt manche smarten Lampen, die können auch
Infrarotlicht als man das braucht. Das kann sinnvoll sein, wenn man beispielsweise eine Kamera bei
sich im Flur hat oder Kamera im Haus hat und nachts das Licht aushaben will, aber möchte,
dass die Nachtsicht von der Kamera gut funktioniert und die Kamera-LEDs aus irgendwelchen Gründen von
der Kamera selbst nicht dafür ausreichend sind. Dann kann das sinnvoll sein, dass man auch noch
eine hat, die Infrarotlicht machen kann. Dann wird es aber richtig teuer, wenn du sowas in
Kombination hast. Kannst du auch durchaus mal 80 Euro pro Lampe ausgeben.
...gesehen von Philips Hue und bieten dir den Vorteil, dass du keine ganzen Systeme kaufen musst,
sondern einfach nur... Muss man mit Home Assistant auch nicht,
da kannst du fast alles zusammen integrieren, wie man will.
... oder Lampen. Gerade Anbieter wie Ikea oder Lidl Smart Home bieten dir gute und günstige
Alternative zu Philips Hue und Konsorten. Diese Leuchtmittel sind in der Regel dimmbar und können
zwischen warm und weiß hin und her geschärft werden. Richtig, das reicht meistens schon.
Es gibt natürlich auch Lichter, die farbig sind. Die sind aber meistens etwas teurer und das ist
natürlich eine Geschmackssache. Sind wir uns einig? Ja, seh ich auch so.
Und ob man sie einsetzen möchte. Außerdem arbeiten die Marken von Ikea und Lidl mit dem
Funkstandard Zigbee zusammen. Zigbee! Oh, ne Zigbee!
Er hat ja sogar den Typ eingeblendet, lol. Und können so automatisch in den großen
Echo eingebunden werden, weil dieser über einen eingebauten Zigbee hat.
Weird Champ. Da wir jetzt schon ein paar Lampen
und eine gemütliche Atmosphäre haben, kommen wir gleich zum nächsten Punkt. Gerade jetzt lohnt es
sich mehr denn je auf ein smartes Thermostat zu setzen, denn die Preise für Gas und Strom sind
ganz schön in die Höhe getrieben. Da hat er recht, hat er prinzipiell recht.
Ich denke trotzdem nicht, dass es was bringt, weil wenn man mal ausrechnet,
ab wann man was spart, also wie teuer die Thermostate sind und die brauchen auch regelmäßig
Batterien und Zeug, bis man das wieder eingespart hat, was man damit erstmal ausgegeben hat. Ich
glaube, das ist eine Rechnung, die geht bei den meisten Leuten nicht auf.
Und knabbern arg in unseren Portemonnaies. Smartes Thermostate können aber nicht nur
per Sprache oder per Automation gesteuert werden, sondern du kannst auch Heizprofile
und ähnliches anlegen. Man kann schon sinnvolle Sachen machen, z.B. wenn der Fenstersensor erkennt,
dass das Fenster auf ist, dass die Heizung ausgeht. Das geht alles, aber das ist alles so im Bereich,
wo ich sagen würde, meistens lohnt es sich nicht, also die Anschaffungskosten wirst du
damit in nächster Zeit nicht wieder reinbekommen. Hier gibt es natürlich eine Vielzahl von
Herstellern und die bekanntesten sind wahrscheinlich Hormetic IP und Tado. Die Installation ist sehr
einfach und ich habe selber auch geschafft und ich bin wirklich handwerklich nicht begabt. Wenn
du da aber keine Lust drauf hast, wenn man schon eine Fritzbox hat, ist tatsächlich auch sehr
simpel. Oder ist die nicht zutraus oder wie auch immer, kannst natürlich gerne einen Fachmann
fragen und die machen das dann für dich. Ja, das Anbauen ist wirklich easy. Also Thermostate
ist wirklich easy. Das kriegt jeder gebacken. Du brauchst eine Zange, wenn es zu fest ist,
um das abzuschrauben. Das ist wirklich einfach. Du kannst auch nichts kaputt machen. Selbst wenn
du die abschraubst, da spritzt kein Wasser oder so aus der Heizung. Es passiert gar nichts,
wenn du das Thermostat abschraubst. Außer, dass die Heizung auf volle Pulle geht. Okay,
nee, äh, warte mal. Nee, dass die Heizung ausgeht, nicht auf volle Pulle.
Keine SmartLogs, keine SmartLogs. Ja, die habe ich auch. Ja, die habe ich auch. Ich habe aber
eine Mischung. Ich habe billige Akara-Sensoren und noch ein bisschen ältere Z-Wave-Sensoren,
weil warum soll ich die austauschen? Die gehen halt.
Das heißt, wenn zum Beispiel keiner zu Hause ist, aber der Kontakt dann so an der Wohnungstür
bemerkt, dass sie aufgeht, werden automatisch überall alle Lampen auf 100 Prozent gestellt
und die Homepots in der Wohnung gehen auf 100 Prozent und machen unnötig laute Töne.
Ja, ist ja gut. In Sachen Sicherheitskameras hast du eine große Auswahl von Ring,
Eufy, Akara und viele weitere. Aber auch hier sei gesagt, jeder Hersteller hat seine Vor- und
Nachteile. Ich persönlich benutze Ring-Kameras bei uns zu Hause, weil wir damals mit Alexa
angefangen haben und diese sich nahtlos in die Systeme einbinden lassen, weil Ring ja auch
Ring kommt mir nicht ins Haus. Auf gar keinen Fall, Alter. Eine Amazon-Firma ist. Der Nachteil
an Ring ist natürlich, dass man ein Protect-Abo braucht, damit man Aufnahmen und Livestreams
speichert. Ja, und dass wahrscheinlich mein Zeug irgendwie in die Cloud geht. Und dass ich
ein Abo brauche, um mir das überhaupt richtig zu benutzen. Nee, da habe ich wirklich keinen Bock
drauf. Nee. Darum soll es gerade gar nicht gehen. Also Ring zu der Ring-Sticker-Kamera,
was nur eine Kamera aus dem Portfolio ist, habe ich hier oben ein Video gemacht und kommen wir
auch gleich zur nächsten Kategorie. Inzwischen gibt es viele Haushaltsgeräte. Wisst ihr, was das
beste Haushaltsgerät ist? Das, was zuverlässig funktioniert, das braucht keine Smart-Funktionen
haben, weil das meiste, was man braucht bei einem Haushaltsgerät, ist das Ein- und Ausschalten. Und
das Ein- und Ausschalten, das kann man meistens auch über irgendwelche Zwischensteckdosen lösen.
Ja, also zum Beispiel bei einer Waschmaschine oder bei einem Wäschetrockner und sowas in der
Richtung. Das muss eigentlich gar nicht smart sein. Klar, es gibt ein paar Funktionen so nach dem Motto,
wann ist die Wäsche fertig, dass ich einen Timer angezeige. Wie auch immer gibt es das
Möglichkeiten, aber das meiste braucht man gar nicht. Volle und nicht so sinnvolle Haushaltsgeräte,
die dir das Leben erleichtern. Also smarte Kühlschränke. Von der Küchenwaage über
Kaffeemaschinen. Also smarte Kühlschränke sind zum größten Teil wasted. Saugroboter,
Kühlschränke, Öfen, Spülmaschinen und so weiter und so fort. Diese können dir einen Mehrwert
bieten, indem sie sich darüber benachrichtigen, dass die Waschmaschine fertig ist oder die
Spülmaschine fertig ist, dass der Kühlschrank wieder aufgefüllt werden muss, dir die Wohnung
saugen und wischen oder pünktlich morgens den Kaffee zubereiten. Aber gerade was Saugroboter
angeht, kann ich dir aus eigener Erfahrung sagen, du solltest nicht den Fennigfuchser spielen und
dich etwas mehr erkundigen. Ja, also wenn man Saugroboter haben will, da lohnt es sich tatsächlich die
etwas besseren zu kaufen, nämlich die, die eine automatische Entleerungsstation haben. Ansonsten
macht es nämlich echt keinen Bock. Ich habe das ausprobiert mit dem Staubsaugerroboter. Ich habe
einen Roborock S5, was sehr nice war, weil den konnte man mit Custom Firmware flashen,
ohne Entsorgungsstation und ich war zu faul, Leute. Das war mir zu anstrengend, da immer auf die Erde
und das Ding hochzuheben und auszuleeren. Ich sauge lieber von Hand ab und zu mal anstatt mit
dem Staubsaugerroboter. Hätte ich einen mit Entsorgungsstation und einen, der keine
China-Chinesen-Cloud-Internetverbindung die ganze Zeit braucht, dann würde ich mir das nochmal
überlegen. Was diese Geräte wirklich können, weil ich habe inzwischen zwei smarte Saugroboter
und die funktionieren nach dem Chaos-Prinzip. Das heißt, sie fahren kreuz und quer durch die
ganze Wohnung. Das haben die alten Dinger von Eufy gemacht, das war auch Mist. Da lassen sie
ganze Räume aus und da sollte man wirklich ein bisschen mehr Geld in der Hand nehmen und zu
Dreamy oder zu Roborock wechseln, weil diese haben eingebaute Leidertürme auf den Staubsaugern oben
drauf. Oder Kameras, die deine Wohnung filmen und an die China-Cloud schicken. Wo sie hinfahren müssen
und wo sie noch nicht waren. Nimm dir also die Zeit und ein bisschen mehr Geld in die Hand und
kauf dir gleich das Richtige, bevor du den Mist machst, den ich jetzt habe. Das stimmt, da hat er
recht. Wenn man sowas haben will und einen mit Entsorgungsstation. Ohne Entsorgungsstation würde
ich mir keinen mehr holen. Das habe ich gelernt aus meinem letzten. Natürlich gibt es auch noch
Unmengen an Kategorien und Subkategorien von smarten Geräten. So gibt es zum Beispiel auch
noch smarte Stecker oder Steckerleisten, die nicht schlaue Geräte in schlaue Geräte verwandeln können
beziehungsweise sie ein und ausschalten. Smarte Steckdosen ist eigentlich eines der praktischsten
Sachen ever. Es gibt auch noch Fingerbots beispielsweise von der Firma SwitchBot. Oh,
die sind auch nice. Ohne Scheiß, davon habe ich auch zwei. An Stellen, wo sonst gar nichts geht,
aber man mit irgendwas drücken muss, sind die SwitchBot-Dinger sehr pogu. Wie sieht das mit
dem Wischen aus? Habe ich nie benutzt. Ich habe zwar einen Roborock S5, der hat so einen Lappen,
aber nachdem, dass ich auch noch wechseln müsste, hatte ich da wirklich keinen Bock drauf. Also es
gibt die Möglichkeit bei den ganz neuen, die können irgendwie auch das Wasser entleeren und auffüllen.
Aber ich bin der Meinung, für Nasswischen sind die Roboter immer noch nicht das Beste.
Eingebauten Finger, die Knöpfe drücken können und somit auch dumme Geräte smart machen können.
Natürlich gibt es noch unzählig viele andere Kategorien wie Setup-Boxen, Smart-TVs,
Smart-Speaker, Rollo-Motoren und so weiter und so fort. Aber das Hinzufügen dieser
Geräte ist ja nicht alles. Und da kommen Automation ins Spiel. Ja, aber bitte nicht über Alexa.
Mit Automationen hast du die Möglichkeit, ein oder mehrere Geräte gleichzeitig zu steuern
und das anhand von verschiedenen Auslösern, zum Beispiel nach Uhrzeit,
nach Sensorstatus. Das interessiert mich jetzt nicht. Meta, Meta hat noch nicht so richtig.
Als interessierter Mensch wirst du wahrscheinlich schon mal über den Begriff Meta gestoßen sein.
Hier behandelt es sich um einen neuen Standard, der alle Geräte, die Meta zertifiziert sind,
auch in alle Systeme, die es gibt, einbinden kann. Da Meta aber gerade einmal in der Version 1.0
gestartet ist, wird es wohl noch einige Zeit dauern, bis wir einfach alle Geräte, die wir haben wollen,
in unseren Warenkorb packen müssen und uns keine Gedanken darüber machen, ob sie nun funktionieren.
Die Hersteller stehen auf proprietäre Erweiterung. Ich weiß nicht, ob das bei Meta...
Oder nicht. Wenn du aber zukunftssicher handeln möchtest und dir jetzt schon smarte Geräte
zulegen möchtest, die zukunftssicher sind, dann solltest du auf jeden Fall schauen,
ob es Hersteller gibt, die schon Meta-Geräte angekündigt oder ein Upgrade auf bestehende
Geräte angeboten haben. Du kannst doch auch Meta über Zigbee machen, oder nicht?
Mein Meta ist ja nur das obendrüber. Es spricht ja nichts dagegen, das über Zigbee zu machen.
Neuen Funk-Standard Thread unterstützen, sollten zukunftssicher sein und nur wenige
Ausnahmen erhalten kein Meta-Update, wie zum Beispiel irgendwelche Nanoleaf-Lampen.
Ja, die sind ja auch nicht teuer genug. Kosten ja nur für ein paar Lampen 300 Euro.
Ich hoffe, ich konnte dir mit diesem Video helfen, wie du dein Smarttum in 2023 starten kannst.
Ja, wie beim letzten Video, ich sehe einige Sachen anders.
Die ersten sind bei Meta auch schon wieder ausgestiegen. Wundert mich alles nicht.
Also zukunftssicher ist da nichts.
Zukunftssicher ist da nichts.
Das gucken wir jetzt nicht, aber bestes Tagesgeld. Vielleicht geht das besser als meine Stonks,
weil meine Stonks sind dieses Jahr nur gefallen.
Naja, egal. Leute, ich geh jetzt was essen. Ich hab Hunger. 12.19. Voll gut. Ich war jetzt
fast vier Stunden on, das reicht. Genug für heute. Vielleicht bin ich nachher noch mal
on. Mal gucken. Dann ein bisschen Technik, Bastel, Bastel-Kram. Alles klar, bis denn,
Leute. Ich bin weg. CU, macht's gut.